in today's era the internet and
smartphones have become an integral part
of our lives we use our phones for
almost all of our day-to-day tasks
earlier we used to shop at malls queue
up in front of banks and make our travel
bookings at travel agencies but now we
can do all this in the comfort of our
homes using smartphones all of this is
possible because of a high level
programming language called java hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class based object oriented programming
language java
java is an object oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a
high-level language that is easy to read
and understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded assistance apart from
these java is also used to develop
software for devices it is used not only
in computers and mobiles but even in
electronic devices like televisions
washing machines air conditioners and so
on online forms banking and shopping are
possible because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991.
he had a single moto while creating the
language it was right once run anywhere
this meant that the code would have to
be written only once but it could be
used anywhere they named this language
oak because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named to
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995.
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
core libraries like java.lang java.tutil
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an object oriented programming
language based on c and c plus however
it is improved and simplified to solve
the errors in programming java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the java
interpreter the whole java code is run
on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class
classes are used to organize code just
like how fruits vegetables and clinical
products are divided into different
sections in a supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling this
makes java very unique the most popular
feature of java is that it is platform
independent here compilation happens in
byte code and because of this java can
run on any machine it is a very secure
language as it contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data the next
feature is inheritance as the name
suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ
so in this tutorial mr vikesh pandey our
training expert with more than 12
successful years of real-time experience
in software development and along with
that he has an expertise in artificial
intelligence and machine learning
industry so he will be helping you out
in learning the fundamentals of java
with a detailed theoretical explanation
along with practical examples so that
you can have a better learning
experience
now over to our training expert hello
guys this is vikesh and let's get
started with the first topic of this
series which is about introduction
to java so when we talk about java it is
one of the most popular programming
language out there and it was created
way back in 1991 but it was publicly
released only in 1995
it was developed by one of the famous
developers of our generation who is
james gosling at sun microsystems and
then later java was acquired by oracle
and today oracle owns java java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different aspects of how it is easy
and simple to use it's a write once run
anywhere type of programming language
again we will look at details into into
into this particular concept as well and
when we talk about the usage of java you
can use it to build web applications
mobile applications desktop applications
even command line applications and at
the same time you can also use it to
build complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's a object oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in java happens
around objects
objects enable the execution of the
program objects talk to each other to
exchange data and messages we will look
at a look at the concept of objects in
details in the upcoming lectures
it's a platform independent language
which means that
again going back to the previous point
of write once run anywhere
it basically enables the program to be
run on any platform once compiled so
once you have prepared your program and
you have compiled your program then your
compile program can be run on any
platform it is a strong type checking
language which means that it will
force you to respect the contracts of
the variables to the data types for
example if you have created a collection
which should accept strings then
you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly type
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a java compiler and you have a java
interpreter you first compile your
program and then you run the program
using the help of java interpreter java
also provides automatic garbage
collection it's a really important
feature and if you talk about the
languages prior to java like c or c plus
plus they did not offer this capability
and this capability made java really
popular because it could automatically
find the unused objects and variables
and remove them from the memory to free
up memory space for the program
execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so this they can be one
thread which is monitoring your
leaderboard score there can be another
thread which is displaying the speed of
the car there can be another thread
which is displaying the graphic there
can be another thread which is
displaying the sound so you see all of
these threads are working parallelly and
java provides the support to create such
applications using the multi-threading
capability it has java is secure by
default because there are no pointers in
java so there are no possibilities of
having any memory leaks or any reference
leaks from the application again if you
take the example of programming
languages like c or c plus plus you had
the concept of pointers and we we
witnessed lot of a lot of scenarios and
a lot of incidents where there was a
memory leakage happening in the in the
production application which was which
was really a bad experience for the
organizations so java removed the
concept of pointers totally from its
programming language it's also a very
robust language because it provides a
really great exception handling
framework out of the box which
developers can use and implement to
build really resilient applications
so now let us understand how a java
program is run so at first you basically
write your java program and you store
your java program into a dot java file
then you compile your java file with the
help of the java compiler once the
program is compiled the compiler is
going to generate another file which is
a dot class file and this dot class file
is basically the compiled file or also
known as the byte code file so this byte
code or the dot class file code can be
run on any platform be it a linux
platform or a windows platform or a
macos platform or any other platform to
give you some more context the first two
steps where you write your java program
and you compile your java program can be
run on any machine let's take the
example that you ran these two steps on
a windows machine so you ran your you
write your program and you compile your
program on a windows machine which
generated a dot class file then you
transported this dot class file to a
linux machine and it also worked there
you transported your class file to a mac
os machine and it worked there as well
and that's what brings the platform
independence concept of java that you
can write the program once
on any platform
and once you have the bytecode available
then you can run this program on any
other platform of your choice
okay so that was about how the java
program execution works and how the
platform independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download java and install java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for java development
kit so the java development kit is the
installation of the java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like java
runtime environment or jre java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other supporting libraries so let
us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can
run that dot class file using gre in
fact if you just run your program on
your local machine jre will
automatically kick in and run your dot
class file so the java runtime
environment or jre runs your dot class
file with the help of these three
components let's talk about first
component which is java virtual machine
or jvm so the java virtual machine is
actually the virtual environment inside
which your program runs this is the real
main environment inside your dot class
file is running so when
when this program is running how does it
achieves this environment for achieving
this virtual virtual machine environment
it would need some runtime libraries and
that is provided by these class
libraries for example there would be a
runtime jar or rt.jar as a shorthand
which will be supplied to the program at
the runtime to make sure that the
program runs smoothly then there are
other supporting libraries as well which
your program may be using for example if
this program this dot class file is
let's say a calculator program
then it might be using a square root
function from java.math package so how
do how does the java.math package gets
supplied at runtime it would be supplied
by the other supporting libraries which
are present inside gre so jre will make
sure that your program runs inside the
java virtual machine it gets the
required runtime libraries and it also
gets the libraries which are referred in
your program at runtime and this all
together will make sure that your
program is running so you can see jdk
basically
provides gre automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
gre separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
installed the jre you don't install jdk
there you just install the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment and that brings us to the
end of this lecture let's get started
with installing java we will basically
look at how we can install java on a
windows machine so the first step to
install java is to download it from the
official oracle website so for that
let's open a web browser and let's type
jdk
java download and hit enter then you
need to find the link which says
oracle.com because
like we discussed in the previous
lecture uh java is owned by oracle so we
need to download it from the official
website only so we can click on this
link which says java se downloads it
will bring us to the downloads page and
we will see different versions of java
you can see the java sc 15 you can see
java se14 you can also see java sc 11
and all the previous versions
under another thing which you will
notice that it says lts here which means
long term support basically long term
support are the releases for which
oracle is going to provide
long-term security patches and updates
for the non-lts releases java will not
provide long-term support and long-term
patch fixes and long-term security fixes
so it's a good idea to analyze and
evaluate on which version you want to
develop your applications on for this
demo i think it is fine we can go with
the non lts version and even for your
for your customer facing applications
you can start with the non lts version
and then upgrade to the latest lts
version whenever that is available so
for this demo we can download java sc 15
and you can also do the same on your
machine it will work exactly the same
way as an lts works
so you can click on the jdk download
option here
let's click on that it is going to bring
up the downloads detail page and you can
see uh there are multiple options given
here uh in terms of what platform you
want to install java on whether it is a
linux platform or it is a mac os machine
or it is a windows platform so like i
said in the beginning of the demo that
today we are going to see how we can
install this on a windows machine so i'm
going to download the windows x64
installer here if you are working on a
linux machine or a macos machine you can
download those respective installers as
well so you can see the exe here so
let's click on this
once we click on this we'll get this
pop-up which will ask us to accept the
oracle technology network license
agreement so we can hit this check box
and click on download jdk 15 and this
shall start the download and you will
see some some exe getting downloaded in
in your download box here but as the
download is going to take some time and
uh i'm not going to wait for that and
that's the reason i have already
downloaded the jdk 15 for this
particular demo and that jdk is is
sitting here on my desktop which i have
downloaded prior to this demo so we'll
just run this particular exe which is
exactly the same exe as the one which is
being downloaded so let us double click
on this it will ask you for this pop-up
in some cases so you can just hit yes
basically it is asking whether you trust
this exe or not but as we downloaded
this from official oracle website then
we can trust this particular exe so i
will hit yes
and now the installer is going to unpack
and you might get a screen like this
which will be an installation result for
the java sc development kit 15. another
thing which before i proceed i just
wanted to highlight that as well that
you might have noticed about jdk here
it's exactly the same term which we
covered in the last lecture that when
you install java you basically install
the jdk which is the java development
kit and this is also visible here when
it says java sc development kit 15. so
let's hit next then on this particular
page you have the option to change the
installation location of java if you
want to by default it is going to
install in c program files slash java
jdk 15 but if you want to change the
location and you want to install java to
a particular custom location of your
choice that is also possible you just
hit change here and then you can choose
whatever directory or folder or place
you want to install this
java on and you can
basically select the appropriate
location for this particular case i
don't want to change that i'm happy with
the default location which is available
here so i'm just going to proceed with
this particular location here so i will
just hit next
and then java is going to install and
it's it's very fast installation it
generally takes few seconds as you will
see in this demo basically it is going
to unpack all the all the libraries and
all the runtime libraries and all the
class path libraries which we discussed
in the previous lecture and put all that
into the location which we specified to
install java it will also set up the
rest of the prerequisites which are
required to run java successfully so
looks like the java has been
successfully installed as is visible in
this message and there's also a next
step if you want to
access the tutorials or the api
documentations the developer guides the
release notes etc i don't want to do
that so i will just hit close here and
now if we want to just verify if java is
is installed or not then we can
verify that from the command line prompt
let me just exit this
and let's go to the command prompt to
verify to see if java has been
successfully installed so to do that uh
we'll we'll just open the search bar and
we'll type cmd
it is going to show us this command
prompt here we'll click on this
and it will open the command prompt for
you like it has opened for me and there
you just need to type
java hyphen version and you hit enter if
you get a message like this it means
java has been successfully installed if
you get a message saying that java is
not recognized as a command it means
that java is still not successfully
installed and something has gone wrong
in your installation and in that case
you might want to restart you might want
to go back and reinstall this java exe
again so in this case it looks like it
has been successfully installed and we
can also get some interesting
information from here we can see which
version of java has been installed it
says java version 15. we can also see
that the jre is also installed the java
sc runtime environment or jre is also
installed and we can also see that the
jvm is also installed which is java
hotspot server vm vm means the virtual
machine so if i connect this back to the
previous lecture we can see that
the java jdk basically installed the jre
as well as the jvm as well and the
complete java package has been
successfully installed now we are ready
to use java
a java program and run java programs on
this machine and at this step i would
like to conclude this lecture in the
next session we will be discussing how
we can install eclipse because that
would be the natural next step for any
java developer that they want to install
java and then they want to install
eclipse and start working let's get
started with installing eclipse on a
windows machine so the first thing which
we need to do is to download eclipse so
for that i'm just going to open my web
browser and type eclipse download
press enter and then you need to find
the link which says
eclipse.org
downloads which is the first link in my
search results you can also see it says
eclipse downloads the eclipse foundation
and eclipse foundation is the one is the
organization which maintains the eclipse
installers so we can click on this
once we click on this we will be
redirected onto the eclipse downloads
page and there again you will see bunch
of options you will see the default
option highlighted which would be the
eclipse installer for uh for jre for mac
os windows and linux and then you have
some other tool platforms option as well
like eclipse g or oreon which you might
want to use for advanced cases but for
running java applications all you need
is an eclipse installer which is coming
from here so based on your machine
eclipse will automatically detect
whether you want a 64-bit installer or a
32-bit installer and you can just click
on this particular link which says
download 64-bit here so i'm just going
to hit download 64-bit it is going to
open this particular screen where based
on your current location eclipse will
suggest the nearest possible
distribution mirror distribution mirror
is basically a server which is present
somewhere in this world which contains
this eclipse installer exe and eclipse
has created these servers all across the
globes these servers are basically
called the mirrors and based on your
current location which will be deducted
taken taken from your isp from the
internet ip address from which you are
accessing this particular website so
based on your isp location it is going
to suggest you the nearest possible
mirror location so that your download is
the fastest
so in my case the nearest location is
netherlands here as you can see and i
get a download option this is the file
name which says eclipse installer jre
windows64.exe
and if you think that this mirror
doesn't make sense just click on this
option select another mirror and then
you can choose another mirror but
generally it works really well it works
based on it works based on your ip
location and it's generally
the download speed is pretty good based
on the suggested mirror so i'm not going
to change the mirror location because i
think this works fine for me so and i'm
just going to click on this particular
button which is going to start the
download of the eclipse installer so now
i have i have hit the download button
and you can see right now an exe has
been download has begun to download uh
it is going to again take some time and
i have already downloaded this
particular exe just to save us some time
and i'm going to use that exe to
showcase how we can install it another
thing just wanted to highlight is that
eclipse is an open source organization
it works on donations so if you feel
generous about it and if you feel that
eclipse is doing really great work you
can also donate to it which will show
here so we can move to the next step
which is about installing so you can see
here i have an installer here an exe
file basically which i have pre
downloaded to showcase this demo i'm
just going to double click on this and
it is going to unpack the installer you
can see this this icon will be presented
to you which says eclipse installer by
oomph oomph is basically the provider
for this particular installer who
manages the installer and based on your
computer's capacity and speed it is
going to take few seconds and
in the background what it is doing is
basically it is unpacking this installer
and creating all the installation files
which it needs to successfully install
it on your computer once that is done
you will be presented with this kind of
screen and you will see that eclipse
provides multiple different kind of ides
for different set of developer
communities you will see an option which
says eclipse ide for java developers you
will also see eclipse ide for enterprise
java developers you will see the ide for
c plus and c developers web and
javascript php eclipse committers who
basically contribute to the eclipse
organization or
rcprp tester scientific computing there
are tons of ides which eclipse maintains
for our use case throughout this series
i think we will be focusing on this
particular ide which says eclipse ide
for enterprise java developers you can
also use this particular ide but this is
a very bare bone ide with very limited
set of integrations like it says it
includes a java ide a git client an xml
editor a maven plugin and a gradle
plugin but if you look at the enterprise
you will get more integrations you can
use this particular ide to work on
whatever you work here so these all will
work here but in addition you can also
use this ide to build a web application
build a web service build a jpa
application data tools java server pages
faces etc so this is more
more advanced i would say and we will go
with this particular ide and you can
also choose this id if you want to but
for this demo we are going to choose
this one i will click on this then it is
going to show me which virtual machine
it is going to use so if you remember in
the previous lecture we installed java
15 it has automatically detected that
location by reading my c program files
folder and it has automatically taken
that if you have multiple jdk
installations on your machine you can
click on this icon and change a
different java virtual machine i'm going
to leave it as is again the installation
folder is also by default taken to your
c users username slash eclipse slash the
jee
version number and again if you want to
change this you can also change a
different installation folder i'm going
to leave everything as default it will
automatically create a start menu entry
and a desktop shortcut and now i hit
install it might come
ask you for a user agreement so you can
hit accept now and now it has begun the
installation the installation generally
takes a bit of time to complete in some
cases so again it depends upon your in
your computer's capacity and speed
basically if it's a good robust machine
with with good capacity the installation
might be very fast as you can see in my
computer and if you have a computer
which is not very strong on
configurations you can just be patient
and wait for some time and the
installation will be finished once the
installation is finished you will see
this launch option here you will also
have an option to keep an installer if
you want to show the readme file but i
think the the main option here which we
are going to use is the launch option so
if you hit the launch option now the
actual ide is going to start up it's
again going to set up some configuration
files and some bootstrap configuration
files which it needs to and then it will
ask you to choose a workspace again
workspace is up to you where do you
where you want to create your workspace
the workspace is basically the location
where you
will create your projects it will store
those project files and the source code
of those projects so it is up to you
where you want to create it again i'm
going to leave it as default here but if
you want to change it just hit browse
here and choose whatever location you
want to you can see you can choose you
can go to pc and you can choose whatever
location you want to i'm going to leave
it as is and you also have a choice that
you don't want eclipse to ask this every
time so you can check this box and next
time eclipse is not going to ask you to
choose a directory as workspace and
every time you start eclipse it will
automatically go to this particular
directory so you can either check it or
uncheck it based on your convenience
and hit launch once you hit launch it is
going to start the actual ide as a
desktop application and you will get a
nice interface and a welcome screen from
eclipse which will which will basically
show the basic overview of the screen
something like this so now you can see
that the eclipse id has started it has a
welcome page which has multiple options
you can check out a project from git you
can import an existing project you can
go to the marketplace create a java web
project or whatever or you can just
close this you have a nice navigation
project
project explorer bar here so all the
projects which you are going to create
will be listed here there are also some
quick shortcuts here for creating
different kind of projects and if you
don't want to use that just go to file
new and choose a kind of project you
want to create whether it is a maven
project or enterprise application
project or dynamic web project or just a
project if you just hit just a project
you can choose a basic java project to
start with click next give a project
name let's call it test demo you can
choose an execution environment here the
jre and currently this particular ide
has support up to 14 but i think this is
going to work fine we don't need to
worry about it we can also use a project
specific jre like in this case java 15
which is the current installation so i
can use this option because i want to
use java 15 environment because i have
java 15 installed
so you can basically choose whatever
option you want to choose it gives you
flexibility in terms of choosing the gre
whether you want to choose an external
gre whether you want to choose a project
specific jre or you want to use the
default gre jdk installation so you can
use this option as well if you want to
project layout is create either you want
to create separate folders for source
and classes or you want to create the
user project folder again this is these
are just basic configurations which you
can play around with if you want to i'm
just going to leave it as is and hit
next and then it is going to just give
me a review screen here if i want to
change anything i can otherwise i can
just hit finish
i can create a module name here if i
want to but i don't want to create it so
just hit on don't create and open the
java perspective
and that's it you have a java project
here where you can create your java
files under this src and you can start
executing those files we will look out
on those details in the upcoming
lectures but for this lecture i think
this is what we wanted to achieve we
wanted to show how we can install
eclipse and how we can create a very
sample
java cli project so this is it for this
uh this session in the next session we
will look at some of the data types in
java let's get started with primitive
data types in java we are going to learn
about the primitive data types in java
and we'll also see a short demonstration
of it
so let's get started let's first just
learn about those uh data types i've
just opened the official
oracle documentation and don't worry if
you see how this link appears here you
can just open a browser window and just
type java primitive data types and if
you hit enter the first link which you
will be given is this particular link
and this is the same link which i have
opened so let's learn about the data
types now so java has
these primitive data types which you can
see here some of them store numbers some
of them store boolean values and some of
them store characters so the data types
which store numbers are byte short int
long float and double
these six data types basically are used
to store any kind of numeric value let's
understand these a bit more byte is the
shortest possible data type value which
you can use in java to store numbers you
can only store numbers within the range
of minus 128 to plus 127. so you can see
the range is very small and java has
created this variable for use cases
where you want to store numbers which
have very small value in this range why
do we provide these kind of options just
to save memory because the smaller data
type will require less memory to be used
in the java program similarly the next
bigger data type is short which is a bit
bigger than byte and the range of this
particular data type where
variables will range from -3 to 678 to
plus three two seven six seven so that
is the range for this particular
variable and you can see that it says it
has a very big range as compared to the
byte data type so if you want to store
very uh values which lie in this range
you can use short the next one is int
data type you can use this one to store
even larger values which range from
minus 2 raised to power 31 to plus 2
raised to power 31 minus 1. the next one
is long which is even bigger than int
and it can be used to store the values
within the range of minus 2 raised to
power 63 to plus 2 raised to the power
63 minus 1. so as you can see as we go
from top to bottom from byte to long the
size of the value which can be stored
using this data type increases and
that's how you will basically take a
decision of whether you want to use byte
or you want to use short or int or long
based on what size of the value that
variable is going to contain then the
next ones are float and double these two
have been created for the use cases
whether where you want to store the
values numeric values which have
decimals which are precision values i
should also mention that byte short int
and long are only used for storing
absolute numbers which do not have any
decimal representation even if you try
to store a decimal value in these
variables they will automatically be
trimmed the decimal values will
automatically be removed and you will
only be
shown the absolute values
and in case of float and double they can
maintain those precision and decimal
values so we use float for the use cases
where you want to store decimal
representations of the values and you
can see that the float value can store a
smaller precision value but double can
store even a bigger precision value so
if you have really big precision values
to be maintained very big decimal values
to be maintained you should use double
and the float is used for
storing a bit smaller size of the
precision values i mean its range of
values basically beyond the scope of
this discussion if you want to read more
about this you can go to this particular
links which will explain this in detail
but the basic idea is that float is good
for storing two precision values and if
you want to go beyond that you want to
use double in some cases some people
also use float to store even beyond two
values as well so it completely depends
the main the decision factor is how long
the value you are going to store in the
decimal and that will take the decide
whether you want to use float or double
the next one is boolean which is used
for storing the boolean values boolean
values can be either true or false so
there are only two possible values and
then we have care which is used for
storing characters it is using 16-bit to
store the value and this is a very
popular java question for beginner level
programmers that why does it store uh
need 16-bit to store the character it's
because it stores a unicode
representation unicode representation is
a representation which can be accepted
across platforms across the world in
different character encodings
so let's move on to eclipse now where i
have prepared a very short and simple
demo i'm just creating a variable for
each data type and i'm printing them
you also see some things here like the
these keywords and don't worry about
these keywords i will cover these
keywords in detail in the upcoming
lectures you also see this and you can
just for now you can remember that
system.out.println is used for printing
anything in java anything you want to
print on the console you would be using
system.out.println what is system what
is out and what is println again we will
cover these in the uh upcoming lectures
for now i'm just creating a bunch of
data types here variables here basically
i'm creating a cab type variable a byte
type variable a short type variable an n
type variable a float type variable a
double and a boolean the way you create
variables is basically you put the data
type name you put the variable name
which can be anything you put an equal
sign and you put the value actual value
which this variable is going to store
and i've done the similar thing for all
of these
variables java wants semicolons to be
there when you write your statements so
please remember that your statements
always end with semicolons so i've
declared all of these variables here a
byte a short and int flow double and
boolean and then i'm printing all of
them basically here i'm printing the cad
variable here i'm printing the byte
variable here i'm printing the short and
so on so forth so how do we actually run
this application or this program we just
double click on this or right click on
this you go to this run as option you
see this run as java application option
so you can hit this option it will run
the application and it will present all
the output here in the console tab let
me just bring this up so you can see all
the variables have been printed here and
this is coming from these print
statements like i said this is used
system.out.println is used to basically
print anything and i've used that to
print all the variables here first i am
printing the carry variable whose value
is
a
then i am using the byte variable which
is denoted by b and whose value is 2 so
you can see the value is 2 here then i
am printing the third variable which is
c which is a short type variable which
has a value 22 you can see short and
this is coming here the next print
statement is int so you can see int here
with the value 45 and this value is
coming from here then we have float
we can see the float value being printed
here and you can see the float value
declared here you also see an f here and
this is the standard naming convention
with java proposes that whenever you
declare float and double you end them
with f or d based on whether it is float
or it is double then you see the double
value which is having which is having a
bigger precision than float so i have
printed the double value using
this particular
print statement which is printed here
and then we have the boolean value which
is stored as g
and the value of g is true and the same
value is printed here so whatever i
write here basically is printed here
this is just a placeholder and this is
the actual value so you can see that we
are able to use all the variables here
all the primitive variables basically
which range from byte character byte
short int float double and boolean
and that's it for this session in the
next session we will be discussing about
the non-primitive data types in java
let's get started with non-primitive
data types in java in the previous
lecture we talked about the primitive
data types and now we'll discuss about
some of the data types which are not
primitive first of all let's understand
what is the difference between primitive
and non-primitive so the primitive data
types are the ones which are by default
supported by java and non-primitives are
the one which are a bit custom in nature
where you as developer have the liberty
to define the nature of that data type
we'll look at some examples of that as
well but when we talk about which all
are the non-primitive data types we
broadly talk about arrays we talk about
classes we talk about strings as well
and we will cover some of them in
today's lecture and we have the a
detailed lecture upcoming about the
classes as well in fact in the and uh
after a few lectures will we'll cover
how we'll create classes as well but for
today's lecture we are going to focus on
string data type and array data type and
like i said for classes we have a
dedicated lecture upcoming so don't
worry about that and again for this
particular case as well i have already
prepared a demo for this and will
basically do some look at some hands-on
examples to see how do we create these
variables what is what does these
variables mean and the first
non-primitive data type we are going to
talk about is string and before i go on
further i should also mention that it's
very debatable in the java community to
call string as a non-primitive data type
and actually technically speaking string
is a special data type it neither fully
lies in the primitive category nor it
fully lies in the non-primitive
categories i'm covering this as as a
non-primitive data type because it's a
bit inclined towards the non-primitive
category why do we
do this is because java does provide
native support for string handling in
the jdk and that's the reason some of
the developers feel that string is a
primitive data type which is primitively
supported by java but at the same time
string is so customizable and it's so
special in nature it's the way it stores
the value the way it provides the
operations and handlings it's so
different than primitive data types that
it cannot fully be put in the same
bucket as the primitive data types so
that's why i said it's it's a special
data type a bit inclined towards the
non-primitive category so what is string
basically we covered about the cad data
type in the previous lecture and
in cav data type you can only store a
single character right but if you want
to store a complete name of somebody
then it's a list of character it's
basically a lot of characters together
then in that case you would need a data
type to store that continuous sequence
of characters and that's what string
does string can store a continuous
sequence of characters
technically string is basically a
character array you can call string as a
character array and don't worry if you
don't understand about the word array i
will explain that in the same lecture so
basically it stores the continuous
sequence of characters that's how that's
how we define string and you see this
string this is a basically the keyword
the data type basically in java so
whenever you want to create a string you
need to write string with s capital you
need to give a name to the string this
can be anything and then you can provide
the value which is which this particular
string is going to contain so you can
see this is a continuous sequence of
characters t e s t
are the four characters which this
string is going to contain and after
that again i'm printing this particular
value and like i said don't worry about
this we'll cover this when we'll when
we'll write our first program in java so
this is just to print the string value
i'm just putting a string placeholder
here and then i'm actually printing the
printing the values of the string
variable now string can be created in
multiple ways in java this is one way of
creating it there is another way of
creating a string variable which is this
one which says again the string data
type some variable name a keyword called
new again don't worry about what is this
new keyword we'll cover this when we'll
talk about running our first program in
java and writing the first program from
scratch then we against a string and
then we provide the value so if i
compare this line number 4 to line
number 7 you can see the difference is
that i'm still storing the same value
test but the difference is that here
there is no new string keyword but here
we have this new string keyword so
what is the difference the difference is
this that in this case
in this particular case
string is going to
reuse the same object multiple times but
in this case every time you call this it
is going to create a new object again
what is object it's just you can think
of it as for now you can think of it as
a memory block will again cover objects
in details but these are two different
ways in which you can create string this
is generally the most popular way of
doing it because this is memory
efficient because you can reuse the same
variable again and again
so i'm creating the string variable here
and creating another string variable
str1 here and printing both of them then
i've created this strange looking thing
here which is basically an array array
like i said is also an a non-primitive
data type in java and array can store a
continuous sequence
of anything
that anything can be a number
that anything can be characters that
anything can be or a floating number as
well so basic idea is that if you want
to store a collection or or sequence of
multiple multiple
values how do you do that you do that
with the help of arrays array is a data
structure a non-primitive data structure
in java which can store lot of values of
similar type we also call it as
homogeneous data structure which because
it can only store same data type values
or homogeneous data type values so the
the biggest way to identify array is
this square bracket whenever you see
this square bracket in java it means
it's an it's an array variable so here i
am creating an integer array variable
with the name arr this is the name of
this particular array it is only going
to store integer values because i've
specified int and the moment i provide
the square brackets it's mean it means
that it is an array so you can declare
an array like this and then you need to
assign a size to the array size is
basically denoting how many values
this data structure is going to store so
i'm saying new again it's a keyword and
i'm saying that ok create a
memory block for storing two integers so
this particular array arr can store at
max two values two values at continuous
locations the next thing about array is
that it stores the value in a zero index
based location so like i said it can
store two values so the first location
will always be array of zero and this is
how you specify the location or index of
the element which is going to be stored
so at the zeroth location of this array
i'm storing zero
the first location of the array i'm
storing one and this is just to show an
error scenario but i will just comment
this for now you can just put double
slashes and comment any line so i'm just
storing filling up this array for two
values and the two values location would
be zero index and first index these are
just continuous memory locations and we
denote those memory locations as 0 and 1
array indexes always start with 0 and
i'm just putting some values here you
can put any values and then i'm printing
the whole array and i'm also printing
the first value of the array and we'll
see how this pans out and we'll also see
how we can change this so now we are
going to run this application so i'll
just go to run as and click on run as
java application and once i hit that i
get this output here so let's understand
this output the first one is i'm just
printing the string which has the value
test and you can see it has printed here
it is coming from this line
then the next line which is printed is
line number eight where i'm saying
another string str1 and str1 also had
the same value so you can see another
string has the same value and then
i have printed the array here the
complete array and you see this strange
value here it also tells us that if you
want to print the array then you cannot
just put the variable name and print it
the reason is because this is a
non-primitive data type and once you do
this it is basically printing the memory
footprint of this array the whole memory
location where this array is stored
that's why you see this strange looking
number which is the memory hash code and
if you want to print any particular
value or any particular element inside
this array then you can do that by
providing the index location of that
element so here i have said that print
the zeroth location element of the array
the zeroth location array element of the
array was zero so you can see the value
zero here let me put some other value
just to just for fun and show you how
this works so just change the values and
now let's see what do we get for array
zero you can see now i get value three
because now that at the zeroth location
the three value is being stored and that
is what is being printed here we can
also print the first value
i'll just go run as java application you
can see now the array of first index is
being stored which is basically
technically the second element of the
array but because array always works on
a 0 index based value format that's why
when we say array 1 the second element
is printed when i say array 0 the first
element is printed so always remember
that array is a 0 index based collection
or data structure basically what happens
if i do this
now there is no third element in this
array because the array has the size
only of two elements and when i say
error of 2 which means i'm trying to
print the third element in this array
which does not exist so let's see what
happens in that case
i get an exception exception is
basically an error i get an error saying
that index two is out of bounds for
length two it means that the array
length was actually 2 and index 2 does
not exist remember it's saying index 2
not the element 2. index 2 doesn't exist
because only index 0 and index 1 exist
this makes two elements and the actual
size is also two it does not have
capacity to store third element it does
not have third element location anywhere
that's why it complains that you are
trying to print a non-existing value so
this is where i would like to conclude
my lecture about the non-primitive data
types so we covered about string we
covered arrays and like i said we'll
cover classes in the upcoming lecture as
well
in the next session we are going to talk
about tokens in java let's get started
with tokens in java when we talk about
tokens in java these tokens are
basically some reserved expressions or
words or symbols which have a predefined
meaning in java and you cannot override
this meaning because this meaning is
already defined by java and you can use
those expressions those symbols and
those words in only the way java wants
you to there is no way you can change
the meaning of those terms or those
symbols so we will be covering those
tokens in today's lecture these tokens
are broadly divided into five different
categories these categories are keywords
identifiers constants special symbols
and operators so let's talk about each
of them one by one so when we talk about
keywords
these are the words which are reserved
by java and they have a predefined
meaning you might have already seen some
of these reserved keywords for example
we have used int when we were working on
the primitive data type lecture we have
seen this as well though we haven't
actually
found out the meaning of this but we
will find out the meaning of this in the
coming lectures so don't worry about
that we have seen boolean as a as a data
type again we have seen byte so these
boolean byte int
class care catch super switch
synchronized all the all the keywords
which you see here these keywords have a
predefined meaning in java and you use
these keywords so that you want to take
an action an expected action by java for
example if you call something as int
then you want java to treat it as int
int will only have a single meaning in
java and there is no other meaning of
int in a java program so that's the
intent with the keywords these are
reserved words which have a predefined
meaning and we will cover these keywords
at length during this whole course the
next token is identifier and identifier
is is nothing but just a variable name
technically and we have already covered
this this kind of identifier when we
were showing the demonstrations for
primitive data types and non-primitive
data types etc it's basically anything
which you declare as a variable is an
identifier and when you declare the
variable name again java puts some sort
of restrictions as to what you can or
cannot do when you work with java and
you declare the variable names for
example these variable names cannot
start with numbers so you cannot have a
variable name which starts with any
number you cannot have a variable name
which contains spaces in between them
you either have to fill those
if there's a if there's a variable name
which you think has two parts for
example student name then you need to
write it as student underscore name so
that you can create the variable name
with the same impact and still does not
contain space so spaces will not be
allowed when you create the variable
names similarly you cannot have plus
hyphen and ampersand in the variable
names as well these are the restrictions
with java puts on the identifier tokens
whenever you create identifiers the next
one is constants and we will cover these
constants in detail in the coming
lectures as well but to give you an idea
of what constants are so constants are
basically exactly what they sound like
they are the identifiers
which you have declared in your program
whose value cannot be changed once
defined so if you write something as
final
int i equal to 5 then this value is
fixed you cannot change the value of i
again in the program java will not allow
you to change the value of i again
because i has now become a constant
because you have put a final keyword in
front of it and again final is a keyword
you see final is a keyword basically so
you so these constants are treated
specially by java that java will make
sure that their values will never change
during the course of the execution of
the program these can come really handy
when you have situations where you do
not want the certain variables values to
be to be modified for example if you
have an application where you are
counting the number of applicants and if
you have declared the number of
applicants as final then every time you
call the application you can do a plus
one to the previous value the value will
not be reinitiated so it is very useful
concept and and it can be very handy in
programs where you don't want to change
the values the next is special symbols
these special symbols are the symbols
which again have a predefined meaning in
java we have already seen this square
bracket symbol in our previous lecture
when we were creating arrays so whenever
you use these square brackets then java
would understand that you are trying to
either access or create an array or you
are trying to access or create a list
etc so this is predefined you cannot use
this anywhere else or with any other
meaning similarly when we talk about
these braces these standard brackets are
standard braces these again have a
predefined meaning in java generally
whenever you will write functions and
methods in java you will use these
brackets to define the parameters of the
function now you cannot use these
brackets
in any other meaning in java java will
not allow you to use this anywhere else
apart from using it in method parameters
similarly the next one is the curly
braces and the curly braces are used to
define a code block in java you might
have already noticed that when we were
looking at the previous demos you could
see some curly braces then some code and
then the and then the curly braces would
end for example if i show you here just
it's just a sample example and let me
open the example which we covered in the
last lecture so you can see this curly
brace here and this curly brace ends
here right so this defines a code block
in java any code block which you want
java to understand will always be
starting with a curly braces and ending
with a curly brace i remember i talked
about the standard braces you can see
these are the standard braces opening
and ending and this is where we are
defining this particular methods
arguments now what is method what is
argument don't worry about that we will
cover in detail but just an introductory
concept whenever you are trying to
define a method and you want to pass any
argument to the method we use these
brackets to do that okay
similarly this is semicolon is used to
uh close any java statement so you will
see this semicolon here every java
statement has to have a semicolon as
ending otherwise java will complain that
it is a syntactical error so it is part
of the syntax you need to put the
semicolon and semicolon has only one
meaning in java which is that your
statement is actually ending
then we have star and star is used for
multiplication and then we have equality
which is used for assigning any values
and again assigning any values is
everywhere you are seeing this equality
sign everywhere so these are all tokens
basically the last type of token we have
is operators and we will cover these
operators in the upcoming lectures in
detail with the examples but these
operators are basically some special
symbols like for arithmetic it would be
plus minus multiplication divide for
comparison it will be uh greater than
less than for logical it would be
ampersand uh and and pipe operators
bitwise again will have some bitwise
operation
operators they so the so these are
basically different categories of
operators and under each category of
operators there are certain symbols like
for arithmetic we have plus minus we
have com for comparison we have greater
than less than etc so these again
symbols are also reserved by java under
the operators tokens category you cannot
use these in any other meaning or in any
other way and like i said we will look
at a detailed example of this as well in
the coming lectures so this was a quick
overview of what are different types of
tokens in java so we have keywords we
have identifiers constants
special symbols and operators so this is
it this is all what i wanted to cover in
today's lecture and in the next session
we will be looking at data type
conversions let's get started with data
type conversions so when we talk about
data type conversion the whole idea is
to basically answer the question that
whether i can convert a int data type
variable into a long data type variable
or a long data type variable to a float
data type variable and also vice versa
can i go back can i convert a float
variable into a long variable or an int
variable and vice versa so this lecture
is about answering all of those
questions and we will basically look at
some examples to understand how the
conversion works but let me just explain
the basic principle the basic principle
is that smaller box can fit into larger
box but if you have to fit a larger box
into a smaller box you need to do
something else so
what do we mean by smaller box and
larger box here the smaller box is a
variable or a data type which has a
smaller range if you remember we talked
about the range of short byte int etc
and we could see that as we go from
short to byte to int to long to float to
double the ranges were increasing right
so we will follow the same kind of
analogy that if we have to store a
smaller range variable into a larger
range variable java will automatically
do that but if i have to store a larger
range variable into a smaller range
variable then i have to sacrifice some
quality of the value and we will look at
the examples of that as well so let's
first look at look at the example where
we can store our smaller range variable
into a larger range variable we call
this as implicit data type conversion so
here you can see i have declared an int
variable with the value 100 and i'm
printing the int variable then i have
declared a long variable and what i'm
doing that i'm assigning the value of
int a to the long variable b so i'm not
assigning a new value to this long
variable but rather i'm just passing on
the existing integer value into a
variable of type long similarly after
that i am taking the value of this
variable of long type and storing this
value into a float type so you can see
int is basically smaller than long and
long has a smaller range than float so
i'm just storing a smaller range
variable into a larger range and then a
larger range variable into the largest
range and then i am printing all the
variables values to see if this actually
is working can long automatically store
the value of a and can float
automatically store the value of b here
i'm just printing the variables and
again using the concept of the previous
lecture this is just to print the values
and i will cover this in detail in the
next lectures of how this works but here
you can understand that we can use
system.out.println
to basically print the values and here
i'm just printing a string and then the
value then again the string and the
value and here also the string and the
value so this is what is happening in
this program and again don't worry about
these details i will cover about what
these concepts are in the upcoming
lectures so let's run this and see if
the data type conversion actually works
so i will just right click and do run as
and go to java application and if i
click on this i get this output so the
first output is pretty straightforward
i'm just printing the int variable as is
so this works then i am storing the int
into a long and printing the long
representation of a which is b basically
and this also works without any errors
or any warnings by java similarly when i
talk about storing the long variable
into a float variable c this also works
but here you see an additional decimal
precision here because as we remember
from the previous sessions float is used
to store values which have decimals or
which have positions so it will
automatically convert your absolute
number into a number which has decimals
whenever you try to cast this into float
casting is also a word which is used
some people call it as implicit data
type conversion some people call it as
implicit data type casting so if you
hear the word data type casting or
implicit data type casting you can think
that it is exactly the same concept as
data type conversion so this is about
implicit data type conversion now let's
look at an example of explicit data type
conversion how does that work so using
the same analogy of the boxes now i will
try to store a larger ranging value
variable into a smaller range variable
and see how that looks like so i will
start with the largest which is which is
double variable so i have created a
double variable and as we know that
double is a is a variable which is used
to store decimal values so i'm storing
this value here and then i'm just
printing the double representation as is
without any changes
then i'm trying to store this variable's
value into a float variable so i'm
trying to go to a smaller box now i'm
trying to grow from double to float and
if you remember i told you that if you
have to do that it will not work out of
the box but you have to do a bit uh
something special as well and this is
the special part this is called type
casting type casting is basically a way
to tell java to explicitly cast this
variable's value into this data types
variables value and you always need to
do this whenever there is no implicit
casting happening if you are trying to
store a larger value variable into a
smaller value variable you have to do
this otherwise java will complain you
will get a compilation error so that's
what i'm doing i'm telling java to store
the value of a as a float and store the
value in f and this is where i'm telling
to store the value as float so you just
put brackets and you define float and
then i'm printing the float
representation similarly in the next one
i am trying to store the value of this
double variable into a long so you can
see now i'm trying to go even
from our precision data type to a
non-precision data type because long
does not understand decimal values so
i'm trying to store a variable which has
decimal values into a variable data type
which does not understand decimal values
and we will see how the output looks
like but here also you need to do the
explicit casting explicitly you need to
tell which data type this a needs to be
converted into that's what i do here and
then i print the long variable here and
then next i will again go down further
and i will try to store a larger long
variable type into a smaller int
variable type so again i'm trying to
store the value of b
into a smaller data type which is
integer and i'm naming the variable as c
here again i have to do this explicit
casting i'm telling that telling java to
explicitly cast the value of b which is
a long data type variable into an
integer c which is an int data type
variable and then i'm just printing the
value so this is what is happening in
this program that from double to float
to long to int now let's run this
program and see what happens so i will
right click and go to run as and choose
the java application option and this is
the output i get first of all for the
double representation the value gets
printed 0 is ignored then in the float
it works fine as well without any
precision loss because float can also
print values up to 1 to 2 decimal points
without any problems even beyond that
actually so it works fine
then when we talk about the long
representation we are trying to convert
a double variable into a long variable
and we see that the precision the
decimal values are lost this is expected
because long does not understand decimal
values that's why anything after the
decimal or in fact the whole decimal
portion is gone when you're trying to
store double or float into some absolute
data type variables like tint or long
and then in in representation since you
already have this long this long can
easily be casted to int by just
providing this explicit casting and the
int representation also prints 50. so we
started from this value and we ended up
with these values when we try to store
them as long or inked so this is all i
wanted to cover in today's lecture so we
covered basically about the data type
conversion or data type casting concepts
how does implicit data type casting
works and how does explicit data type
casting works and as we know the concept
the basic concept is that the uh the
value can easily be casted from a
smaller range to a larger range without
any changes or without any extra code
but when you have to go from a larger
value to a smaller value you have to
provide these casting instructions to
java to successfully cast those
variables in the next session we will be
looking at how we can write the first
hello world program in java and there we
will actually cover all the all these
things which which i have been saying
that we will cover so we will cover all
these ways of how we can write the first
hello world program in java let's get
started with how to write your first
program in java so i have been talking
about this lecture and the details of
this lecture in the previous lectures as
well and today we are going to focus
exactly on how do we actually write a
java program so as we have already
covered how you can install eclipse and
how you can create a sample java project
in eclipse if you haven't seen that
please go back to my previous videos
where you can actually see that and once
you have created your java project so
your java project might look like
something like this you will have an src
folder here so and under the src folder
uh you see some some namespaces sort of
things created here right we call these
as packages and in java you can think of
package as something which can group
multiple related artifacts together this
is simply a grouping mechanism i can say
it's a way to put all the related
artifacts to a particular business
problem into a certain place for example
if you are working in an e-commerce
application so
you have you might have created multiple
java files for let's say for checkout
and then some more java files for the
filters flow i would say then some other
java files for designing the
advertisements so you have multiple java
files and these java files now below
belong to these three different domains
so you want to group them together for
easy accessibility for
referencing each other
files with the within the code so if you
want to achieve that kind of flexibility
you would group the checkout code files
into a single package you can name it as
checkout package then you can similarly
do the same thing for the advertisement
package and for the filters package so
similarly uh i have created some
packages here which you can see you see
a package here which says are your
github wikis panda hello world and how
do you create a package you just right
click on this so you go to the src and
you right click to go to new and here
you will see this option which says
package so you can just click on this
and write anything which you want as the
package name let's call it as test
package uh it says invalid because the
package is a keyword so it is not
allowing me to put package here but
let's call it test package one and you
can just click finish and you will see a
test package popping up here then you
can right click on this again go to new
and then you can create a java class now
what is a java class a class is
basically a blueprint for an object it's
basically the specifications of an
object like i covered in the very first
lecture everything in java is an object
or most of the things in java are object
i would say so
object is basically an instance of the
class so let's say you create a class
for if i take the same example of
e-commerce you create a class for
writing the business logic of checkout
and then you create instance of this
particular class to work for a
particular customer order so class is
basically a blueprint it's the
specification it's the skeleton of the
object so once you click on this you can
create a class now eclipse is a pretty
smart ide it will provide you with bunch
of options on how you actually can
create a class what and it will also
provide use with some sensible defaults
for example it will automatically select
a source folder in your project which
you have created it will automatically
select a package in fact the currently
selected package and if you want to
change the package just hit browse and
choose any other package which you want
to choose so your your class file will
be created in that package then you can
provide a name to the class so let's
call it as
test
hello
world and you can see i have followed a
sort of a naming convention here the
first character i've kept it as capital
and then any other new world which is
coming in my class file name is also
capitalized so java
would expect you and it would encourage
you to follow this naming convention
that whenever you are creating a class
always start with a capital letter then
small letters and every new word you are
writing can start with a capital letter
again java will not throw an error if
you don't do this
h capital or w capital but it's a good
practice the next thing is the modifier
we are going to cover the modifiers in
details in the in the upcoming lectures
but for now you can understand that
anything which is marked as public is
accessible to every other java class in
this whole project that's the basic
meaning of making a class as public
public as the name
suggests itself it means it's visible to
everyone you can select a super class
and again we'll talk about this super
class later but this is the java lang
object is the super class of all the
classes which are created in java again
interface is again an advanced concept
and there are some other interesting uh
defaults it provides for the for example
if you want to create a main method now
what is the main method we'll just cover
it in a while so i will not do that i
will leave everything as default and i
will click on finish so i have this new
file coming up here and you can see it
has automatically picked up the package
which i selected and it has also written
public class test hello world with a
starting and ending curly braces in the
previous lecture we covered about this
curly braces that all the code block
have to be in the curly braces whenever
you write a java class the very first
statement java would expect to have in
the class is package name so make sure
that you have package as a keyword and
then the actual package name as the
package name for that particular class
you can see the package follows a dot
convention and it always ends with a
semicolon like all the java statements
and with semicolon so that would be the
first thing which you will write in your
class second thing is the access
modifier of the class like i said you
want this class to be accessible to
every other file in this project then
you can mark this class as public the
next thing is the class keyword you need
to write this particular keyword as is
otherwise your class will not be
detected so you write this as class then
you write test hello world or whatever
name you want to write but make sure
that whatever public class name you
provide here that name should match with
the file name these two things should
match the file name and the class name
if they don't match you would experience
weird behaviors as the class will not be
compiled the class might not be able to
run etc so always make sure that
whatever file name you provide you
always have a class with that name in
your file so my class structure is is
ready but there's nothing here in this
class in fact you cannot you cannot even
execute this class because for executing
the class for executing any class in
java any class at all in java you would
need a main method in java main method
is the entry point method of the java
whenever you are trying to run any
application be it a very small or very
large java application you would always
and always need a main method in that in
the class in the project somewhere and
you need to tell the java uh runtime to
execute that class and then the class
will have a main method and the your
program will start executing so always
have a main method otherwise your
program will not execute and how do you
write the main method so you first write
public
then you write static
then you write void
and then you write me and then you
provide
a parameter to this method as this now
let's understand what did i actually
write here first keyword is public
because this method has to be public
because like i said java runtime needs
to be able to access this method so the
similar concept which applied on the
class is applied on this method as well
that the entry point method has to be
public otherwise java will not be able
to find this method so you need to make
this method exactly as public the next
keyword is static you again need to
write this keyword as is and the reason
we write static here is because we
we want to run this particular class
without creating an object of the class
static is again a keyword which we will
cover in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that whenever you
want to access
something within the class without
creating an object then you need to
create it as static the next is void
void is basically the return type of
this method the method name is main and
it has to be main it cannot be main one
or main two otherwise if you do that
java will not be able to run your
program because it will expect you to
write this particular method exactly as
what i have written here no changes at
all should be there if you make any
changes java program will not run
because it will not be able to find the
entry point method which is the main
method so public static void main
remember that you need to have this in
your program so white is the return type
which means that this particular program
it will not return anything back to the
runtime because a method can have this
capability to either return something or
not return something for example a
method which can
add two numbers will return the result
of addition right so we return the
result return is the word here in this
case this method is not expected to
return anything because there is nobody
consuming it right java runtime will not
do anything with the with the return
value of this particular method that's
why java will force you to write void
here and main is the exact method name
which you need to use java will expect
you to supply a string array argument if
we covered arrays in bit detail in the
in the in the previous lectures and we
will cover arrays in actually in the
next lecture in very detail but you can
as we discuss that array is basically a
sequence of characters or words or
integers or anything right so in this
case this is basically uh the mandatory
parameter which you need to write as is
this parameter name can be anything
obviously it can be a rg args or
whatever you want to write it as but the
basic fundamental is that java will
basically supply all the command line
arguments using this particular string
array that's why you need to provide
this then let's write something in the
program because this is a hello world
program so i will just write
system
dot out dot print ln and i'll type a
string here which says hello
world and a semicolon so again i have
been saying that i will explain this and
now i will explain this why do we need
this and what does this mean so as i
have told earlier that whenever you want
to print something on the console in a
java program you need to write
system.out.println
now system here if you just go if you
just hover over it eclipse will show
what it is so system is basically a
class which contains several useful
class fields and methods it cannot be
instantiated means you cannot create an
object of it and it provides many
facilities like
standard input standard output and error
output exactly what we want to focus
here because we want to
use system class to print something on
the standard output the standard output
in this case is the console so if you
want to input something or you want to
output something or you want to output
an error then you need to use system
class and all of these standard input
standard output and error are streams
and that's what comes to the next word
what is this out how it is a stream to
print standard output similarly we have
system.err which is for printing the
error output streams similarly we have
system dot in for taking its standard
input streams so system dot in
system.out system.err these all are
these in out and err are streams and
then println is the actual method let's
hover over that let's first see out here
so you can see this is a stream object
which is used to print anything which is
ready to accept output data basically
and then we go to the println method and
it says print a string and then
terminate the line so like i mentioned
earlier as well this whole syntax is
used to print and actually this is the
core method this is the real method
which prints something on the console so
system class uses the output stream to
print something on the console using the
help of println method there is also a
print method so there are two methods
one is print and one is println the
difference is that in case of print
method the print method will not provide
you or terminate on a next line but in
in
system.out.println the ln means line
here it will print something and it will
bring the cursor to the next line if you
do not use this and if you again use
another print statement then both of the
statements will be printed on the same
line i will show that as well but
and then we provide any random string
here which we want to print so you right
click on this particular program you go
to run as and you run as java
application and you want to save this so
you can say always save resources before
launching and you see the output here so
this is how you can run your first java
program now let's also see the
difference between
system.out.println and system.out.print
so i will just copy this here and i'll
say hello world
one let's say and this time i will not
use system.out.println
but i will use
system.out.print
just put a space here so that it's
visible so if i use print how does that
look like i go to run and i go to run as
java application so now you see both of
the outputs are printed on the same line
there is no this output hasn't gone to
the next line and now if i run the same
program with
system.out.println methods now both of
these outputs will be divided on two
lines the first output then a line break
the hello world one goes to the next
line in the previous run the hello world
one was printing right next to it on the
same line so that is the difference so
this is how you can build your very
first program the hello world program in
java in the next session we will be
discussing about arrays in java let's
get started with arrays in java we
discussed about arrays in a bit detail
when we talked about the non-primitive
data types but this is a concept and a
topic which needs to be understood well
so that's why we'll go i will do a deep
dive on arrays in this particular
lecture so as i described earlier that
array is basically a container which can
store values or a sequence of values or
sequence of numbers or sequence of
characters into itself we can think of
it as a box which can store all the
values in a continuous fashion as you
can see here this is just a pictorial
representation and this is coming from
the official java docs and you can see
that we if we create an array of size 10
then we have these 10 blocks created
here you can see 1 to 10 so the whole
length of boxes the number of boxes here
are 10 but the way arrays are designed
is that the index index is basically
used to access the element in this
particular box the index of the boxes
start from zero so it goes from zero to
nine so remember the array length is 10
it array in the array can contain 10
elements but the index of the array
starts with 0 and will always end at
length minus 1 which is 10 minus 1 in
this case which comes as nine so it will
always be length minus one it will
always the index will always start from
zero and go till length minus one length
can be anything in this case the length
is ten so the index ends at nine if the
length was 20 the last index will be 19
but in total you have these 10 memory
locations we also call them as
continuous memory locations because they
are continuously placed and array
basically blocks 10 memory locations and
creates a container over it so this is
how an array basically looks like inside
the memory and
whenever you want to access the elements
of the array you will say array of 0 or
array of 1 or array of 2 you basically
need to specify the index to access the
element at index for example if you want
to access the element which is sitting
in this box you need to say array of
index 8 and we'll see how we can do that
but this is the basic understand
understanding an idea of the concept of
arrays so let's try to understand this
with the help of an example i will
switch back to eclipse ide and i've
created a very simple program here to
demonstrate the functionality of arrays
here so we already covered in the
previous lecture of what is package and
what is public and what is class how do
we give the class name and what is the
meaning of this particular method so i'm
not going to cover that again we'll
start directly from here so here the
first thing which i'm doing is i'm
declaring an array of integer this is a
variable name the identifier basically
it can be anything and this is the data
type it's an integer array and as we as
we covered this as well that whenever
you put square bracket in front of a
data type it becomes an array data type
so this is an integer array
representation now we just declared an
array but we still haven't allocated a
size to it so you can do that with this
particular
syntax so you can put the variable name
of the array and say new int and put the
right size here this size can be
anything and once you do this now array
will actually allocate those memory
boxes which we covered here but the
moment you do new int 10 this box these
boxes continuous boxes will be placed in
the memory and the memory is allocated
to this array we call this memory
allocation this is how you allocate
memory to the array so we allocated
memory to this array for storing 10
integers the next thing is now we can
start storing elements in those boxes so
like i said that the array index always
starts with 0 so if you have to store
the first element you actually have to
store it at index 0 location so you give
the array name you provide these square
brackets and you put the index value
within the square brackets that is how
you basically point to a particular
element inside the array so we say an
array of 0 and we put the value 100 then
we initialize the second element which
will be index 1 then will be the third
element which will be index two fourth
element index three fifth element index
four sixth element index five and so on
until we store till the last element so
this is the tenth element which is
accessible as index 9 and the value is
1000 basically so from 100 to 1000 we
stored 10 values in this array and we
stored them by accessing the index and
this is actually the only way you can
store values in the array by pointing to
the indexes so we go from 0 to 9 and we
stored all the values 0 being the first
element and array of 9 being the last
and the 10th element remember the length
minus 1 concept okay so now we will try
to print all the elements one by one
that's pretty much what we are doing now
so as we covered in the previous lecture
that we use
system.out.println to print anything and
we understood the whole meaning of this
so i'm not going to repeat that now
we want to print the first element the
first element is sitting at index 0 and
we can access that element with this
syntax by providing the variable name
and the actual index value so i'm just
writing a random string here which says
element at index 0 and then i'm putting
this plus here and putting the variable
name this plus is basically used to
concatenate the output of a static
string with a random variable or
basically you can print anything
with using plus plus is used for
concatenation so i'm just trying to
print this whole value but here this is
a string value which is a static string
and then i have a value coming from the
array so whenever you have to print some
value from a particular data type or
variable or collection then you can use
this plus syntax to concatenate a string
static string with your actual value so
that's what i've done here by saying
plus and array 0 and similarly for index
1 i'm printing the
the first index then for 2 3 so far and
so on so forth till the index 9. so
basically i'm just printing the all the
values of the array starting from index
0 to index 9 so that's all which which
is written in this program now let's try
to run this program so i will right
click go to run as and go to java
application and hit on this and now if i
just expand this console you can see all
the system.out.println statements have
been executed and they printed this so
this is the static screen a string part
in fact including the colon this is the
static string part element in index 0
printing exactly as is and then
dynamically the
zeroth index element of an array is
printed here similarly we have printed
the index 1 location element index 2
location element index 3 location
element and so on so forth till the
index 9 location element so in total
these are the 10 elements but the index
always works from 0 to length minus 1 in
this case it will be going from 0 to 9.
so this is basically all which i wanted
to cover in this lecture the whole idea
was to give you more understanding of
arrays and remember this is just an
integer array you can similarly create a
character array you can also create a
string array for uh for you as well so
it it's completely uh it's completely
related to the data type you're using if
you create a care array then you can
only store characters into it if you
create a string array then you can only
store strings into it and now you can
probably relate back to this particular
thing which i explained in the previous
lecture that we create this string array
for the reason that when you run this
particular program and if you want to
provide any command line values command
line arguments to the program those
arguments will automatically be stored
in this args and then you can access
this as args of 0 or gsf1 etc in your
program that's the whole concept so
these are this is the basically the deep
dive one array which i wanted to cover
and in the next session we are going to
cover about operators in java let's get
started with operators in java when we
talk about operators in java there are
multiple types of operators like
assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what how what these operators are and
how they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so
when we talk about assignment operators
i have again opened the official java
docs here if we understand assignment
operators we have been using this
operators all the while in all of the
demos so far and the basic idea is very
simple whenever you assign a value to a
variable you use the assignment operator
which is nothing but the equal sign we
have already covered this in multiple
demos so i will not cover this as part
of the demo but what i am going to cover
in detail is about these arithmetic
operators so arithmetic operators are
basically used to perform any kind of
arithmetic operation on a java program
it can be an addition operation it can
be a subtraction operation it can be a
multiplication operation a division
operation or an operation by which you
can find the remainder of the division
so we will look at each of these
with an example and as you can see the
symbols are expectedly what you
generally use in mathematics so
you see the the plus sign here which is
for addition you see the minus sign
which is for subtraction you see the
star sign which is for multiplication
you see the slash sign which is for
division and you see the percentage sign
which is for finding the remainder of
our division so let's see an example of
each of these and how we can use them in
a java program so for the arithmetic
operations i have prepared a
demonstration of it in the eclipse ide
again i'm using the same java project
which i've shown you we created in the
previous lectures so i will for all the
demonstrations i will just continue on
the same project so
again the way to create a class remains
the same exactly the same as how i
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also i created a class i
named the class as arithmetic demo and i
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class and i have
basically tried to demonstrate each of
the operation so let's start with the
addition operation first
so i create an integer variable here
named as result and then i try to use
the addition operator to make this
variable store the result of this
addition so it's a simple one plus two
you can also create two different
variables for one and two let's say x
equal to one and y equal to two and you
can also do int result equal to x plus y
it will have the same effect but just
for simplicity i have put the literal
numbers here so result is storing the
the expression value of 1 plus 2 and
then i'm printing this value here you
can see i'm printing the result variable
here with using
system.out.println then i'm storing this
result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then i'm trying
to subtract something from it so now i'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so i'm printing the
original result and
then what i'm doing that i'm again
assigning the new result which is 2 to
the original result so now original
result and result both are at 2 then i
move ahead and i try to demonstrate the
multiplication operation so i take the
same variable result and i say multiply
it by 2. so whatever the value of result
was which at this place should be 2
multiply that value by 2. so 2 into 2
the new value of result should become 4
after this multiplication operation and
again i'm assigning the value of
original result to this particular
variable and then i'm showcasing the
fourth mathematical arithmetic operation
which is division so you can see result
by 2 here so basically whatever the
current value of result is i'm dividing
that value by 2 so 4 divided by 2 should
become 2 so again the new value of the
result variable should become 2
then i am printing the value and again
storing the value
back into the original result then the
next operation is again an addition
operation where i whatever the value of
result is at this particular point which
is 2
add 8 to that particular value so the
new result value becomes 10
and then i'm printing that particular
value again assigning the original
result to the result and then to
showcase the remainder operation
i'm doing result
we call this particular operator as mod
or modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is
in this case would be 10 so i'm saying
10 mod 7
so 10 mod 7 would become 3 because if we
divide 10 by 7 the remainder should be 3
and this modulus operator is used to
calculate the remainder of a division
operation so that 3 will be stored in
this result variable and then we print
that particular variable so that is what
i am doing if i take you back up there
i'll just minimize this window and this
window as well so if i take you back to
the starting
i'm doing an addition first here at line
seven then i am doing a subtraction at
line twelve
then i'm doing a multiplication at line
and a division at line 22
and then again an addition at line 27
and then a modulus at line 32 and i'm
printing the respective values
so let us run this program and see what
results do we get so i right click i go
to run as i go to java application there
is also a shortcut for it if you want to
use the shortcut you can use that so i
click on this and the output is is
displayed here so you can see let me
bring this output back to its original
position yeah i just dragged it here to
the top to the bottom so if we start
from the top and see what all results
did we get printed so line 9 says 1 plus
2 equal to the value of result so 1 plus
2 equal to at this particular point the
result value was 3 because 1 plus 2
equal to 3
moving on the next variable here is
minus so the current value was 3 we said
3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we store
the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3 then a string here
minus 1 equal to so this is just a
string
and then the actual current result value
which is 2. so far so good we move ahead
and then at line 19 we are multiplying
the current value of result by 2 and
again displaying the original result and
the current value so
2 is the original result here because
here 3 minus 1 had become 2 so original
result value was 2 multiply that by 2
becomes 4
then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4 by
2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2 the
current value of result then again
moving on to the next variable
at line 29 now the result value should
become 10 because 2 plus 8 is 10 and
again we are printing the original
result and then the current result value
so the original result was 2 then we
added 8 to it and the new result value
had become 10 which is coming from this
particular variable
moving on to line 34 we are again
printing the original result which was
10 here
and then we are saying this particular
string which is modulus 7 and the
current value of result is coming from
this expression which is 10 modulus 7
and like i said modulus or mod operation
is basically used to calculate the
remainder of a division operation which
so 10 divided by 7 remainder is 3 so
that becomes 3 and that's why you see
the value 3 so this is a demonstration
to show you how we can use the addition
multiplication subtraction division and
modulus operators which are all the
arithmetic operators so in the next
session we will be discussing about the
other operator types which are unary
operators and we will also discuss some
other interesting operators which are
popularly used in java let's get started
with junary operators so when we talk
about unary operators technically they
are also arithmetic operators but they
provide us a shorthand or they have a
more advanced meaning so if you see on
the screen
these are the unary operators
we call them as unary plus unary minus
increment operator
decrement operator and logical
complement operator so when we talk
about the unity plus operator basically
it is used to indicate a positive value
so whatever value you are having it will
just make that number as positive number
you might be wondering that this plus
has an addition meaning as well right
which we saw in the previous example yes
that's correct but when we use that
addition symbol we use that between two
variables but when we talk about unary
operators they are used with a single
variable that is why the name unary
because they are used with a single
variable they require only one operand
so
unary plus basically makes any number
positive generally minus negates an
expression and makes that number
negative
increment operator increments the value
by plus 1
decrement operator decreases the value
by minus 1 and logical complement
operator inverts the value of the
expression from true to false or false
to true let's understand this with the
help of an example so i have created a
class here called unary demo and i have
a static void main method here and i
have created a variable called result
and the first example is about using
unary plus so i'm creating a variable
called as result assigning the value as
one and just putting one plus in front
of it which makes this as positive value
though we can argue that this also has
the same effect as this and yes that is
true but in case if this value was
written as
something like minus 1 instead of plus
then we could basically make that number
positive by just putting plus in front
of it so that's basically the power of
unary operators and that's how you
generally use unary operators so i just
put it back to plus one the next example
is about decrement operators so the
current value of result was one because
we did this now we are saying result
minus minus which means whatever the
value of result is
just decrement it by 1. so the current
value was 1 so now the new value of
result after this evaluation becomes 0.
so at line 14 we print the current value
of result which is 0. moving on at line
16 we are using the increment plus plus
operator here which means whatever the
current value of result is just
increment it by 1
so the current value of result was 0
till this line so it becomes 1 because
this means increment by 1 so line 18
will basically print that value
1 and then at line 20 i am using the
unary minus operator which means
whatever the value of result is just
negate it just put a negative in front
of it just make that number negative so
if i just say minus result the current
value of result was 1 so it became -1
and then to showcase the negation
operation i created a boolean variable
named it as success
assign the value of this variable as
false and printed the value of success
variable as is first
and then printed the value of success
with a negation in front of it with an
exclamation mark which will basically
flip the value or invert the value of a
boolean variable so if this was false
line 28 should print true if this was
true
line 28 should print false in this case
this is false so the line 28 should
print true so let's right click on this
and run this program and see if we get
the expected output and yes we see the
output here so let's try to interpret
the output now
the line 10 should print 1
yes
then line 14 should print 0 we see 0
here
line 18 should print 1 because we use
the increment plus plus so 0 plus 1
became 1
then we use the unary minus operator so
the value should become -1 yes we see
minus 1 here and then for boolean
variable we should see first the false
because the value is printed as is and
then we are printing a negated value so
we should flip the value from false to
true and yes it is printing the value as
true so this was about unary operators
now when we talk about this increment
and decrement operators what if i put
this particular value in front of result
what effect is that going to happen
let's analyze that part as well so for
that i have prepared a separate demo
again i've created a class called pre
post demo and it has a public static
void main method i'm declaring an
integer variable i with the value as 3
so the i becomes 3 here and then i'm
saying i plus plus
as we have already seen in the unary
demo example this should increment the
value of 3 to 4
so it will print 4 expected right then
at line number 9 i am putting this plus
plus in front of i now what will happen
now
it is going to increment the value of i
and then basically assigning the value
of i so the whole difference between i
plus plus and plus plus i is that
in this case
the value of i is assigned first and
increment later in this case the value
of i is incremented first and assigned
later so here the value from 4 becomes 5
so at line 11 if you see if we print i
it will print five because we have we
are saying that first increment the
value and then update the value of i so
increment happens on i equal to four and
i becomes five
at line number thirteen it becomes more
interesting because here inside the
system.out.println statement itself i'm
saying plus plus i now what will happen
like i explained
first the value will be incremented and
then the value will be assigned so
before printing the value is getting
incremented so the value from 5 becomes
6 here at line 13 but if i try to do
this
now i am saying
first assign the value of i
and then increment it so i at this line
is still 6
because i has already been assigned 6
and as the post increment says
if you put this plus plus after the
variable it means that you are first
assigning the value and then
incrementing the value so anything which
happens after line 15
the value of i will become 7 but at line
15 the value of i is still 6 because we
are using a post increment operator so
the value is still assigned to i as is
and then incremented and when we do
system.out.println the assigned value is
printed not the incremented value
so like i said after line 15 the value
of i will become incremented by 1 and it
will become 7. so hope you understood
this example or and the difference
between the pre-increment and post
increment remember the thumb rule that
if we put plus plus before a variable
like at line number 9 the value will be
incremented first and then assigned so
at line 13
the updated value will be printed
because the first we are doing the
increment and then we are printing the
value for assigning the value similarly
at line 15 we are first printing the
value and then incrementing the value so
when the value is printed at line 15 the
old value of i will be printed but after
line 15 the new value of i will be
accessible to the program so let's right
click on this and run this program
and now if we see the values we assigned
i to 3 we did a post increment here so i
becomes 4 we print the value of i so
here the value of i is 4 we see 4 here
then at line line
9 we are saying plus plus i so 4 plus 1
becomes 5 though this is a pre-increment
but since we are not printing this plus
plus i as is
it does not have any any change so the
value of 4 becomes 5 at line 11 we print
5 then at line 13 we are saying plus
plus i which means increment the value
of i first and then assign it so the
value of 5 becomes 6 and then i gets
updated and printed similarly at line 15
first the value of i is assigned and
printed and then incremented so at line
15 the value is still 6
you see this 6 here and then the value
is incremented so after line 15 the
value becomes 7 so that's how we are
basically
using the unary operators and this is
where i would like to end this
particular session in the next session
we will be discussing about other type
of operators which are comparison
operators and logical operators etc
let's get started with equality and
relational operators when we talk about
relational operators they are sometimes
also called comparison operators and the
basic idea behind using these operators
is to compare things or compare the
values of variables or compare the
objects in java so in java if you need
to compare anything for example if you
want to compare if something is less
than the other thing or something is
greater than the other thing or
something is equal to the other thing
then you need to use the comparison
operators which are provided by java
here you can see i have opened the
official java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators
so you can see if i want to compare if
an object or a value is equal to another
value then i use the double equal sign
if i want to compare for non-equality i
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if i want to do
a greater than comparison then i will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if i want to do the greater than equal
to or less than or less than equal to
they again follow the same kind of
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
i have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static void main method inside
this class and this method has two
variables of integer type called value
one and value two value one has a value
one and value two has the value two and
then i am trying to compare the value 1
and value 2 variables using the
different relational operators we just
covered for doing that i need to use a
conditional operator as well we will be
covering conditional operators in much
much detail in the upcoming lectures but
for now you can understand that when we
talk about conditional operators we talk
about if an else statement so if is
again a keyword in java which can be
used to compare things and the syntax is
very straightforward you write the if
keyword and then you write the actual
comparison syntax or the actual
comparison expression so in the first
example we can see that i am writing a
condition which says evaluate if value 1
is equal to value 2. i should put a
curly braces around here you can see
there are no curly braces here but that
is for a case when you have only one
statement under it but again i will
cover this in detail and i don't want to
confuse the audience here so i will just
put curly braces around all of these if
statements so that it becomes easy to
interpret what is actually going on in
these code blocks as we know that these
curly braces are used to define a code
block so the first if block says compare
if the value 1 is equal to the value 2
if yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10. if this condition is
not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will executed otherwise line 14
will not be executed similarly in this
condition i'm saying compare if value 1
is greater than value 2 or not so if the
actual value holded by value 1 variable
is greater than the value 2 variable
then this condition will become true and
the line 18 will be executed otherwise
it will be skipped then similarly at
line 20 i am doing the reverse i'm
comparing if value 1 is less than equal
less than value 2. if that is the case
then line 22 will be executed otherwise
it will be skipped and at last i'm also
showcasing an example of less than equal
to operator that you put less than and
equal to together and again you compare
the two variables similarly you can also
use greater than equal to variable
comparison operator as well in this
example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than less
than and less than equal to let's run
this example to understand so for
running the example i will just right
click here go to run as and click on
java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2.
similarly if i talk about the next
condition which was if value 1 is not
equal to value 2 then execute statement
14 and yes 1 is not equal to 2 that's
why we see this particular
system.out.println here you see this
printed moving on is value 1 greater
than value 2 so is 1 greater than 2 no
it's not so line 18 will never be
executed then the next one is is value 1
less than value 2 so yes 1 is less than
2 so line 22 will be executed and we see
the line 22 output here
system.out.printer and output moving on
is 1 less than equal to 2 yes 1 is less
than equal to 2 so this particular
condition is also true and line 26 will
be executed and that's why we see this
here and that's all so we can see that
we are able to use these comparison or
relational operators to evaluate
different conditions and we write those
conditions using the if block and again
if you do not understand the if block
fully don't worry we will be covering
the if blocks in detail but the focus
here is in using the operators the not
equal to operators the greater than
equal to operators less than equal to
operators etc so i hope these operators
give you better understanding of how to
use them now moving on to the next
section of this comparison operators
sometimes we also use some logical terms
to do the comparison for example if i
just move down here and i show you these
conditions here we call them conditional
operators conditional operators are used
to evaluate the conditions like and or
or and we use them in two two ways
either we can use it as ampersand or
double ampersand or we can use them as
pipe or double pipes so the idea is
basically to evaluate if one condition
is true and other condition is also true
or one condition is true or other
condition is true so whenever you want
to combine two conditions together
that's where you're going to use these
logical operators or conditional
operators you can also use the simple
english keywords like and or or or you
can use the logical representation of
these keywords for example ampersand
ampersand or double amp percent is
equivalent to and similarly double pipe
is equivalent to or so we can use these
as well interchangeably you can
use either of these operator
representations to run a conditional
check in composition meaning you can
compare two conditions saying okay if
one is true and second is true or one is
true or second is true so the whole
focus is here in and and or comparisons
so let's switch back to the ide and
let's look at an example of this to
understand this in detail so i will
again take the similar kind of example
again i have created two variables here
value one and value two value one has
value as 1 and second variable value 2
has value as 2 and then i'm writing two
conditions this time in the same if
block you can see i am writing first
condition saying is value 1 equal to
equal to 1 and is value 2 also equal to
equal to 2 so this whole if condition is
only going to be true only if both of
the conditions are true that's the
property of and and will force that both
the conditions on the left hand side of
it and the right hand side of it hold
true and then only the whole expression
is going to hold true even if one of the
conditions evaluate to false the whole
if expression will evaluate to false
similarly for or or conditions we again
write a left hand condition and a right
hand condition and in between we write
this double pipe we can also write or or
in english that will also have the same
effect and this will evaluate in a way
that this whole expression this whole
expression will evaluate to true if even
a single condition either on left side
or right side of it becomes true so r
will just need one expression to be true
to make the whole if condition true
whereas and will force both of the
conditions to be true to make the whole
expression as true so and will require
two truths to actually become true but
our condition will require only one true
to become true so if we try to do uh
understand this logic here i am saying
that if value 1 is equal to equal to 1
which is correct and value 2 is equal to
equal to 2 then make this condition as
true so yes in this case this condition
will evaluate to true because value 1
has value 1 1 and value 2 has value as 2
so it will print the line 10 whereas in
the next condition i'm saying evaluate
if value 1 is equal to equal to 1 or
value 2 is equal to equal to 1 so either
of the expression if becomes true either
the left side this expression or the
right side this expression either of the
expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
if i write it like this
then we know that value 1 is not equal
to 4 because it's 1 and value 2 is not
equal to 5 because it's true in that
case both of the expression will become
false and then line 14 will not be
executed if i write it like this then
the left hand expression is evaluated to
true because value 1 is 1 but the right
hand expression is false but it's fine
the line 14 will still be executed
because either of these side is true so
the whole expression becomes true
similarly here and will require both of
the expressions to be true and if either
of them becomes false the whole
expression becomes false so in the
current state line 10 will be executed
but if i change this to this then the
left hand side of this ampersand will
evaluate to false and the whole
expression will evaluate to false in
that case and line 10 will never be
executed let's try to run all of these
scenarios to make a better understanding
of this
so in this case both of the conditions
should work fine so i will just right
click and run as java application and
yes we see this line 10 being printed
and we also see this line 13 being
printed so both of the lines are printed
correctly both of the conditions are
evaluating to true now let's try to play
around with it let me change this value
to 4 so now value 1 this left hand side
expression is false which should make
the whole expression as false and it
should not print the line 10 which is
this statement so let's run this program
and see if that works
yes we see that this particular line is
not printed now because this whole
expression became false because the left
hand side of this expression became
false similarly in the r case either of
them have to have to be true you can see
currently value 2 equal to equal to 5
condition will actually result in a
false condition because this is not a
true value 2 is actually 2 not 5 and
still we see this particular expression
because either of them have to be true
if i make both of them as not true now
both of the conditions on the left hand
side of pipe and right hand side of pipe
are false conditions what will happen
now nothing will be printed the reason
for that is that value 1 is also that
this condition is also false and value
two condition is also false so the whole
expression became false and this was
already false so this is all i wanted to
cover in this lecture we covered our
about the comparison operators and how
to use them and in the next lecture we
are going to talk about the bitwise
operators let's get started with bitwise
operators now bitwise operators are very
less commonly used in the java
programming world generally we don't use
them and generally we don't need to use
them you would generally use them when
you are doing really complex bit wise
calculation where you need to manipulate
the bits now what are actually bits so
if you remember when we talked about the
integer type variables we talked about
how much memory each of the variable
type or data type was going to consume
we said that this will take one byte and
this will take two bytes etc one byte is
basically made up of eight bits and bits
are nothing but positions where either a
zero is stored or one is stored actually
the whole machine will convert your
whole program ultimately in zeros and
ones which are nothing but bits so if
you want to do the manipulation at that
level so now you can understand you are
you are actually working at right at the
machine level understanding so if you
want to manipulate the bits which are
going to be understood by the machine at
that level then you can use bitwise
operators but like i said generally we
don't need to use them now when we talk
about bitwise operators there are
multiple ways in which we can use them
we can use them with the standard and or
or operations if you remember we covered
this and or operations in the previous
lecture you see a difference here that
in case of and we are using a single
ampersand or and not double ampersand
this is one of the concept which we did
not covered in the previous lecture and
i would just like to brief you about
this concept that if you use double
ampersand that is also called a short
circuit operator and if you use a single
ampersand that is called a standard
operator to build an understanding about
this i will just quickly recap of what
we covered in the last lecture and we'll
try to explain these concepts as well so
let's go to the logical operator demo
and here if you remember there were two
ampersands and two pipes
this is also a valid expression a single
ampersand is also a valid expression the
only change is
in this case
even if the left hand condition
evaluates to false
still the right hand condition will be
evaluated although we know that in case
of and either of the expression needs to
be false and the whole expression
becomes false so java provides an
advantage or with that if you use double
ampersand and if the left hand operation
becomes false then it will not cover the
right hand operation it will not even
evaluate the right hand operation
because it doesn't matter if the left
hand operation has already returned to
false or evaluated to false then no
matter whether right side is true or
false the whole expression is still
going to be false right that's the
property of and
one of these side has to be false and
the whole expression becomes false so
why why evaluate two sides why waste the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer
by just evaluating the left hand
condition and if the left hand condition
is false it will skip evaluating the
right hand condition and just make the
whole expression false but if you use
this
a single ampersand then both side of the
expression will be evaluated
irrespective of their output so in this
case
even if the left hand expression is
false it is still going to evaluate the
right side expression and similarly it
works for the or case as well in this
case in our case as we know if one of
the condition is true the whole
condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if you use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right hand side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so the left hand side is already true it
will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the
single ampersand being used for bitwise
just to explain why it why it is used
and how it is used for or operations in
bitwise you use this cap or whatever you
want to call it as and for
the inclusive bitwise or
or operation you're going to use a
single pipe you also use some shift
operations where you shift the value of
bit of a particular variable to either
left or right again these are again very
complex calculations if you want to use
that please read about this and use that
but in the in today's demo what we are
going to cover
is the and and or examples of bitwise
operations
so here i have again created a class
called bitwise operator i have a public
static void main method i have two
variables here which are int a equal to
five
and into b equal to seven now these five
and seven
are actually stored as bits as zeros and
ones in the computer's memory so how
they are actually stored they are stored
in a standard bit representation which
you may have
studied in your mathematics if to give
you a recap this 5 will basically be
written in a memory as this
0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2 raised
to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2 raised to
power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2 raised to
power 2
into 1 becomes 4 and 2 raised to power 3
into 0 becomes 0 so 4 0 plus 4 plus 0
plus 1 becomes 5 and that's how 5 is
displayed to you similarly for 7 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 plus 2
raised to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 1 plus
2 3 plus 2 raised to power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 1 plus
2 plus 4 7 and 2 raised to power 3 into
0 is 0. so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 which
is 7 and that's how this 7 is built and
stored and now if you try to do this if
you try to write this condition you can
also write the condition into a
system.out.println block and it will
basically evaluate this condition so now
if you say a and b
in this case this is going to do a
bitwise operation because this is
bitwise operand it is going to do a
bitwise operation and what would be the
result if you do an and on this so again
use the same logic as if in case of and
if one is false then the whole
expression is false
so 0 and 0 becomes 0
and 1 becomes 1
0 and 1
becomes 0 because 0 means false and 1
means true so if either of them is false
the whole evaluation becomes false so
that's why 0 or and 1 becomes 0 and 1
and one is always one the value of this
is again five as we already have
evaluated similarly if you do a bitwise
or and if you do this again we are doing
an or operation so zero or zero are
basically false or false becomes false
true or
true becomes true false or true should
be true because one of them needs to be
true so this is false but this is true
so the whole value becomes true and the
finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to the power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7
and plus 2 raised to power 3 into 0
which is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1
becomes 7 and that's how you get
actually 7. so let's see if we get 5 or
7 in this bit wise operation yes we can
see the values as 5 and 7 so this is a
bitwise operation happening similarly
you can also use the shift operations
where in case if you're using the this
particular kind of representation or
this particular kind of representation
they are called which they are called
left shift and right shift operations so
if you use this in front of a variable
then
for example this one will be shifted
here and this zero will be shifted here
and this one will be shifted here so
that's how the whole value is going to
shift all bits are going to shift one by
one towards left similarly if you are
using the right shift then all the bits
are going to be shifted towards right by
one bit that's the whole concept of left
shift and right shift bitwise operations
and if you want to know more about this
please read some official examples from
the java doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this
so this is all i wanted to cover in this
lecture so in the next session we are
going to talk about
the control flow statements like if else
etc let's get started with control flow
statements so what are control flow
statements and why do we need them
control flow statements are the ones
which can help you control and define
the flow of execution in your program
now why do we need them is because if we
want to evaluate some conditions or we
want to create some branches of
execution saying that if this condition
becomes true do this and if this
condition becomes false do that so you
can see there are two different branches
of execution of a program in this kind
of approach and that's where control
flow statements can help us there are a
lot of different types of control flow
statements like if then else and switch
and for and while and do while and we
are going to cover all of them in detail
in this series so let's get started with
the first one which is the if statement
we covered briefly about this when we
talked about operators and i promised
you guys that i will be covering this in
detail and this is the session where
will we we will go deeper into this
concept as we have already understood
that if condition is basically used to
evaluate a condition if it is true or
false the result of an if statement will
always have only two values it can
either have a true value or it can have
a false value there is no other
possibility or there is no other value
of an if statement or of an if
expression now like i explained if you
want to do a simple uh programming
execution where you say if a particular
condition becomes true do this
and if this becomes false then do that
it means you need to write this else
condition as well that if this doesn't
hold true what do i do and how do i
write that so let's understand that with
the help of an example for this
particular example i've created a class
and there is a public static void main
method which is the entry point of this
program's execution i have a variable
which is called test score this is an
integer variable with the value 76 and i
have a care variable which is grade
basically what i'm doing that based on
the test score marks i'm trying to
define the grades which a student will
get so for that i have built a condition
here so you can see it starts with if
which is a keyword then you put these
standard braces or brackets and you
write your condition inside it in this
case i am writing the condition saying
that if test score
is greater than equal to 90
then the student should get and grade a
so here i have defined this grade
variable and here i am just assigning
the value to the grade variable at line
11 if the test score is greater than 90
the grade should be a but what if the
score is not 90 what if this condition
becomes false and you want to do
something
in that case you can write this else
block here we call this else block so
you write else as the keyword you start
the curly braces and then you define the
grade if the score is not greater than
90 what should be the grade of the
student so in this case we are saying
the grade is f so if we try to run this
example in our in our mind we see that
the value is of the test score is 76
so 76 is not greater than equal to 90 so
this particular condition will not be
true so line 11 will not be executed but
instead
else block will be executed because if
the condition goes false then else block
should be executed as per java so this
block will be executed and grade will
get a value of f
and then we are printing this grade
value by just writing a
system.out.println a string plus the
value so let's run this particular
program and see what happens
we get a grade equal to f here in this
cis out or
system.out.println because this
condition was false so the control the
flow of the control of the program went
to line 12 and then to line 30 because
this was the else block so this is one
understanding where we can write an if
and else logic you in some cases you
might not need an else block so else
block is not mandatory it's an optional
block if you want to remove this and if
you just want to do a sis out here that
is also fine cis out means
system.out.println
for shorthand we sometimes call it as
sis out so you can do something here as
well if you don't need the else block if
you need this block feel free to write
it but this is an optional block but in
some cases your conditions will be more
complicated than just a single condition
if you try to understand it from a real
world example in real world you will not
have only two grades as a and f you will
have more grades right a b c d so on so
forth so what are you going to do in
that case
for that kind of case
java provides us with an keyword which
is called else if else if is just a
continuation of if saying that okay if
this condition doesn't hold true
evaluate the next one with an else if so
i've commented out this code let me put
this code back into its place and then
we will walk through this code to
understand it okay so i have put the
code back to where it should be and this
is how it looks like so let's just walk
through this the line 10 and 11 doesn't
change it's still the same but then i
have added some additional conditions
saying that okay if the score is greater
than equal to 90 the grade should be a
but if the score is
not greater than 90
but greater than equal to 80 then the
grade should be b
similarly if the score is not even
greater than 80 but greater than equal
to 70 then the grade should be c
similarly if the score is not even
greater than equal to 70 but greater
than equal to 60 which means basically
between 60 to 70 then the grade should
be d
and if the score is even below 60 then
the grid should be f so you can see i
have basically defined the whole logic
for defining the grades here and it
always works in a top down approach one
by one the way in the sequence in which
you will define the else if block will
be the sequence in which they will be
executed so after the condition at line
10 and if this condition fails
line 12 will be naturally executed if
this condition also fails line 14 will
be executed
and so on so forth it will never be the
case that if this condition fails then
suddenly line 16 is executed and then
again line 12 is executed it will always
work in a line by line fashion so make
sure whenever you are using the else if
statements
write it in a sequence in which you want
the natural program to be executed so
this is all we have here and now let's
try to run this example let me just
bring the system dot out dot println
align up save this file right click run
as
java application so we see the value is
grade equal to c which means
this particular code block was actually
executed only this condition held true
now that now let's try to understand how
this happened the value was 76 so 76
greater than 90 no this condition
becomes false so line 11 is never
executed it naturally goes to line 12
because that's where we have defined the
next else if block
is 76 greater than equal to 80 no it's
not so line 12 condition also becomes
false line 13 never gets executed and
the control shifts to line 14 and there
we have the condition saying that is 76
greater than equal to 70. yes this
condition is true so the line 15 gets
executed and once this condition gets
true
none of the further conditions will be
executed because you only need one true
statement one true execution in the
whole if else if block if that one code
block
gets true that code block is executed
and then the execution jumps out of the
if else if blocks and it will directly
go to line 22 and it will execute that
had it been the case that this
particular block was also evaluated to
false it would go to line 16 and if this
was also false it would go to the block
which is else block let's see that let's
make this value as 56 so now
56 is not greater than 70 so line 15
will never be executed because this
condition will evaluate to false 56 is
greater than 60 no so this will also be
false and ultimately the grade should
fall to
else block where we are assigning the
grade as f let's see yes we get the grid
f because ultimately this block was
executed because all of the above
conditions evaluated to false so this is
all i wanted to cover in this if else if
demo there is another addition of
another way of writing if statements
which we call as nested if where we have
an if block inside an if block inside an
if block and so on so forth how do we
write that and how does the control
flows in that kind of an execution we
will cover that in the next session
let's get started with using nested if
statements in java now in the previous
lecture we saw how we can use an if else
block and also an if else if else block
but there is another case where we can
use these if statements and that is when
you have nested if blocks when would you
use it let's take an example let's say
you have multiple conditions to check on
a particular program and where the
output of the first condition is the
input of the second condition and the
output of the second condition is the
input to the third condition and so on
so forth if you have that kind of
situation you can write it in a nested
if statement kind of block so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as you can see i have opened an
example here which is about nested if
statements i've created a class which
which is named as nested if demo and i
have created a public static void main
method inside this particular class and
now i have declared an integer variable
with the value 50 then i am checking the
first condition saying if i equal to
equal to 50. if that condition is true
then i will check the next condition
which is if i is less than 75 and then i
am adding one more hypothetical
condition saying if this is true then
also check if i is less than 55 so you
can see if i equal to 50 holds true then
only this condition will be executed
similarly if i is less than 75 then only
this condition will be executed so they
are dependent upon each other this
condition block is dependent upon the
previous block to be true and this if
condition block is dependent upon this
if block to be true if either of these
if blocks don't go true the next
subsequent nested if block will not be
executed so in this case i am checking
it for first equality condition saying
if the value is equal to 50 then execute
this statement at line number 10 then
check if i is less than 75 if that is
also true execute the statement at light
number 12 and then if i is also less
than 55 then also execute line number
14. i can also add an else block as well
anywhere in this nested hierarchy if i
want to if i add an else block here that
else block will be corresponding to this
block if i add an else block here and
that else block will be corresponding to
this if block and if i add an else block
here then that else block will be
corresponding to this particular if
block so you can also use those else if
and else blocks as well with nested if
blocks and make it as complicated as you
want it to be so that's about this
program and let's see if we run this
program what output do we get and let's
interpret that output so i'll just right
click run as java program and i see some
output in the console first i get i is
50 so line number 10 gets printed
because i is 50 then i also see the next
line output as i is smaller than 75 it
means this condition was also true
because 50 is less than 75 so line 12
also got executed and then i'm checking
if i is less than 55 so yes 50 is less
than 55 so line 14 also gets executed
and we get this statement on the console
so this was a simple way to see how we
can implement the nested if conditions
now we are also going to talk about
another concept which is used in writing
the if conditional blocks which is
called ternary operators so ternary
operators are used as a shorthand of
writing if else block as you can see
that these if blocks are quite verbose
we have to write a lot of code to
actually write some conditions in this
case i'm executing three conditions but
the code is
almost seven lines or eight lines so we
will see how we can simplify this if we
use a ternary operator and for that i
have created another class which is
called ternary operator demo and this
particular class again has a public
static void main which is the entry
point of this particular program and
then i have declared couple of variables
first is int a equal to 1 and second one
is int b equal to 2. i have also
declared a result variable and we will
see how we can use this result variable
and at line 10 i have written my if else
expression so you can see this if else
expression doesn't look like the one
which we have seen before so let's
understand how do we write it if you're
trying to write an if else expression
with ternary expressions or ternary
statements then the first thing which
you need to understand is the structure
of it so here at first you will specify
the actual condition which you want to
test in your if block so this is my
condition then after that condition you
are going to put a question mark and
after the question mark you are going to
put the actual result which you want to
be executed if this condition becomes
true so if the if condition becomes true
what do you want to do whatever is that
you will write it here and then if the
condition becomes false then the logic
should go into the else block and the
else logic should come after this colon
so all you need to remember is this
question mark and this colon before the
question mark you are going to write the
condition after the question mark you
are going to write the statement which
is going to be executed if this if
condition becomes true and after the
colon you are going to write the else
block condition which is going to be
executed if this condition becomes false
another thing to notice is that ternary
operators can be used only in cases when
you have only one statement to execute
in if block and one statement to execute
in else block it cannot be more than one
statements so instead of this you can
also write
system.out.println here which will also
be fine if i just write this system dot
out dot print not print f but i want to
write println so i'll just write println
you can also do this this is also fine
you don't need to store the result
obviously
but but you can also write this
condition in a way but this all this
only has to be a single statement it
cannot be more than one statement
because this expression can only hold
one statement at a time so use it in
situations where you have to check a
condition and do something in the if
block which is only one statement and
again one statement in the else block
the same expression can also be written
in a verbose if else way in which we
have been saying it before and we'll
also i will also show that to you and
here where this a and b is going this is
getting stored in this variable called
result so if this if condition holds
true then the result is a and this is
going to be stored in here and if it is
going into the else block then b is
going to be stored in the result block
let's run this program so we can see we
get the value 1 because we have set the
condition as a less than b so yes 1 is
less than 2 so this particular statement
gets executed and this value gets stored
here in the result variable so that's
how you can use the ternary operators to
write shorthand if else statements the
same expression can also be written in a
verbose way for example you can write it
in this way saying if a is less than b
then result equal to a else result equal
to b this code has exactly the same
effect as this one line of code so you
can see this is this is pretty uh simple
to write pretty short to write the code
which i'm writing here in four lines can
be written here in one line and that's
the power of ternary operators so this
is all i wanted to cover in today's
session so we talked about nested if
statements and the ternary operators
here how to use them in the next session
we are going to discuss about switch
case statements let's get started with
using switch statements in java so let
us first understand why do we need
switch statements generally whenever you
want to check a condition you can use an
if else block but what if you have
multiple conditions to check what if you
have so many possible execution paths
that it becomes too verbose to write it
into an if else kind of block what if
you have to check on constant values of
certain expressions how do you do that
it becomes even more challenging and the
code becomes even more verbose so in
such cases switch statement can be used
in which you can write switch statement
to have as many possible execution paths
as you want and it will work with
constant values as well so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as how and why will we use the
switch statements so for that i have
created this class which is called
switch demo and it also has a public
static void main method which is the
entry point and in this program what i'm
doing is i'm trying to accept a number
as the month number in the program and
then with that particular number i'm
trying to print the corresponding
month's name so that's the logic pick a
month number and you should get the
month's actual name so now in this case
you can you can imagine there will be at
least 12 if else if blocks which is a
long line of if else statements at the
same time if we try to do this for other
conditions where the value is constant
please understand that the value of
month is going to be constant it's going
to be the same number so it's not
similar to you evaluating a condition
it's similar to you evaluating a
condition to a particular constant value
imagine if you have to do some sort of a
classification of employees in higher
salaries and lower salaries and there
are hundreds of salary bands in the
company so are you going to write 100
afl's logics that is going to take a
long time and then what if new bends get
new bands get introduced then it gets
even more complex so we will use switch
case statements in cases where there are
lots of if else conditions and the
expression evaluates to a constant value
remember in the if else cases the
expression evaluates to a boolean value
so here uh i'm supplying the month value
as six then i'm also creating a string
month one string variable just to print
or store the name of the month and then
the way you write the switch statement
is to write the switch keyword and then
in the brackets you supply the month
integer value and then you start writing
your conditions so you can see you write
the case as keyword and then you write
the number or the possible values this
particular variable or this particular
expression can hold so all the possible
values this particular expression can
hold will be written individually as
cases so case equal to 1 here 1 means
the value of month is 1 in that case the
month string which we created here shall
store january and then we see a
statement called break so break is again
a keyword in java and this keyword has a
special meaning it has a special usage
you will use the keyword break to
abruptly break the control of execution
from the current code block and the code
block is identified with curly braces so
here you can see the curly brace starts
from here and it ends
down to line number 51 at here so the
moment your java program is going to
encounter this particular statement it
is going to jump out of the current code
block execution and continue thereafter
that's the basic logic and usage of
break statement so use it whenever you
want to skip the rest of the code after
the break statement if you don't want to
execute the rest of the code you will
write break and the moment the java
program sees this particular statement
it will jump out of the current code
block specified by the curly braces and
will resume execution after the code
block so in this case it will resume the
execution after the line 51. that's the
usage and the meaning of this expression
called break so in this case we are
saying that if the month value is 1
which we denoted as here case 1 then
store the value of the month string as
january and break out of this particular
code block because we don't need to
execute any further we have found a
match then another case would be if the
month value is 2 so you write case which
is a keyword and then the exact
expression value the constant value
which is two and if that's the case then
month string becomes february and again
you break because in this particular
case there will only be one condition
true at a time there will never be a
case that month with the value 2 will
have two meanings will have two month
names a month with the value 2 will
always have a meaning called february it
will never have two meanings or two
month names attached to the same integer
value and that's why you do not want to
execute any further and that's why you
write this break statement if you do not
write this base statement it is going to
evaluate all of the cases one by one
even if the cases are not going to be
true but it is going to waste lot of
processing time evaluating all the case
conditions which you have written here
which does not make sense because we
know that only one condition at a time
can be true here because we are
evaluating and checking for a constant
value which is an integer value so
that's the reason we put a break in each
case if intentionally if you want to
check multiple cases do not put a break
statement but the program can become
really confusing in that case so take
your wise call so here we put a break in
each case similarly case three the month
string becomes march case four the month
string becomes april case five becomes
may case six becomes june case seven we
have one string as july case eight month
string is august
case 9 we store the monstring as
september case 10 as october case 11 as
november and case 12 as december after
that you will also see an interesting
block called default this is the another
capability of switch statement that what
if none of the above conditions hold
true what if we specify a value which is
not between 1 and 12 and it will not
match any of the cases which we saw just
above and if you want to execute some
code in that case if none of the
conditions matches you may want to
execute some default execution also in
such cases you are going to use default
default is the code block which will be
executed if none of the case matches so
here you can see that if none of the
cases match then we are going to store
the value of month string variable as
invalid month and then we'll eventually
break out and once we break out of this
program we just want to print the month
string that's all we are doing in this
program that we take an integer value as
the month number and then we print the
corresponding month name here by looking
at the case blocks and we also default
define our default case block if none of
the conditions hold true so let's run
this program we have specified the value
as 6 which should result in the month
name as june and yes we can see we get
june let's change the value and let's
put the value as 10 and see what do we
get so right click run as java
application and we got october yes
exactly correct let's put an invalid
value as 13 and let's see what happens
now now we get invalid month so our
default code block just got executed
because we entered a value which is not
matching any of the case conditions
which we have specified so this is how
you are going to use the switch and case
statements while writing your conditions
whenever your condition evaluates to
multiple constant values remember the
the key here is to understand if your
expression is evaluating to multiple
constant values which do not change and
in those cases using a switch case block
is a better idea than writing if else
statements so that is all what we are
going to cover in today's session and in
the next session we are going to
understand something about
two-dimensional arrays and
multi-dimensional arrays as well let's
get started with understanding arrays in
detail we have been talking about arrays
throughout this course of java in the
previous sessions as well and we have
covered some basic understanding of how
to create arrays how to declare them how
to fill values in the array and how do
we print the array with positions as
well as the array as whole but whatever
examples which we took previously were
one dimensional arrays because arrays
can have more than one dimensions as
well you can create a one-dimensional
array you can create a two-dimensional
array you can create even a
three-dimensional array and you can go
up to as many dimensions as you can
handle in your java program so it
depends upon the kind of complexity you
want to have in your program and the
kind of values the kind of structure you
are going to store in your arrays and
based on that need you can choose
whether you want to use a 1d array or
one dimensional array or a 2d array or a
3d array and so on in these sessions we
are going to talk about 1d arrays 2d
arrays and 3d arrays and after that
we'll leave up to you to try out more
dimensionals if you want to we have
already covered the basic array
structures which were one-dimensional
arrays so i will just give you a quick
walkthrough of how we actually handled
one dimensional arrays so this is a
sample program to demonstrate
one-dimensional arrays if you remember
this is how we use to create arrays we
write the data type of the array and
then we write the square boxes which
denote that this is an integer array
data type we assign a variable to this
and then we initialize the array with
the size 4. so new is the keyword which
is used to initialize anything in java
and we are going to use this heavily
when we talk about classes and objects
and even collections literally any
object which you want to create in java
requires a new keyword so here i am
writing new and then int4 which means
create an array of size 4 and then i'm
filling the value of the four positions
which i have created as part of this
array and if you remember when we create
these kind of arrays we store them in a
zero index based position the first
value gets stored at zeroth index
position and then so on so forth so it
will always start from zero and never
start from one remember that and after
that we just print all the values of
individual positions of the elements in
the array and if i just run this program
all of the elements of this particular
array should be printed one by one so if
i just show the full console of the
output we can see that element in index
0 was 10 element index 1 was 20 element
at index 2 was 30 and element at index 3
was 40. so this was just a quick
refresher of how one dimensional arrays
can be written and whenever you declare
a very simplistic array it will
generally be a one-dimensional array now
let's look at the two-dimensional arrays
and how do we write them when do we need
them for that i have created another
example which is says two-dimensional
array i just created a class and it has
a public static void main method and
i've created a two-dimensional array
this time so let's understand this
two-dimensional array in a bit detail
and when do we need that generally you
would need to use two-dimensional arrays
whenever you are trying to do any matrix
calculations
if you if you understand what do you
mean by matrix it's basically a two by
two structure which stores the values in
the form of rows and columns
so imagine a table of two rows and two
columns then it will be a two by two
matrix so if you want to store that
particular table in a java program you
would need to store that as a matrix as
a two-dimensional matrix rows being the
one dimensional and column being the
other dimension and that's what we are
doing here and if you want to
store that 2d matrix in a java program
the approach and the procedure for it is
pretty similar to how you create a
one-dimensional array with slight
changes
the first change is instead of a single
square bracket you are going to write
two square brackets because it is a two
dimensional array so remember the number
of square brackets you are going to put
while initializing and declaring the
array is the number of dimensions which
your array is going to have since this
is a two dimensional array example
that's why you see two brackets here if
this was a three dimensional array
example you will see three array three
square brackets here and so on so forth
so that's the first part of it second
part to understand is to how to store
the data remember i told you always
imagine the structure of rows and
columns whenever you are trying to store
a two-dimensional array in java so what
are rows and what are values and how do
you represent them while you declare and
initialize a two-dimensional array so
you start with the curly braces as a
normal 1d array but inside the curly
braces you create nested curly braces
blocks we can see three blocks here they
start with their own curly brace and end
with their own then this curly brace
starts here and ends here and then this
curly brace starts here and ends here
idea is that you provide this outer
curly braces to define the overall
structure and then inside each of the
curly braces is going to represent a row
in your two-dimensional array so each of
these
values this blocks is going to represent
a row so i can say that this is the
first row this is the second row and
this is the third row and if i try to
visualize it in terms of columns then
this is the first row first column
first row second column first row third
column similarly second row first column
second row second column second row
third column and third row first column
third row second column and third row
third column so individual values are
going to be represented as columns and
the whole curly braces is going to be
represented as arrays that's the basic
mental idea or mental image you should
have while declaring a two dimensional
arrays remember to declare the rows
inside the nested curly braces and
whatever elements you have will
automatically be indexed as columns
another thing to remember that since
this is an array data structure
everything starts from 0 and nothing
starts from 1 so this will be row 0
this will be row one and this will be
row two i'm talking about the position
we can still call it as first row second
row and third row but the position of
this particular row element is zero the
position of this particular row element
is one and this particular row element
is 2. similarly for column as well this
is column 0 column 1 and column 2.
similarly column 0 column 1 and column 2
and so on so forth once you understand
this data structure well and you have
defined it correctly then everything
should fall in place if you want to do a
matrix addition or if you want to do a
matrix multiplication or a dot product
all of the kind of calculations can be
performed using the 2d array concept
here in this program what i'm doing is i
am printing the values of this
particular 2d array into a matrix style
and you see some strange code here which
is for etc don't worry about this i'm
going to cover in detail what this 4
means and how do you write this for now
what we can understand that we just want
to print this you might not need to
print this in your java programs when
you write a production grid application
but you might want to do manipulations
on these
arrays as metrics maybe you want to
create a transpose of a matrix or you
want to do a dot product or addition or
subtraction or whatever be your use case
in this case just for demonstration
purpose i am printing the values as rows
and columns nothing else so this all of
this code from line 8 to line 14 or in
fact line 13 is just showing how to
print the values you can see some system
dot out and you can see some construct
here and like i said don't worry about
this i will cover this in detail let's
run this program and see if my java
array is stored correctly and how can i
represent this so you can see i have
represented it in a style of a 2d matrix
where this is the first row this is the
second row and this is the third row
similarly this is the first column
containing the value 2 3 7 so column 0
will have value 2 and column 1 will have
this value 3 and column 2 will have this
value 7 for row 0. let me also do
something here which can help you
understand this concept better let me do
a
system.out.println and let's print an
individual value because like i said the
for loop can be confusing here to
understand so let's say i want to print
arr of
zeroth row first column and see what
kind of values do we get let me comment
this code comment is control backslash
and this code will be commented and this
code will not be executed and now only
line 15 will be executed instead of the
four block so if i run this i get the
value 7 so row 0 and first column row 0
first column is 7. let's try with one
one i want to print the
row at zero one position remember not
the first row but the one position row
which is basically technically the
second row so second row second column
and see what kind of values value do i
get in this case i get six so second row
second column similarly if you change
this value to two then third row second
column which should point to four yes we
get four similarly you can write a value
here as 0 and you can write a value here
as let's say 2 this will print the
zeroth row and the second column so
similarly whatever kind of value you
want to write you or you want to access
you can access it in this fashion and
remember the column and row indexes will
always start from zero so this is a
simple demonstration of how you can use
two-dimensional arrays and in this
session we also
did a refresher of one dimensional array
so that's all for this session and in
the next session we are going to be
discussing how we can define
three-dimensional arrays and we'll also
see an example of it let's get started
with how to create and use a
three-dimensional array or how to go
about using multi-dimensional arrays in
java so as you can see from this image
we talked about 1d array which is having
just one axis then we talked about 2d
arrays in the last session where we had
rows and columns basically an x-axis and
a y-axis
and then we can also have a 3d array
which will have three axises which will
have an x-axis a y-axis
and also a z-axis think of a simple box
which every box in this world will
always have at least three dimensions
and from from here you can go even build
more complex arrays which can have four
dimensions or five dimensions or as many
dimensions as you want it to have and
today we are going to look at an example
of how can we build a 3d array and how
do we access those elements but this
picture is just to show you the mental
model of when you will be creating a 3d
array so for example generally an image
data is stored in in three dimensions so
you can you might want to store the
image data into a 3d array and there can
be many other use cases in the
mathematical and research computational
use cases where you might want to use a
3d array so but remember there's an x
axis there's a y y-axis and then there
is a third axis which is called the
z-axis
so
let us look at a java program to
understand how we can build a
three-dimensional array and for that i
have created this class which is called
multi-dimensional array it has a entry
point method which is the public static
void main method and then i have created
an integer array and this time instead
of one or two square brackets i have
three square brackets
and if you remember i mentioned this in
the previous session as well the number
of square brackets which you're going to
put while initializing the array is the
number of dimensions of the array and
since in this particular program i'm
going to demonstrate a three dimensional
array that's why you see three square
blocks boxes let me just minimize this
yep so we have three square boxes here
and we have created the variable name as
arr or short form as array then we start
with the outermost curly braces as is
then we put another curly braces which
starts from here and it ends here then
another set of curly brace which starts
from here and end here so this is the
this is the first dimension this is the
second dimensions and these are the
third dimensions that's how you're going
to define the different dimensions
remember this is the first dimension
when the first curly brace starts then
you have the second dimension which
covers this hole and this hole and then
you have third dimension which are these
so that's how you're going to visualize
and and put the three dimensions in use
while declaring a three
three-dimensional array
and the values work in the same fashion
it's it's a zero index based position so
since we do not have an official name
for the third dimension so i'm just
gonna use x-axis y-axis and z-axis to
refer to the three axises so this would
be x of 0 this would be
y of 0 and this would be z of 0.
similarly x of 1
y of 1
and z of 1 and so on and so forth so now
if i try to access the value which is at
zeroth x position
first y position and second z position
what's the value do we get here let's
run this program and understand and
interpret the output okay
so when we ran this program we got the
output as 11. so let's understand this
output so when we say the zeroth
position on x the first position on y
and the second position on z
so this is the 0th position on x
and this is the first position on y
and then this element is 0 1 2 is the
second position on the z axis so to to
describe it in a nutshell this defines
the x axis so we have two elements on
the x axis here this one and this one
then we have two elements on the y axis
on each x-axis so this is one this is
two on the first x-axis and this is one
and this is two on the second y second
x-axis
so 2x and 2y and then on the z axis i
have three elements each
so hope this helps you understand and
visualize this so x axis and this one is
other x axis and then y-axis y-axis and
then in elements inside this are z-axis
so i'm saying zero with x-axis in this
block first on the y-axis which is this
block and then second element or the z
or second position element on this
particular axis in this particular block
which is 11 and that's why we get 11. if
i print
0 let's say
i change this particular value as 1. so
now the output should be coming from
this side so
second
x position because it's one second y
position so this will go here and then
the two position which is the third
element of the z axis which is 13. so
let's see if we get 13. yes we get 13
here so this is just to show you how you
can interpret this particular array and
always be mindful of how you are
structuring this array if your structure
is gone wrong then your program will
become useless and it will give you a
lot of unpredictable outputs which might
not make sense and which may introduce
errors in your program so be very
careful how you define the structure of
the elements here that's the key and
after that you just need to understand
the x axis the y-axis and the z-axis
always remember all the accesses start
from zero so when i say two i'm
basically referring to the third element
and not the second element so this is
all i wanted to cover in this particular
session where we describe how we can use
a three dimensional array and from here
you can go to any lens like i said you
can add more square brackets here and go
to four dimension or five dimension or
six dimension but remember the more
dimensions you add the more complexity
of the program will be having the
program will become more and more
difficult to debug and understand so
always try to take a wise call as to how
many dimensions you want to use in your
array and that's it for this particular
session in the next session we are going
to talk about the different loop
statements in java let's get started
with today's topic which is about how to
use do while loops now in the previous
session we covered the usage of while
loops but we have another type of while
loop which is called a do while loop so
let's understand when do we need that
and how do you actually use that let me
switch to the java documentation and if
i can find some syntax of it as well yep
so as you can see here if i just
highlight this portion this is how you
actually write a do while statement
block so you write do you start a code
block you write some executable
statements and then after
the code block ends you write a while
expression and end it with semicolon
this is the syntax basically it starts
with do or curly braces some executable
statements a while block or a while
statement basically with an expression
ending with a semicolon let's understand
this with the help of a program to
understand the structure better so for
this i have created a sample program
here which is called do while demo again
having a public static void main method
and it has a variable which is count and
it is initialized as one then i write do
i write this code block or the curly
braces and then i am just printing the
value of count then i am incrementing
the value of count and then i am writing
a condition which says while count is
less than 10 and semicolon if you
compare this with the previous demo we
ran if i just put them side by side we
had while condition statement
and
the state change condition here we have
do statement condition change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is that if you have a
use case
where before you even evaluate the
condition you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something in that case
you will use the do while loop even
before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
just described here in this program so
coming back to the do while so i say do
and then am saying print this particular
statement without checking anything this
condition will be executed for the first
time without any condition check at all
this will just work as is like a normal
java statement after that i am
incrementing the value of the count and
then i am checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment the first comparison
happened with the original value of
count but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count hope you get the difference in
a better context now that you will use
this when you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and will also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if i run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number 9 again print this
again do an increment on the count and
again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say 3 less than 10 now similarly print
the value increment check this will
continue to happen till this particular
condition becomes false and once this
condition is false it will exit out of
this whole do while loop and it will go
to the line number 12 and if you have
any statement written there you can that
statement will be executed in this case
so
let's try to change some values here and
let's see if if we can make sense of
this program if we change the value
let's see if i put 11 here what will
happen now let's run this program you
will see the
now you will see that this particular
output is displayed which says count is
11. so what happened here that count was
11 it entered the do while block it went
to this particular statement which said
count is 11 then it incremented the
value so the value became 12 and
obviously 12 is not less than 10 so it
did not print it again it only printed
once even if the first time the
condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false
still line number nine got successfully
printed and that's the whole that's the
whole idea behind using the do while
what if i change this value to 10 let's
see what happens
and after that we'll run one more
combination to just make it more
interesting this time again count is 10
line number 10 will be printed as count
is 10 then at line number 10 the count
is incremented to 11 and 11 is not less
than 10 so in this case the loop ends
and it will move out now what happens if
i do this
if i say less than equal to here let's
run this program and interpret the
output now again only one statement is
printed because in this case the count
is 10 10 is printed here and we are
saying 10 plus 1 11 11 is still not less
than equal to 10 and that's why the loop
just exits let's make it 9 and see what
happens now you see two values
so count is 9 it enters the do while
loop goes to statement number 9 prints
the current value of count which is 9
then increments the value to 10
then at line number 11 this while
statement is executed and the condition
is checked is 10 less than equal to 10
yes 10 is not less than but 10 is equal
to 10 so this condition will hold true
it will go back here print count is 10
make count 11 again check the condition
is 11 less than equal to 10 no it's not
and then the condition will return to
false and loop will be exited so hope
this will give you a better
understanding now since we ran different
permutations and combinations of the
values and we saw when this will be
executed and when this will not be
executed but the bottom line is very
straightforward that whenever you want
to write some pre-processing logic even
before checking the very first condition
of your loop then in that case you will
be using a do while loop otherwise a
normal while loop or a for loop will
absolutely work fine so that's the
takeaway i would like you to take away
from this particular session and that's
all for this particular session we
talked about do while and we also try to
give you some sort of a comparison
between while loops and do while loops
in the next session we are going to be
discussing about for loops in detail
let's get started with understanding the
loop statements in java so first of all
understand why do we need loop
statements so generally whenever you are
dealing with some data structures in
java which can store multiple elements
for example we saw array which can store
multiple elements string is also
basically technically a character array
which is storing multiple characters so
whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same uh
then in that case you would like to have
a way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if i want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using loops coming to picture
now java provides multiple constructs to
write loops in java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for loop there is also an enhanced for
loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular so there are multiple ways
in which you can actually iterate over a
collection and access all the elements
of the collection one by one and you can
use it to multiple useful cases for
example if you have a huge i of employee
salary and you want to give bonus to
each of the employees and add the bonus
to the salary then you need to do this
edition for all the employees it would
be nice to have to written a while loop
and the while loop can automatically
access all the employee salary one by
one and keep adding the bonus to the
salary this would be an easier way to do
this rather than individually updating
each employee's salary and the first
loop statement we are going to
understand is a while loop so
the syntax of while loop is very
straightforward you write the y keyword
you enter the actual condition which
will be evaluating to a boolean true or
false so you write the expression which
will be a boolean expression exactly
similar to the conditions which you are
used to write in your if statements so
you write your condition which will
evaluate to either true or false and
then you write your statement and these
statements will keep executing till the
time this particular expression
evaluates to true so generally the way
it works is that it will enter the while
block it will evaluate the expression if
the expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call them steps basically so it will go
to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the ide and look at an example of it so
i have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why we
will be using the while loops so i've
created a while demo class i've added a
public static void main method here
which is the entry point i have declared
a variable which is int count equal to 1
so the count value is 1 right now and
then i'm writing a condition here i'm
saying while count is less than 10 do
this
so it will print the current value of
count and after that i'm using the post
increment unary operator if you remember
we covered this in the previous sessions
what is the meaning of this it basically
will increment the value of count by one
this expression is is equivalent to if i
write it in this way if i write count
equal to count plus one this is exactly
the same as this no difference so this
will have the same impact i will just
remove this line because we already have
the count plus plus here so if we try to
understand this we are basically
incrementing the count and then checking
the condition again so at first time it
will be 1 less than 10 yes that is true
it will go inside and print the count
value the current count value which will
be 1 and then it does count plus plus so
now the count value becomes 2 it will
again go back here again check the
condition saying is 2 less than 10 yes
that is true so the while condition
again becomes true it will again go
inside this print the current value of
count which is 2 then do count plus plus
so it will again increment the value of
count so the now the count value becomes
3 again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the 3
again go here make count as 4 4 less
than 10 prints 4 again count plus plus
count becomes 5 and so on so forth it
will keep doing that till the value
becomes 10 so at a step when count plus
plus results in the account value being
updated to 10 it will go here and say is
10 less than 10 now that is not true
because 10 is equal to 10 but 10 is not
less than 10 so this condition will
become false and it will exit of this
while loop and it will come here and it
will execute if there's if there was
anything written after the while loop
that will be executed so that's the idea
that you want to do something till a
particular condition holds true then you
can use the while loop define your
condition and execute the statements and
try to do something which changes the
state of this condition here i'm
changing the count so that every time a
new evaluation happens if i comment this
this will result in an infinite loop
because 1 will always be less than 10 i
will not be incrementing the count here
and it will keep running forever it will
never stop it will just keep printing
one one one every time till your
computer program runs out of the memory
so always remember not to end up into an
infinite loop that's probably one of the
biggest mistakes any beginner programmer
does so please try to be aware of that
particular loophole not try to run an
infinite loop always try to write
something in the code block which can
change the state of the condition and
also make sure that that state condition
sometimes sometime should become false
you should also make sure that that all
that always becomes false because if i
do this if i do this then this condition
will always remain true because it is
already 1 then it will become 0 then it
will become minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 so
and so forth but that value of count
will forever be less than 10 and again
you will never be able to exit this loop
your program will be stuck in this loop
till your program runs out of the memory
so always remember to write a statement
or a statement of execution in your in
your code block which can change the
state of the condition which results in
some eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and that's
it after 9 the moment the count plus
plus resulted into the count value
becoming 10 it checked that condition
and then it just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false so always do
something inside your code block which
results at least of one scenario where
this condition becomes false and that is
how you can use the while loop now you
can see this is a pretty generic code
and you can write any kind of condition
here write any code you want to execute
here and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all i wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop we have
lot of more exciting stuff coming in in
terms of different loops and in the next
session we are going to understand how a
do-while loop works let's get started
with for loops in java so so far we
covered about while loops and do-while
loops and we also saw different examples
of using different types of data
structures like arrays but one of the
core requirements whenever you are
working with any kind of collection is
to iterate over it exactly similar to
what i explained in the do while and
while lectures that you would often
require to iterate over a collection or
a data structure and for that one of the
most sophisticated and easiest way to do
that is using for loops so let's
understand the syntax of for loop first
and then we will also look at an example
of it in the in the eclipse ide so i
have just opened the official java docs
here so if you see this is basically the
syntax of a for loop statement so let's
understand it and let's also try to
compare it with a while loop so that we
can understand how it compares with the
while loop so if we see the syntax we
first see the term initialization
then we see the term termination and
then we see the term called increment
now if i try to compare it with a while
loop
there also you basically did these three
things you first initialized a variable
outside the while loop which is called
initialization and then you wrote a
condition
which is your termination condition you
wrote a condition saying let's say while
i is greater than 10 or while i is less
than 10. so that is the condition which
is also the termination statement the
loop will continue to execute till that
condition
evaluates to false and that's when the
loop terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the i plus plus
which we used to do in the while loops
so these three portions together
make or constitute any kind of loop in
any kind of programming language and for
loop if you see the the kind of code
which you use to write in a while loop
in multiple lines where you first
initialize a variable then you write a
condition in the while block and then
inside the while block you use to
increment the variable all of that can
be done in a single line in the for loop
and that's why i said it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way to write
loops in java so you write all of these
three things the initialization the
condition and the increment or decrement
values in the single line and then you
start with the curly braces and you
write the code which you want to keep
executing till the condition evaluates
to false that's the basic syntax of it
so let us try to understand this with
the help of an example so here i have
opened a class which is called for demo
and this is a class which will
demonstrate the usage of a for loop so
again we have a public static voidbain
method which you can see here which is
the entry point and then i use the
keyword for i put standard braces for
the brackets
and then i do the initialization so this
part is the initialization part you
initialize the variable so i just say in
ti equal to 1 initialization done you
end it with a semicolon so that it is a
single statement understood by java and
then you write this condition which is
your evaluation slash termination
condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your loops
should run it's exactly similar to what
you used to write in the while block if
i just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while uh syntax or the
construct and then we did the increment
here so we are doing all of these three
steps but we are doing it in a single
line so this is the condition and then
we write our increment or decrement
values which are going to change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying i plus plus
so technically what i am saying here is
that
start with i equal to 1 and then check
the condition i less than 10 so in the
in the first step it will be checking if
1 is less than 10 if the condition holds
true go inside the for loop execute the
statement at line number 7 and then go
back to this particular statement so we
do y plus plus so i becomes 2 and then
you again go back to the condition and
again you check if 2 is less than 10 yes
it is so again you go inside inside the
for loop and do whatever is written
there there can be multiple statements
here for now i have just written one
system.out.println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
does the increment so 2 plus 1 becomes 3
again does the evaluation exec and if
the if the condition holds true it will
again go inside so this will continue
this condition checking execution and
increment will continue till the time
this condition holds true the moment
this condition becomes false the control
will come out at line number nine so
that's the basic anatomy and control
flow it's very important to understand
the control flow of a for loop otherwise
you might end up into a program
which is forever running and which will
just eat up all the memory available in
your jvm so be very sure of what you
write in your for loop be very sure of
specially these two parts the condition
and the increment or decrement so this
is very important piece the
initialization happens only once and
then this condition evaluates if the
condition holds to true some code
executes goes back to the changing
statement which can be an increment to
decrement whatever and again compares
the updated value with the condition so
this will keep happening let's run this
code to interpret the output
so i will right click go to run as java
application
and if i
interpret the output here i can see that
it started with count is one two three
four five six seven eight and nine it
stopped at nine so what happened there
let's try to evaluate the termination
condition so let's say i has become 9
and 9 is less than 10 so it goes inside
and it prints count is 9 which is i then
it goes here and it says 9 plus 1 i plus
plus means 9 plus 1 the current value of
5 plus 1 it becomes 10 and then it again
compares the condition so now 10 is not
less than 10 10 is equal to 10 but it is
not less than 10 so the condition
becomes false and count is 10 is never
printed because this condition has
become false it will jump out so let's
say if i do this
if i put an equal to here and if i now
execute the same program
this time i will see 10 here and because
i have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the i will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite loops for
example if i say i equal to 1 i leave it
that and i say i minus minus so what
happens i equal to 1 1 is less than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then i decrement the value i don't
increment the value i decrement the
value so whatever value comes out will
always be less than 10 and this loop
will run forever for fun let's try to
run this and i will i will have to kill
this program manually but just to show
you what happens and what you should not
do in your java program so you see it
will continuously keep printing the
values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is cut it is forever running
it will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever
so i'm just gonna kill the program but
this is something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's session we talked in detail
about the for loop and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another interesting way of writing for
loops which is also called enhanced for
loops let's get started with enhanced
for loops in java so we covered about
the for loops and the structure of it
and the control flow of it in the
previous session and today we are just
going to talk about another way of
writing for loops which is a bit even
more smarter than the traditional for
loops which we call as enhanced for
loops we generally use the enhanced for
loops for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for loop and this for loop is
even simpler like i said it's even
simpler than
writing a classic for loop and the
syntax is
simply like this you again start with
four put the standard brackets and then
let's start from the right most because
then i will be able to explain it better
you specify the collection in the right
most side of the bracket the collection
can be an array it can be a list can be
a map so whatever different kind of
collections which are available in java
and we are going to cover collections in
detail so don't worry if you don't
understand what our lists and what our
maps and what are sets we will go into
detail of each of these one by one in
the upcoming sessions but the idea is
that you put the collection to the
rightmost then you put a colon and then
you put a representation of the member
of this collection so for example
here this numbers is basically an int
array so this int array means that this
array can only hold integer numbers and
that's why we write int here because
this array is only having integers then
we put any placeholder variable name
this can be anything you can even write
it as i if you want to you can write it
as anything any variable name which you
want to write this is a temporary
variable so now this code is going to
execute in a manner that it is going to
iterate over this array one by one
starting from the first element going
till the last element you don't need to
write any initialization code you don't
need to write any termination condition
code and you don't need to write any
increment or decrement code also and how
these three how these three values are
actually taken care of let's understand
that as well so when we talk about the
initialization as i have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index 0 as
you know that array is a zero index
based structure then comes the condition
part so the condition evaluation is
going to be again based on the size of
the array or the size of the data
structure which you are using it is
going to start from the first index
which is the index 0
and it is going to iterate till the
arrays last element is reached
so technically start from the index 0
and go till the last element that's your
evaluation condition and then comes the
increment part so at each step after it
has
successfully accessed the first element
automatically the index is going to be
updated to pointing to the next element
so if it starts from here once the first
step iteration is complete i is
automatically going to be incremented to
index 1 and then it will basically this
i will be holding 2 then in the next
iteration the same i is going to be
holding 3. similarly i will keep holding
the new value of the collection item one
by one till the collection items last
element is reached so this is the basic
premise that you can write a collection
variable here and keep iterating over it
and this whatever variable you write
here will hold the current items value
one by one so in the first step this i
is going to hold one in the second step
this i is going to hold two in the third
step this i is going to hold three and
so on so forth that's the basic idea so
now let's run this program to see what
kind of output do we get so you can see
we basically are able to print all the
elements of the array and that's
probably one of the most popular usage
as well that if you want to just print
all the elements or access all the
elements of
array or a collection one by one then
just use enhanced for loop so you can
see at each step it is printing the
value of i and the value of i is
basically the subsequent elements of the
array that's the whole idea with
enhanced for loop under the hoods if you
talk about how does it work under the
hood it is actually using the classic
for loop construct itself but for
developers it is making it easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection you will
start with the first element and you
will go till the last element so it
knows the initialization value the
termination condition and it also knows
the increment condition and that's the
reason you will use enhanced for loops
in java for iterating over collections
and in the next session we will be
talking about the nested for loops
concept and we will be looking at an
example of how to implement nested for
loops and when do we use nested for
loops let's get started with nested for
loops in java so we talked about the
while loops the do-while loops the
classic for loop also the enhanced for
loop so now we are going to look at a
variation of the classic for loops in a
in a condition where we have to use more
than one loop in a nested fashion and
how do we do that what are the use cases
when we use that so in front of you you
can see an example which i have prepared
for nested for loops and in this
particular example i have created a two
dimensional array as you can see on the
line number six i have created an
integer array and i have put two square
brackets here which are basically
symbolizing that this is a two
dimensional array so this two
dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for loops
to print this 2d array in a 2d matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to
interpret this particular 2d array so we
have a curly braces outside and then we
have these three inner elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a
three into three 2d array which has
three rows and three columns so so we
can say that this is basically a three
into three array which has three
dimensions on the row side and three
dimensions on the column side or just a
three by three matrix or three by three
2d array so as we know that in case of
arrays everything starts from 0 so
technically if we talk about the indexes
it would be the index 0 index 1 and
index 2 on the row side and similarly
index 0 index 1 and index 2 on the
column side so that's that's something
which you should remember because we are
going to use this particular concept
when we write the for loop so let's try
to write the for loop now if you look at
line number 8 we put this keyword called
for
and then we write the initialization so
we say int i equal to 0 then we are
writing the termination condition and we
are saying
run this particular loop run this whole
loop which ends at line 13 till i is
less than 3 and keep incrementing i at
every step that's what i am doing in the
line number 8 then inside the for loop i
am writing another for loop which has
another different variable called j it
can be anything you can name it anything
you want and this also starts with 0 and
this also has a similar condition which
is which says run this particular loop
the line 10 basically or this loop which
is signified by this curly braces run
this particular loop till the time the
value of j
is less than 3 and keep incrementing j
at every step and at line number 10
print the element of array which has the
current value of i and the current value
of j these are basically the positions
these are not the elements the element
would be represented by this hole but
print the element which is at current i
and j's position values that's what this
code means so let's try to do a dry run
on this particular code to understand
how this is going to work so at first we
have i equal to 0 0 is less than 3 and
it goes inside it initializes j as well
with 0 and j is 0 is also less than 3 so
this condition went true that's why we
went to line number 9 and line number 9
condition also went to true so we went
to line number 10 remember that
in this particular case at line number
10 the values of i and j are 0 and 0
respectively and we are saying print the
array of 0 and 0 so 0 with rows zeroth
column element should be printed so this
is the zeroth row because this is the
first uh first sub block and this is the
first element so in this case in line
number ten two should get printed then
it goes here and it increments the j to
one so zero plus one becomes one it
again checks the condition is one less
than three so yes one is less than three
it goes here remember it did not go up
at line number eight it just came back
from line number nine so when it comes
here
i is still zero but j has moved from
zero to one so now we are trying to
access the element which is at zeroth
row first column which is going to be
7 so 7 is going to get printed similarly
on the next iteration j is going to get
incremented from 1 to 2 and again the
condition will be evaluated so 2 is less
than 3 all good it will again come back
to line number 10 and now it will say
print the value of zero row third or the
second column or the third element so
zeroth row third element which is the
nine so nine will get printed then again
j will be incremented and j will become
3 2 plus 1 3 and now the condition will
be evaluated is 3 less than 3 no it is
not less than 3 the condition becomes
false so it breaks out of the loop goes
to line number 12 prints an empty line
because we are not writing anything here
so it will just print a blank line and
now it will go back to line number
eight's condition and it will do an
increment of i and now i will move from
0 to 1 and now the evaluation will
happen is 1 less than 3 yes 1 is less
than 3 so it will again go to line
number 9 again initialize j with a fresh
0. the previous j got destroyed the
moment you came out of the loop so this
is a new j so this j again gets
initialized to 0 0 is less than 3 it
goes here remember i was 1 in this time
so now it will print the value of this
2d array which is sitting at
one comma zero basically second row
first element so second row first
element which is three again j is going
to get incremented and it will become
from zero to one so one is less than
three yes it will again come here and it
will print the value of the array which
is sitting at array of 1 comma 1 for row
equal to 1 and column equal to 1 which
will be 6. similarly j will get
incremented again again 2 is less than 3
come back here we'll print 1 then again
we'll increment j j will become 3 3 is
less than 3 no it's false the condition
is false so it jumps out of the loop
goes to line number 12 prints a blank
line again goes back to 8 line number 8
increments i and i now becomes 2 2 is
less than 3 yes it will again go here
initialize j again with 0 and again does
the same thing for the row 2 and column
0 1 2 and again it will come out of the
loop this time again when it will go
here the value will become from 2 to 3
and 3 is not less than 3 so then it will
break out of the outer loop so the idea
is execute the inner loop for every
value of the outer loop remember this
line because that is how
you will be applying your knowledge of
nested for loops to be used in certain
condition so whenever you have a
scenario where you have to iterate over
a collection based on a certain value of
another collection then you can use
nested for loops or you have a scenario
where you have to hydrate over 2d or 3d
arrays for example if we were dealing
with 3d arrays then you would have seen
three nested for loops here and where it
will apply the same logic that iterate
over all the collections all the values
of the inner loop on our particular
value of the outer loop then increment
the value of the outer loop and do the
same thing again iterate over all the
values of the inner loop based on a
fixed value of the outer loop so let's
run this program and let's see what kind
of output do we get
so like i said our our motive our target
was to print this in a metric style and
you can see that it is printing in it in
a sort of a matrix representation so the
first row gets printed here then the
second row gets printed here and then
the third row gets printed here if you
try to decipher it it will work exactly
the same way as i explained so i equal
to 0
0 less than 3 condition becomes true
comes here j equal to zero j less than
three condition becomes true comes here
prints the array of zero comma zero
which is two then prints the array of
zero comma one which is seven zero comma
two which is nine then j becomes three
it breaks out of the loop goes up here i
becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less than 3 yes
again comes here reinitializes a fresh
for loop with a new j setting to 0 and
it will it will print the array of 1 0
one one one two then similarly array of
two zero two one two two so that's
basically what we are doing we are
iterating we are picking the first row
and hydrating all elements of it picking
the second row hydrating all elements
over it and so on so forth you can do
this for any n-dimensional kind of array
or a collection so this is all i wanted
to cover in today's session where we
discussed about the nested for loops
concept and how and where we will use it
and in the next session we will be
discussing about the java collections
framework let's get started with
collections in java or the collections
framework in java i must say that this
is probably the most important concept
of the java programming language which
you will be using heavily whenever you
are working in any production grade
application so let's understand the
collections framework and the different
classes and the utilities available
inside the collections framework this is
going to be a theoretical lecture
because there is a lot of ground to
cover in this lecture so we will only
focus on understanding the relationship
between the classes why those classes
are created because each class has a
different purpose in this framework and
we will obviously talk about the
hierarchy as well in the upcoming
sessions we will go into the hands-on
exercise of some of the most popular
collections we will not be able to
provide hands-on of all the collections
classes which you which you can see on
the screen because then it is going to
take a very very long time to complete
this concept but we will cover the most
popular ones or the most used ones out
of this particular framework so let's
get started as you can see
let's first understand some of the
symbols here and let me just zoom this
in a bit so that it's visible yep now
that i have just increased the
resolution a bit so you can see there
are three different symbols or legends
here you see this oval shape which is
called interface so you can see some
interfaces here then you see this
rectangular blue box which is called
abstract class and you can see some of
these blue boxes and then you see the
purple box which is called the class and
you see some classes here these ones so
for now we are currently we haven't
covered the concept of interfaces and
abstract classes but we will cover that
in the coming lectures and for
understanding the collections hierarchy
right now the at least the concepts of
it you don't need to be fully aware of
the concept of interfaces or abstract
classes so let's dive deeper into the
framework i trabel is basically an
interface
to give you a very simple definition of
an interface interface basically is sort
of a declaration which will tell you
what kind of classes will be present
under the interface for example if you
have to let's say store all the cars
and all the bikes and all the bicycles
and all the trucks
from all around the world then you can
create an interface called vehicle and
create all of these classes
under the interface and these classes
will be about cars
about trucks
and about other kind of vehicles so an
interface is a generic blueprint of
specific class implementation that's a
very simple definition of an interface
and like i said we will go deeper into
this concept in the upcoming lectures
so that was about interfaces similarly
when we talk about abstract classes the
next legend here abstract classes are
also similar to interfaces where they
provide you a generalization but at the
same time abstract classes provide you a
way to also write some concrete
implementation for example if we take
the example of a bank account so there
in a bank you have different kinds of
accounts you have sales accounts you
have recurring accounts you have current
accounts and there are many other
different types of accounts so
there would be some common
implementation and logic which will be
applicable to all the account types for
example an account must have an account
holder that account holder must have a
valid kyc done for example so there
would be some sort of common logic which
will be applicable to all of these right
so that common logic so you have two
options either you can write that common
logic again and again in the savings
account class in the current account
class in the loan account class etc etc
or you can write it at a central place
and just refer it from there so that's
where you will you will use abstract
classes so you will create an abstract
class of an account and then you will
create these child classes under this
account class which will be the savings
account class the loan account class the
current account class etc so this is a
very lightning introduction to you about
interfaces and abstract classes and
class as we know is basically a concrete
blueprint which holds data and logic
together so here i table is an interface
which will just specify that all the
kinds of data structure which can be
iterated which can be looped over should
be present under this particular
interface that's why we created this
interface
so
under i trabel we have this collections
interface and this will govern that
everything which will present under the
collection interface will be holding
some sort of a collection of items now
we look at the next set of interfaces we
see a set interface we see a list
interface and we see a queue interface
when we talk about the set interface
these three different types of
interfaces represent three different
properties of collection and these
properties are exclusive of each other
for example if we talk about set so set
has a property that everything which you
put into set will be unique it will
never ever tolerate or contain any
duplicate elements that's the property
offset so now you can see whenever you
have a scenario where there is a strict
constraint that your collection should
never have duplicates you will use sets
when we talk about lists list is
probably the most lenient representation
of a collection it can store anything it
can store duplicates as well it will not
raise an error or a warning if you store
same element multiple times it will
happily store it but at the same time
the list is basically an index based
collection you can access the elements
starting from the index 0 till the last
element that's the basic value
proposition so whenever you have a
requirement where you want to access the
elements into a predefined sequence
and one by one then you should use list
also the order is fixed here the first
element will always come after the
zeroth element the second element will
always come after the first element so
whenever you iterate over this
particular list you will never have a
scenario where you do not know the order
of the elements being accessed they will
always be accessed in a predefined order
so it's basically we can call it as an
indexed ordered collection which can
hold duplicates then the third one is q
here so q is basically as you can this
is basically inspired from real world so
think of any queue if you if you go to
buy something at a grocery store or if
you go to buy a ticket at a railway
station or you go to the check-in
counter at the airports so you stand in
a queue and the concept of queue is that
it works on a concept of first in first
out the person who first went into the
queue will be the person first being
served and coming out of the queue and
if the second person come that has to be
standing behind the first person and
once the first person is served and goes
out of the queue the second person comes
at the front of the queue and that that
particular person is served so you can
see it's uh if you have to store that
kind of behavior or if you have to
implement that kind of behavior in a
java program then you would use queues
so so this was about the top level
interfaces which are set list and queue
and out of these list and set are very
very popularly used very heavily used in
any kind of java enterprise grade
application now there are more
interfaces like sorted set navigable set
and dq sorted set is basically forcing
additional constraint on the set that
the elements will be unique at the same
time you can also have the elements into
a sorted order the sorting can be an
incremental sorting or decremental
sorting that depends but the whole idea
is that it will be sorted similarly
navigable set brings another navigation
kind of properties dq is basically a
double ended queue where the elements
can be inserted and removed both from
the front and from the back so there are
the different properties of these
interfaces but like i said the most
popular ones are these three ones now
let's talk about the abstract classes so
the abstract classes you see here are
abstract collection abstract set
abstract list abstract queue abstract
sequential list generally you will not
be using these directly you don't need
to use them directly but you should be
aware that they exist if you have a very
specific case where you want to
use these abstract classes you can use
them in java program but most of the
time you don't need to use them and most
of the times you will be dealing with
either the interfaces or you will be
dealing with the concrete classes now
this lecture is is getting a bit long so
i would like to stop this lecture here
so we covered about the interfaces part
of the collection and we also understood
a bit about the abstract classes though
we are not going to use abstract classes
in much detail in the programs in the
next session we will cover the second
part of this collection framework or the
remaining part of this collections
framework which is around the classes
let's get started with discussing the
concrete classes in the collections
framework in the previous session we
talked about the interfaces part of it
where we discussed about sets the lists
and the queues and we also touched a bit
upon the abstract classes and like i
mentioned earlier you don't need to
generally use these abstract classes
directly in your java program but you
must be aware that they exist you see
some arrows here right if you see if i
just scroll up you see multiple kind of
arrows here these arrows mean that if
the arrow goes from bottom to top it
means
this particular element is a type of the
parent it's basically a denoting a
parent child kind of relationship so for
example here you see tree set is
basically
a navigable set and also extend extends
abstract set which extends set so
similarly you can see all kind of
complex relationships here and generally
you don't need to remember all of those
you only need to remember the few and
those few are basically easily can be
spotted for example whenever you see a
tree set it means it's basically a type
of set whenever you see a word called
list that means that it is a type of
list and you all whenever you see a word
called queue then it means that it is a
type of queue so let's understand these
classes let's first go to the list
interface so you can see list interface
has the relationship with abstract list
and from there it goes down to array
list abstract list has another child
which is called abstract sequential list
which is another abstract class and
which has a concrete class which is
called linked list so let's understand
these two collections or these two uh
are types of list right now so when we
talk about arraylist let's understand
this we already have covered arrays
so what are arraylist they are very
similar to arrays in in a way that
they are also indexed based collections
so you can store elements and access
them based on the index position
starting from 0 going till the length
minus 1 index
and this is an ordered collection you
can access the elements only in a
predefined sequence it can obviously
accept duplicates as well and these all
are properties are also applicable to
arrays the differentiating factor here
is that arraylist is a dynamic array
it's not a static array if you remember
when we talked about arrays we had to
initialize it or we had to specify a
fixed size of it while we initialize it
once you have initialized the array size
you cannot change the array size it is
static it is fixed so if you have
created an array of elements 10 and if
you are trying to store the 11th element
you are going to get an array of array
index bound of exception but in case of
array list it dynamically updates its
size based on the number of elements
stored you can still initialize it with
some some initial size let's say you
initialize an array list and you say
that you want to initialize it with the
size of 10 elements absolutely fine but
the moment you start you try to store
the eleventh element array list is going
to dynamically update its size from 10
to something else so it will keep
updating its size based on the number of
number of elements which are coming to
the collection that's the whole property
of arraylist so remember it's it's used
in the cases when you have an ordered
collection to store and you want to
access them based on the index
and you want a dynamic update of the
size the second sibling of it which is
linked list is also a type of list but
it has slightly different properties
than arraylist in case of arraylist it
was an index based collection you access
the element based on the indexes but in
linked list you access the elements
based on the previous and the next
element that's pretty much what it knows
so an item can only be accessed in a
particular sequence starting from head
to the tail and when we talk about
linked list the idea is that you have an
element which will have a data and it
will also have a pointer or a basically
a reference that reference will be
pointing to the next element in the
linked list similarly the next element
will store the value the actual data and
it will also store a reference to the
next element so you can see if you have
to go to the fifth element you cannot
directly say link list of five the way
you can say this in arraylist because
arraylist is an index space position uh
list right so you can access the zeroth
element or the fifth element or the
tenth element directly just in one line
for one go but in case of linked list
you cannot access the fifth element or
the last element of the linked list
directly you have to start from the
first element and keep jumping the
references till you reach the last
element that's the property of linked
list so these are the two types of list
now let's talk about the type of
set a type of set which is not mentioned
here is hash set which is a very popular
type so a set generally has two popular
types hash set and preset so let's talk
about both of those if i talk about hash
set the property is that it will inherit
the existing properties of set which is
that element should be unique that's
good but along with that hash set will
not remember or honor the order in which
the elements are inserted into it it
will if let's say if you insert 15 or 20
different elements inside hash set and
then if you try to iterate over the hash
set every time the order in which the
elements are accessed and printed will
be different every time the order of
accession will be different every time
the
way in which the elements are accessed
their order will be different
you cannot predict that and that's the
property of hash set whereas when we
talk about reset in case of tree set you
can have a sort of fixed order and a
tree hierarchy so a tree hierarchy if
you know about the tree data structure
from the data structure and algorithms
section you already would know what a
tree looks like basically it has a root
and it has child this is basically you
can call this artery as well right so
whenever you have to store the values in
a in a tree fashion where you can
navigate through the parent and childs
then you would use the preset and
remember since it is a set it will still
inherit the uniqueness property of set
so that's about hash set and preset so
we covered about list we covered about
sets now let's talk about these ones
which are vector stack and priority
queue so let's first understand about
priority queue so you would use a
priority queue
when you need a fifo arrangement but at
the same time if there are few elements
in the queue which cannot wait to be
executed or processed when their turn
comes they wanted to be executed on
priority so whenever you have such use
case where you want to to maintain a
fifo fashion collection but at the same
time you also want to allow few elements
of it to override this fifa arrangement
and get processed ahead of their queue
number so you can use priority queue in
those cases
talking about stack let's understand
stack first and stack is a lifo
arrangement last in first out
so remember in your house when you when
you put plates uh the the normal dinner
plates over one or one over each other
you are basically creating a stack so
the property is that the plate which is
put first on the table
will be picked up at the very last and
the plate which is put the last on the
stack let's say you put five plates on
top of one one on top of other then the
fifth plate will be consumed first
anybody would pick the plate from the
very top they will not pick the bottom
plate because it's it's almost
impossible if you have a big stack you
cannot pull out the bottom most plate
the stack will fall down so you will
always pick out the elements from the
top so it has a leaf arrangement so
whenever you have to create a last in
first out kind of arrangement in your
program for storing collections you will
use stack talking about vectors vectors
are very similar to lists they are
exactly similar there is basically one
major difference is that vectors are
thread safe and lists are not thread
safe now list has provided a way to be
thread safe we will cover that later but
for now you can understand that whenever
you have a program in which you want to
access a collection in a thread safe
manner where two threads cannot modify
the same element at the same time then
you will use vectors so we covered about
the complete collections framework
classes the interfaces and the abstract
classes and always remember the
the reason why you will use arraylist or
linked list or a hash set or a tree set
or a vector or a priority queue or a
stack that is the most important concept
i want you to take away from this
session let's get started with
arraylists in java so when we talk about
error list we are technically talking
about a list in the previous session i
covered in detail about the various
implementation of list interface which
were error list and linked list and in
today's session we'll be focusing only
on the error list i have opened the api
documentation of the arraylist class so
if we just scroll down we will see a
nice description which is provided by
java and it broadly covers all the
points which i described in the previous
session which were that an error list is
basically an array-based implementation
of a list it's an indexed-based
implementation so you can access the
elements based on their index position
you can directly access any element if
you know its index it accepts any kind
of duplicates as well and by default it
is not thread safe if two threads are
trying to access the same collection at
the same time or may be trying to modify
the collection then you will get
inconsistent behavior so that was about
the basic description of arraylist there
are it provides lot of interesting
utility methods as well for adding
elements for adding multiple elements
for removing elements for fetching an
element from the error list and we will
cover those methods in detail in the
demo and with that maybe let's switch to
the demo so for this i have created a
class which is called arraylist demo it
has a public static void main method and
it has an error list example written
inside it so at line number 10 you see
that there is an initialization
happening for the error list and this is
how you basically initialize the array
list to start with you write the
interface name you can obviously write
arraylist as well here instead of list
you can write error list that is
absolutely acceptable but the reason i
have written list here is because it is
a better practice or i would say it is a
best practice to always initialize the
concrete implementations with the
interface type i'm making a very generic
statement which is applicable to
collections and at any other type of
classes and objects you might be
creating in your program always try to
declare it with the type of interface
and then define the concrete
implementation on the right hand side so
the lhs or the left hand side will
contain the interface declaration and
the right hand side will contain the
concrete implementation the reason for
this is that if tomorrow if you have to
change the representation of this error
list to let's say a linked list then you
don't need to do a lot of work because
the linked list is also a child of the
list interface so since list understands
and knows about both of the classes you
can interchangeably use this reference
to point to any of those implementations
that's why it is considered a best
practice to basically
write the left hand side as the
interface and the right hand side as the
concrete implementation that's the first
bit of it second interesting thing you
notice is this so you see these
expressions here and this basically
encloses any kind of generics or class
type what are generics we will cover
this in detail in the upcoming sessions
for now what you can understand and what
you should know that these are denoting
a class type of which
the objects will be stored inside this
particular list
so once i say list of integer it means
that this particular list is only going
to hold integer objects
if you try to insert a string object or
if you try to insert a character object
or if you try to insert a float object
or any other kind of object it will
create an error because it remember in
the very first lecture we said that java
is strongly typed language
it has very strong checks for these kind
of data type mismatch so if that's why
it will expect you to specify the object
type here and whatever type you have
specified here that's the kind of
objects which are going to be stored
inside this list i have been using these
terms called classes and objects inter
interchangeably but for now what you can
understand that this is a type
how we how we write classes and how we
write objects and how we create objects
again i will cover this in detail in the
upcoming sessions so we have specified
the list interface and i'm saying that
this particular variable should hold any
list of integer type then on the right
hand side i'm specifying what type of
list
this error list is and this error list
will be an arraylist class type and
again i have to specify the class type
specifications and then i'm specifying a
size here this is the size of the error
list the initial size of the error list
you can obviously write it without this
as well this is also a perfectly fine
statement in java and in this case the
error list is going to be initialized
with its default size if you specify a
value then the error list will be
initialized with only that size it is
also considered a best practice to
always initialize the array list with a
some known initial value let's say if
the serialist is going to store only two
elements and the default size is
definitely way way bigger than two
elements then you're going to waste lot
of memories so that's why it is the best
practice to specify explicitly specify
some sort of an initial size
this is also acceptable because it is
automatically inferring the type from
the declaration you don't need to
specify it again here in fact some of
this modern ides will also show you a
warning if you write it here so the next
thing i'm going to do is basically going
to add some elements to this error list
so i've created an error list which
should hold only integer values and it
should hold to start with five values
but it will not complain if you try to
add the sixth value so for that i have
just written a small loop here let me
just put curly braces around it for
readability so i am saying in thai equal
to 1 i should be less than equal to 5 i
plus plus and i keep doing array list
dot add so this add method is the method
which is used to add elements to the
array list so whenever you have to add
an element to the error list remember
you need to use the method add and then
specify the actual element which is
supposed to be added so i'm adding one
two three four five in this error list
one by one using this loop and then i'm
just printing the whole error list
that's what i'm doing here after that to
showcase another operation of this error
list i'm removing an element and if you
have to remove an element from error
list just simply call error list dot
remove and specify the index from which
you want to remove the element remember
you need to specify the index and as i
said in the beginning this is an array
based implementation so this is going to
start from zero so when i say remove the
element at index three technically it's
the fourth element of the array list
after that once we have removed the
element i'm again displaying the
modified error list and then printing
all the elements of the
error list one by one and for for
fetching the element if you see here if
you if you observe this particular for
loop i'm using couple of more
interesting methods of the error list
let's understand those methods as well
and then i will run the program so here
you see that i'm saying i
int i equal to 0 and then i am saying i
less than error list dot size
so if this error list has
a capacity initial capacity of storing
five elements and i've just added five
elements to it then the error list dot
size will be 5 but it says less than so
it will start from 0 and run till i
equal to 4 because the moment i becomes
5 5 is not less than 5 and it will come
out of the loop so basically i'm trying
to start this loop where i i's value
starts from 0 and goes till 4 and here i
am calling another error list method
which is used to fetch an element from
the error list so whenever you have to
get an element from the error list just
call dot get on the error list so error
list dot get and i'm specifying the i
value so error list dot get of 0 get of
1 get of 2 get of 3 and get a 4. and
that's technically the five elements
which are stored in this array list so
let's run this program so and now let's
observe the outputs here let me just
bring the outputs down yeah so at first
i'm just printing the error list so
nothing nothing i'm just adding the
elements and printing the complete error
list so if you want to just print the
whole error list just put that inside
system.out.printteller and the whole
arraylist will be printed that's line
17. then i remove the element at index 3
so if i traverse through this particular
list this is index 0 index 1 index 2 and
index 3 so index 3 has an element which
has a value 4 and i'm saying array list
dot remove the element at index 3 so
this particular element should be
removed from this particular list when i
call the line 20 and then if i print the
modified error list at line 24 i can see
that 4 is gone now it's only one two
three five that's the remaining list you
also need to notice that whenever i call
system.out.println
with arraylist i get this square
brackets which is the representation of
an arraylist if you don't want that you
might not want that always right if you
want to print this nicely without the
square brackets then you have to iterate
over the error list and that's what i'm
doing here i'm going from 0 to
errorless.size and i'm doing get of 0
get off 1 get of 2 and get off 3 and
that's how i get these values without 4.
we can also write the same loop using
for enhanced loop so let's say if i
write
for
int i
colon array list and then inside it i
can just say
system dot out dot print ln
i and if i comment this particular loop
for for a moment and run this program
i see the values one by one because it's
ln so every output comes on on a new
line but you can pretty much see the
same output if i remove
this
and if i write it like this just adding
an extra space
it will look a bit more nice a bit more
formatted like this
so as you can see that we can get the
pretty much the same output either using
a classic for loop style which is a bit
verbose or you can use an enhanced for
loop which is a much simpler and shorter
and
less verbose way of doing exactly the
same thing you don't even need to call
the arraylist.geti but i the reason i
put this example because i wanted to
show you the get functionality as well
so that's all we are going to talk about
in this session in the next session we
will be discussing about linked list
which is the another implementation of
the list interface let's get started
with linked lists in java in the
previous session we talked about error
lists and today we are going to talk
about the another type of implementation
of the list interface which is called
linked list if you remember from the
previous sessions we discussed about the
properties of the linked list and all
those properties are listed here as well
so basic idea is that whenever you want
to have a kind of implementation
where the order of the elements is
strictly maintained where the first
element can refer to the second element
the second element can refer to the
third element and so on in those kind of
cases you are going to use linked list
another property of linked list is that
you cannot randomly access an element
directly as you as you could do in case
of error list in case of error list you
just say you just write arraylist dot
get and you provide the index location
and you get the element right away
that's not possible in linked list in
linked list if you have to access the
let's say the second last element or the
fifth element in a 10 size element
list in that case you have to start from
the head which is the first element and
keep traversing till the fifth element
that's the only way possible to access
the fifth element or any random element
so that's the property of linked list it
is also not synchronized so if multiple
threads are trying to access a linked
list concurrently at least one of the
threads and and one of the threads tries
to modify the list then it must be
synchronized externally by some other
ways otherwise you will get
unpredictable results
and again this also provides a bunch of
utility methods and we will cover some
of those methods as you can see
add method for adding an element add all
add first contains get first get lost we
will cover some of these methods in the
demonstration which follows this
particular documentation and with that
let's jump to the implementation
so i have prepared an example here for
the linked list which is called linked
list demo i've just created a class for
it and we have created a public static
void main method here and here you can
see at line number 10 i have declared a
linked list so this looks very similar
to the way we declared an error list you
see if you have noticed on the lhs i
have root i have written the concrete
class and have not written the interface
reason being i am using some concrete
methods and actual methods which are
only available in the linked list class
so i am not looking at the reusability
aspect in this particular example if you
are then you have to add extra code for
it but here i am just writing linked
list and again in this particular linked
list i am saying that i would only store
string objects so that's why inside
these braces i write string and then i
say new link list string
again i have not specified the size so
it will take the default size as per the
jvm implementation now i have declared
my linked list and it's time to add some
elements to the link list
for that i have the method add which is
available in this linked list class
which will provide me with the
capability to add elements
so at line number 12 and line number 13
i'm adding two elements
and if you remember i told you that it
works in a reference based
implementation so at first an element a
will be added and when you try to add
element b element a's reference will be
updated to point to b
that's what will happen in this linked
list and then at line 14 i'm using
another interesting utility method of
this linked list class which says add
last
what this method does that specifically
it will add the element at the very end
of the linked list
so that was about add last and if i talk
about line 15 i'm using another
interesting method of linked list class
which is called add first
so what this will do that this is going
to insert this element d at the very
beginning of this linked list like even
before a d will be inserted so whatever
your linked list looks like whenever you
call add first
that element is going to be inserted at
the very head of the linked list or the
very beginning of the linked list linked
list also provides another variant of
the add method so there is one way to
just add the string element directly
because this is a string a linked list
you can also add it based on the
position so you can say add e at the
second position
inside the linked list so let's observe
this output let me comment all the code
below line 18 because we will be using
some more methods here so we'll cover
that in a while but let's first
understand the output at line 18 if we
run this program so right click run as
java application and this is the output
we get so let's understand the output or
maybe let me do this let me put this
here one by one so that we can interpret
the output
so i'm adding two elements and printing
the list then calling add last and
printing the new list then calling add
first printing the new list and then
calling list.add2 comma e and printing
the list again so let's observe these
outputs one by one i'll comment this and
let's run this now so if i run this
particular program the program till line
14 is executed because rest of the code
is all commented let me comment this as
well and if i run it again yes this is
the output i get so at line 12 and 13
i've added two elements and i print the
list there are only two elements and
they are printed in the fashion a comma
b everything is good here now let's
uncomment this code and now i'm calling
add last method and i adding an element
with string c which should be added at
the very last of this particular list so
let's see now what happens
let me comment this one so that we only
see one list at the output
okay we see a comma b comma c so c has
been successfully added to the end of
the list
now let's interpret this particular
method which is called add first so i'm
going to uncomment this
and comment the previous out so now
there's only one cis out here so i'm
adding two elements adding c at the last
and now adding d at the very beginning
and printing out the list
let's see what happens
okay so the d has been added at the very
beginning of the list even before a so
now it looks like d comma a comma b
comma c so far so good now let's move to
this particular code
and now i'm saying add an element call
called e at the second position inside
this list remember second position so
let's run this list now this program now
so now i see d comma a if you remember
the previous output was d abc if i just
uncomment this for a while just to make
it more clearer and if i run this
program
the previous list was d comma a comma b
comma c and the new one says d a e e has
been inserted at the
position 2 so 0 1 2 position 2 has been
added with this new string e and my list
is modified now it's time to
find some interesting operations about
the removal so what happens if i try to
remove elements from this list and then
we will observe the output again so
let's say if i say list dot remove b and
so i'm saying just drop this particular
element so you can directly specify that
particular elements value and that
element will be removed from the list
and let's see what output do i get if i
just call list dot remove b and i
comment the rest of the code we should
see a new output here which should not
have b so running the program again yes
so this was the old collection and this
is the new collection from which b is
gone because i have called list dot
remove b
now you can also remove elements based
on the index position instead of
specifying the element explicitly you
can specify the index position and what
happens if i call list.remove3 let's
observe the output here as well so i'm
just going to copy paste this is out
and we'll see what output do we get if
we remove the element at third location
okay so this was the previous output
after removing b and if i called list
dot remove 3 so 0 1 2 3
c is the element which is at third
location and it is gone when i call list
dot remove 3 c is gone and d comma a
comma e
is only remaining
now let's try to understand this
particular line which says list dot
remove first
expectedly this is going to remove the
element from the very beginning so
whatever element is present at the
beginning it is going to remove the
element and then we are going to print
the list the modified list so we were
here till d a e and d was the
element which was at the beginning and
if i called remove first
d is removed and now only a comma e is
available and now i use another
interesting method which is called list
dot remove last and then i print the
list the modified list so this is the
list remaining and i'm calling remove
last so e should be dropped and only a
should be
left in this particular list
yes we only see a here so this is
basically what i wanted to show you in
this program that we can perform
different kind of operations using
different methods like add add first add
last remove remove first remove last
obviously there are more interesting
methods available in this particular
class do check out the api documentation
for it and there you can see all the
different interesting methods which you
can use while implementing linked list
so this is all i wanted to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to cover an
interesting framework class which is
called set we are going to learn about
sets in java in the next session let's
get started with hash set in java if you
remember i covered in the collections
framework session that hash set is part
of the set interface hierarchy and sets
have a property that they keep the
collections element unique if you try to
add duplicate elements to the asset it
will not accept that and it will still
maintain the uniqueness property of the
collection hashset provides some
additional features to the set which is
that in this case the elements would be
accessed in a random fashion they will
not be accessed in a fixed sequence
rather they will be accessed in a random
fashion hence the name hash set so if
you read about this particular class in
the documentation it will basically
cover all the things which i just
described it also accepts null elements
if you want to insert null but why would
you try to insert null that's the first
question which you should ask it again
provides similar kind of utility methods
to the list interface collection
hierarchy we covered like some utility
methods to add the elements to remove
the elements to check the size of the
collection and to check if an element
exists in the collection or not etc etc
and we will cover some of these methods
in the demo this is again not
synchronized so this is not a thread
safe collection which you should know so
let's look at a demonstration of hash
set and how do we actually create a hash
set how do we operate upon a hash set
using different utility methods
so as you can see i have created a class
here which is called hash set demo
there's a public static void main method
and then at line number 10 you will see
that i have created the hash set and
again it starts with the concrete class
here which says hash set and you can
obviously write it as
set as well which will also work fine so
we write the set type as string so this
particular set is going to hold only and
only string objects and nothing else and
this set is basically a type of hash set
again this is not mandatory so you can
remove that it will still not complain
and the program will run fine if you
want to specify a size please do that if
you do not want to specify the size
nothing goes wrong and it will be
initialized with the default memory
footprint but remember doing this wastes
a bit of memory so if you are running
this program on a machine which is
really tight on memory always put some
kind of initialization size based on
your knowledge of how many elements are
going to be stored in this collection so
after that at line number 12 we start
adding elements to this collection and
for adding the elements the method which
is provided by the hash set class is add
so you use the add method to add new
elements so at line number 12 line
number 13 14 and 15 i use the method
again and again to add some elements if
you observe the line number 14 and the
line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so i'm trying to
add c
twice to this particular hash set and we
will observe the output to see what
happens if we try to add duplicate
elements in the hash set because if you
remember the sets are supposed to be
unique they should not be storing
duplicate elements that's the property
of sets so that's what i demonstrate by
by adding duplicate elements to see how
it behaves and let's do that let me
comment the rest of the code for a while
and let's run just this part of the code
where i add c twice and i print the hash
set and let's see what happens
so i go to run as and i click on java
application and i only see three
elements even though i added four i only
see three and c has been added only once
not twice
now you might be wondering whether the c
is
the c added at line 14 or the c added at
line 15. so
to understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works so this
add method is basically returning a
boolean value if the element is added
successfully this ad is going to return
true and if the element could not be
added successfully this add method is
going to return false so let's do that
let's store the result of these add
methods let's call this r1 and let's
call this one as r2
okay and now we will try to print r1 and
r2 and see what happens
so if we write system dot out dot
println and i say r1 and then i just
copy this
after line 16
and write r2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which
when we did the add at 14 and when we
did the add at 16 which actually
resulted in c getting added did c get
overwritten or did c did not add twice
what happens
so we see that uh when we do the add at
line 14 we get true so it means that
this ad was successful and c was added
here and when i did the add again at
line 16 this returned a false it means
the hash set rejected this add operation
so this c was not added so the actual c
was never overwritten the original c was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that
so that actually proves that the set
will maintain the uh the uniqueness
property and it will reject all the
duplicates subsequently that was about
the ad
property now let's understand another
interesting property of the contains
method contains method of the set class
is used to find if an element exists in
the set or not so you can just use the
hash set variable name dot contains and
just type the actual element and this is
going to return true or false based on
whether this element is present in the
hash set or not present in the hash set
if it is present then this contains
method is going to return true otherwise
it is going to return false
so let's run this method and observe the
output at line 21.
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain c or not and it returns true
because yes my hash set does contain c
now coming to line 23 i use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
i'm again doing this out and i'm asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list
so then i'm checking if uh what happens
to my hash set if i call the remove
method and i'm just printing the
modified hash set at line 24. so let's
see what happens with the effect of
remove operation okay so after removing
a this is what remains in my hash set
and a has been successfully dropped if i
call the remove method and then i try to
just iterate over the hash set to show
you how does this iteration work it
again works on exactly the same way it
has been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
column you write the collection name so
hash set and on the lhs of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and i'm printing all
the items one by one
so if i run this
i am able to print b and c because
that's all which is remaining in this
hash set so this was a very quick demo
to show you the functionalities of the
hash set how does hash set maintains
uniqueness how do you remove elements
how do you add elements how do you check
for an element's existence using
contains there's also a method to get
the element of the hashtag if you want
to so these are all the different
properties and methods available in the
hash set and do check it check out the
api documentation of the hash set to
learn about more methods so that's all i
wanted to cover in this particular
session where we focused only on hash
set and in the next session we will be
discussing about presets and we will
also see an example of how do we
implement presets in java let's get
started with three sets in java so in
the previous session we talked about
about hash set which is one of the
implementation of the set hierarchy and
today we'll be focusing on preset and if
you remember when we talked about this
collection framework i discussed briefly
about preset that the main reason you
will use tree set is basically when you
want to maintain natural ordering of the
elements if you're adding your custom
elements then you need to tell java how
to compare and sort and order the
elements but that's for another day when
we'll cover about the detailed
comparable in comparator interfaces for
now what you can understand that
whenever you have to maintain the
natural order of the elements
automatically then you should use preset
along with that the set property still
holds true that this tree set cannot
have duplicate elements
we should also know that tree set is not
synchronized so it is not a thread safe
collection so be remember be aware that
whenever you are trying to use preset in
a multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
preset works as expected okay that was
about the brief theory about the preset
you can read about
about it in detail in this tree set
documentation class and with that let's
switch to a demonstration of the tree
set class
so i have prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight i'm initializing that
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
and only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs i'm just saying new tree set and
again this is not mandatory so i can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine after that from line number
10 till line number 13 i'm again going
to add some elements and again if you
see i'm adding elements in random order
i'm adding b and then i'm adding adding
a then i am adding c twice just to show
you the uniqueness property of the tree
set does it still hold true or not we
will be able to figure that out from
this particular example and we will also
see
if i'm adding b before a will it be
printed in a fashion called bac or will
it be printed in a fashion called abc we
should also know that
so let's try to run this program and
understand the output
so if we look at the output we see a
before b but here when we added the
elements we saw b before a we added b
first and then we added a and then we
added c twice and as per the uniqueness
property of this set the second
addition statement at line number 13
returned false and set rejected this
edition because it could see that c was
already present in this particular
collection so c is added only once but
what's interesting is that b is added
first but b is added b is printed after
a so the natural order of the elements
in this collection is automatically
maintained by tree set so what under the
hood reset does here that it looks at
the type which is a predefined type in
java string is a predefined class in
java so it will use its own sorting
algorithm to sort the strings based on
their natural order of sequence and in
the natural order of sequence a will
always come before b and b will always
come before c so it will automatically
apply that sorting and will present the
result to you if you're using a custom
class here let's say your own student
class or your own customer class or your
own account class in that case that
account class or student class or
customer class
needs to tell java how to sort elements
and for that you need to write
comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you you must understand that
whatever the type of class you are
specifying here should
tell java how to sort the elements
either java should know it automatically
if it's a predefined class like string
or integer or float or double then java
would automatically know by default how
to sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
tree set and specifying that as a tree
set type then you should also tell java
how to sort the customers whether you
want to sort them based on your first
name whether you want to sort them based
on their age their salary java doesn't
know that so you need you need to tell
java about that if you're trying to use
a custom class as the type entry set in
this particular example i'm using string
here and it will apply the natural
ordering
let's put c here in the very beginning
to see what happens and i can comment
this as we have already maintained and
verified that c is only printed once and
added once so i'm adding c b a and let's
run this program
i still get abc because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember i told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
hash set again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
i use a hash set here sometimes it will
print abc sometimes it will print bac
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of tree
set no matter how many times you run it
you will always get the same order based
on the sorting implementation available
in the class type
so that's all i wanted to cover about
reset please read about read about its
java documentation in the api docs to
understand what all other methods and
utilities tree set provides but it's
pretty much similar to what we saw in
the hassett example like remove or get
etc etc and contains etc so all this all
similar methods are available in the
tree set class as well and that's all
we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we are
going to talk about an interesting
framework called maps let's get started
with maps in java
so first of all before we understand
this particular diagram and the classes
in this map framework let's understand
why do we need map
so
there would be instances when you would
write a java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole
mapping of the employee id to the
employee name into the java program
how do you do that you need a key value
sort of arrangement where you can store
the employee id as the keys
and each of the employee id key would
correspond to an employee name which
will be called the value so you need a
key and value
arrangement in the java program to store
that kind of information and use that
kind of information in your program and
that's where map comes into picture
whenever you have to store a key value
arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice uh framework
representation of map and this is going
to be a theoretical lecture where we
will understand how this map framework
works what is the property and what are
the different implementation classes and
then in the future sessions we will
again look at some examples of the most
popular map implementation classes which
are used in the java world
so again uh the orange oval are
interfaces the blue boxes or the light
blue boxes are the abstract classes and
the purple boxes are the concrete
classes so map is an interface which
will provide this kind of a blueprint
that every class underneath it would be
working on a key value arrangement when
we talk about this key value arrangement
so we have these keys and we have the
values
so the keys here
are supposed to be unique the values can
contain duplicates
remember this is a very important
concept that in map the keys will be
unique and the values can have duplicate
and because
we want to maintain the uniqueness in
the keys part that's why the keys are
technically stored as a set because we
know that set cannot contain duplicate
sets are by design made to be storing
only unique elements so map uses the set
class to store its keys
and to store the values it generally
uses a list class so you can see map is
basically reusing the classes from the
collections framework sets for storing
the keys and lists for storing the
values that's the basic anatomy and
basic idea of how map is working now you
see some classes here called abstract
map and sorted map and again similar to
the set hierarchy whenever you see the
sorted word and if you look at the
concrete class which is called tree map
this is going to provide you some sort
of an order sorting order automatically
and then you have the hash map class and
this class is going to be providing a
random access this will not maintain the
insertion order this will not provide
you a natural sorting order this is just
to store elements in random order and
the element here a single element here
is basically consisting of two parts
which is key and value always remember
that you also have hash table here hash
table is basically a synchronized
representation this is a thread safe
hash map and tree map are non thread
safe so multiple threads if you try to
work in a multi-threading program with
these hash map and pre-map you're going
to get very unpredictable results but if
you use hash table then it is inherently
thread safe so it will only allow one
thread to be to access the hash table at
a particular time
you will also you will also be thinking
then then it's always better to use hash
table right because you will never get
into those weird errors and you don't
have to migrate your program
to a multi-threaded environment whenever
you are trying to use hash tables yes
that is true but hash tables are slower
for the same reason because only one
thread can
can access it at a time and that's why
hash tables are slower and hashmap and
treemap are way way faster because they
allowed multiple access at the same time
so you have to always be mindful of what
kind of collection type you're using
there are some external ways as well to
make these hash maps and tree maps and
hash set and preset and and array list
and link list as synchronized as well
and we will talk about that in a future
session but for now you can understand
that hash map entry map are non-thread
safe and hash table
are thread safe there is another class
which is
which is coming out from the hash map
class which is called linked hash map
and linked hash map as the name shows it
will basically carry two properties it
will carry the property of hash map
where the elements are stored or
displayed or accessed in random order
and at the same time it is also
providing the linked
property of the linked list where the
sequence is maintained so you can see
you can actually get the insertion order
if you use a linked hash map the way in
which you insert the elements would
always be the way in which the elements
will be accessed so you are getting sort
of a ordering property but the order is
the insertion order it's not the natural
sort order it's the insertion order
that's why the name linked hash map
because it brings the linked list part
of the link property inside the hashmap
where the elements would be presented to
you in the order they are inserted when
you call the add method so that's what
we covered here we covered about map
interface we covered about hash map
class which is going to store the values
and the access will be random the value
means the element means a key and value
we sometime also call this as an element
you will see that representation
sometimes some some people also call it
as i table element it's all the same
thing but it's a key and value
arrangement pre-map also stores the key
value arrangement but it will provide
you a sorted representation and here the
sorting will happen on the keys
not on the values the sorting will be
happening the natural order of salt
which will be maintained by the tree map
is only applicable to the keys here
similarly link hash map
it will insert the elements but when you
try to access it it will maintain the
insertion order no matter how many times
you access it it will only be presented
to you in the order the elements were
inserted and hash table is very similar
to hash map with the difference that
hash table is thread safe multiple
threads cannot manipulate the hash table
at a time it will only let a single
thread access itself at a time so that's
the property of hash table the most
popular classes are generally these ones
hash map tree map and link hash map
very rarely you will also see hash table
but since we have some
ways to
get these synchronized so generally you
would not see much of the hash table
implementation and that's all i wanted
to cover in this particular lecture
where we walk you through the concepts
and the theory of the map framework and
in the upcoming sessions we'll go deeper
into the concrete classes and in the
next session we'll specifically be
discussing about hashmap so we will
understand how hashmap works we will
create a hashmap and we will again look
at some utility methods which are
provided by the hashmap class through
the demonstration let's get started with
hash maps in java
in the previous session i covered about
the theoretical concepts of map and the
key value arrangement and the keys being
basically are set and the values
basically being a list and now we are
looking at the api documentation of the
hashmap class you can see the k comma v
here these are the types of the key and
the value which the hashmap will accept
you can see k is basically the type of
keys and v is basically the type of
mapped values
uh like i explained it's basically keys
are stored in a set fashion and values
are stored in a list collection fashion
this is not by default synchronized so
if you want a thread safe collection
then you would have to do something else
which i will cover in the future
sessions this is a very brief overview
of what hash map is but let's look at
the example to understand better and
then i will be able to explain it in bit
more detail so now we are looking at an
example which is basically a class which
is called hash map demo i have a main
method here and then at line number 10 i
am initializing the map
and as you can see that on the lhs we
see the concrete class hash map and i
can do this
and this will still work provided you
have the import here i had the import
here so it will work fine and i am
saying that this map is going to contain
a key value arrangement where the keys
are the string type
and the values are of the type integer
and it's ultimately a hash map here i
don't need to again provide the generics
because i have already provided the
generics here
the name of the map is just simply a map
and again you can specify a size or you
can skip the size based on the memory
requirements and the program
requirements now coming to the point
where you want to add elements to the
map now since this is a key value
arrangement here the name of the method
through which you are going to add
elements is put so you call map.put and
then you provide the key
comma you provide the value
that's the syntax for adding an element
or we technically call that element an
entry this key value together is called
entry so if you have to add an entry to
the map you have to write it in this way
where key comma value is the convention
so i'm adding three elements or three
entries here which is
a comma 10 b comma 20 and c comma 30.
abc are basically the keys and 10 20 and
30 are the corresponding values of these
keys respectively
after that i'm showcasing another
utility method of this particular class
which you can use to find the size of
the map so you can just call map dot
size and it will print the size of the
map
after that i'm printing the actual map
the whole map and then i'm using some
more methods but again let's comment
this code and let's understand this code
one by one so that there is no confusion
so to start with i'm going to add some
elements some entries and i'm going to
print the size of the map and the map
itself let's run this program
so here
you can see the size of the map is
printed as three because i've added
three entries and then when i call
map inside the
system.out.println method i get the
whole map printed here and this is how
the map will look like when it is
printed we can see key equal to value
syntax here where a equal to 10
b equal to 20 and c equal to 30 are the
key value representations or the entries
here separated by comma enclosed by the
curly braces that's how our map looks
like so far so good the next thing which
i am going to showcase to you is the
contains method and since the map has
this set which is the keys basically
that's why map provides a method called
contains key basically you can check if
a particular key is present in the map
or not and if you know the key is
present then it's very easy to get the
value from the key map will provide a
method also where you can supply the key
and get the value so knowing the key is
the most important part and that's why
map provides a method called contains
key so you can call this method specify
the key which you want to check for the
presence in the map it will it is going
to check whether a is present in this
maps key set or not if the a is
available in this keys we can see a is
available then this condition is going
to hold true and then
like i said if you want to fetch the
value then you can call the get method
providing the key you can fetch the
value from the key that's the that's the
core idea which you should remember so i
call map dot get specify the key and
this is going to spit out the value
which is being pointed by this
particular key in this case a is
pointing to 10 when i say pointing it's
not pointer remember it's just a
reference so map dot get of a is going
to get the actual value which this key
is pointing to which is 10 and then i am
printing
this integer a which is the actual value
pointed by this particular key so let's
run this program and see if this works
so we get these two outputs from the
above and then this is the output which
is coming from the if block so it
checked whether the map is containing a
key with the name a yes it was able to
find that and then we asked the java
program to fetch the value corresponding
to this particular key so we just called
map dot get off a and it fetched 10 and
it printed 10 here that's why you see 10
here okay so that's how you can
basically use the contains key method
and the get method now what if you want
to iterate over all the keys what if you
the what if you have to use
the
all the keys and you have to make some
pattern or make some observation about
all the keys in your map you can do that
by iterating over the key set and for
that map provides a method called key
set so you just called map.keyset and
this is going to fetch all the keys
in a set representation and will be
provided to you so here when i call
map.keyset this is basically giving me a
set which is containing all the keys and
then i'm iterating over the keys one by
one you would be familiar with this
syntax by now which is the enhanced for
loop syntax and inside this i'm printing
the key which is the current temporary
variable holding the current key and the
value pointed by that particular key at
that particular step and i'm again using
the same method get which i which i
showed you
here
same method
so you provide the key and you will get
the value so i'm going to get all the
keys hydrate over the keys and then
print the key and the value let's see
how this looks like
so till this we were good and here you
will see the output which is coming out
from this particular for loop from this
particular for loop line 25 to line 27
where i'm iterating over the key set
printing the key and value one by one so
this is how to show you if you just have
access to the key set you can still
hydrate over the whole map but what if
you know everything you have access to
the key set you have access to the
values and if you was if you just want
to iterate over it then you can use this
particular
way and instead of map.keyset you're
going to use map dot entry set if you
remember map treats each key value
arrangement as a single entry entry is
the keyword here
so map dot entry set is going to give me
all the entries in the map and then
each entry is basically of type entry
class
this is the representation of each entry
and we know how this representation
formed entry is the class basically
which is coming out of this map
collection hierarchy and then let me
just save this and then string is the
key and integer is the value held by
each entry inside the map so that's what
we are going to do we are going to pick
up all the entries in the map and going
to iterate over the entries one by one
by writing this enhanced for loop and
entry is the temporary variable which is
going to hold each entry one by one at
each step and then it's very simple you
call entry dot get key you will get the
key and you call entry dot get value and
you will get the value so it's much much
simpler than this one where you had to
do map.get to understand it's very
implicit getkey is going to get you the
key and get value is going to get you
the value so you just need to call
map.entry set hydrate over the entry set
and get each entries key and value and
print them or do whatever your program
requires to be done that's how you will
use it so let's run this one as well to
verify if this works okay so this is the
output which is coming from the last
loop this loop basically you can see key
i did not put any space that's why you
see key a key b and key c together let
me put a space here and put a hyphen so
that the output looks better and let me
rerun this yep this is much better so
you can see the key a value 10 tb value
20 and key c value 30. this is coming
from this particular for loop which i
just showed you so this is all i wanted
to cover in this particular session we
went deeper into the hash map
representation and we saw a bunch of
methods contains key key set entry set
get put etc and we showed how we can use
the hash map for different purposes in
the program in the next session we'll go
deeper into the tree map concept and
we'll also look at a demo of tree map
and we'll understand how it works let's
get started with tree maps in java now
if you remember in the last lecture we
talked about hash maps in java and we
also had a look at an example where we
saw how a hash map works and how we can
use a hashmap we also had a look at
different utility methods of the hashmap
as well now in today's lecture we are
going to focus on tree maps which is an
another type of map as we discussed when
we were discussing about the map
framework and the main property of a
tree map is that when you enter elements
into a map they will naturally be sorted
or naturally be ordered now when i say
naturally ordered what it means that if
you put the
keys as let's say integer then the tree
map will automatically sort all the map
entries in an integer sorted fashion
where you'll see the natural number
sorting
behavior like 1 2 3 and so on similarly
if you
store alphabets or strings then they
then those will be sorted in a natural
sorting alphabetical order starting from
a to z so these are the uh these are the
data types which the java is already
aware of on how to sort them like
integers doubles floats strings etc but
there can be a case where you have your
custom key this particular key is your
own custom class if that is the behavior
or if that is the scenario then in that
case you will have to provide an
implementation to java to know how to
sort those elements because java doesn't
know for example a student class or an
account class java doesn't know how to
sort that so if you have that kind of
scenario then in those cases you will
have to provide your own sorting
implementation and we will cover about
what kind of sorting implementation you
can provide in those kind of scenarios
in the upcoming lectures for now we will
look at have a look at an example of
tree map where you can see that i have
created a class which is called tree map
demo and i have initialized a tree map
with the keys as integer and the values
as string so this means that each entry
of the map will have key as the integer
value and the value of that particular
entry will be of string type so
basically an integer to string mapping
is what each entry of this tree map is
going to store so nothing different here
you would have already seen this kind of
this kind of initialization for any kind
of map and after that at line 11 i use
the standard put method of the map and i
i started storing the values so at line
11 i'm saying store 3 and a so 3 is the
key and string a remember this is not a
character this is a string because i
have specified string here if you
specify a character here and if you try
to store a string this is going to throw
an error and you need to fix that so i
store 3 as the key and a as string as
the value similarly at line 12 i store 2
as the key and
b as the value and at line c i store 1
as the key and c as the value so these
integers are the keys and the string are
the values
and if i just put them and if i just try
to print them what happens
what kind of order can we expect let's
try to analyze that
so i right click on this i go to run as
and i go to run as java application
it will run the program because i have a
static void main method and now you see
that the map is printed in a different
fashion than the way it was added we
added the map elements in this sequence
that we added three a first two b second
and one c as the third element but when
we started printing them we saw
one c printed first two b printed second
and 3c 3a printed third so what this
denotes that this tree map because the
key was integer here it automatically
sorted these keys into a natural order
sorting and it provided when i tried to
access the map it provided the access in
that sorted sequence only no matter how
many times you run this particular
program it is always going to return the
map in the same format in the same
sequence the sequence of representation
of the elements is not going to change
and you can basically do the similar
behavior for example if i just
change this to string and integer let's
do it like this and if i again swap the
elements here as well i say a comma
three and i say b comma two
and here i can say c comma one if i do
this i just switch the keys in values
position now the string is the key and
the integer is the value and let me just
put these two
before a
so that
we can demonstrate the behavior of the
tree map properly so i'm inserting b2
first and c one second and a three third
and i just save this file and now let's
run this file and let's see how the
output comes so now you can see that
since the key is now string it has
applied it has automatically applied the
natural sorting ordering of strings
which is starting from a going till z
and that's why you see a entry as the
first entry b entry as a second entry
and the c entry as the third entry again
no matter how many times you run it or
you hydrate over it you try to access it
you will always get the sequence in the
same fashion so this is a basic overview
of how tree maps work now you can and i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read about all the other methods which
are available in the tree map which you
can use for example how can you remove
elements how can you
how can you iterate the elements of the
tree map etc
in fact the iteration is is going to be
exactly the same way as we have seen in
the case of hash maps because iteration
behavior doesn't change but to uh if you
want to see what all different kinds of
methods pre-map support it supports a
lot of different methods we can't cover
all of them in this short tutorial but i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read the java docs api of the tree map
to get familiar with those methods so
that you know what kind of
functionalities pre-map can provide in
the next session we are going to have a
look at how we can use stacks and we
will look at a hands-on example of how
we can build stack and how we can use
them in a real life scenario let's get
started with stacks in java
now if you remember when we were
covering about the collections framework
i walked through a complete hierarchy of
interfaces abstract classes and concrete
classes
and i briefly talked about what are
stacks
and what kind of functionality they
provide
in which scenarios you would use them so
let's do a quick refresher of what
stacks are and why do you need them
so stack is basically a kind of list we
can say technically a list but it's not
exactly a list so never say that stack
is a list it's it's just uh because it
is extending the list interface that is
why you can say it is a type of list but
actually it's not a type of list it has
its own representation you will use
stack in the cases where you will have
to maintain a lifo representation of the
objects now what is a lifo
representation it means
last in first out that's the
basically the full form of the lifo
acronym and what it means
that the element which goes
at the last in the inside the collection
will be the first to come out
think of it as a stack of plates at your
dining table
where you you put plates over one
another and the last plate which you put
on that plate stack will be the first
one to be picked up by somebody who
wants to eat something because people
will not take out the bottom most plate
otherwise the whole stack will fall
that's why they will take the top most
plate and that's why we call that plate
representation as stack of plates and
this representation in java is exactly
inspired from that and we call this
stack
you see a bracket here you see a
generics representation here which says
e which means that stack you need to
define what kind of stack it will be
whether it will be a stack holding
integer values or string values or any
of your custom class values so that is
the basic property that the the last
element to be going inside the
collection will be the first element to
be coming out
so let's have a look at an example of
how you can use stack and what are the
different properties which we can
leverage while working with stacks so
for that let me switch back to eclipse
and you can see i have a class created
here which is called stackdemo and it
has a public static void main method
which is making this particular class
executable and here
you can see i have created the i have
initialized the stack so stack of the
class type so you provide the class type
as string which means that this
particular stack is going to store
string objects
and then you just say new stack and you
provide the same
generics here actually you can skip that
if you do this as well this is going to
work fine so that is how you can
basically initialize a stack you can see
the import here which you need to import
to make this work it's basically part of
the java.util package
what are packages again we will cover
that in detail when we cover classes and
constructors and etc
so
now
at line 11 i'm using a method called
push
now the push method is used to insert
elements inside the stack but we call it
push because like i said stack is a
special type of collection that's why it
doesn't use the add method rather it has
a method which is called push which is
used for inserting elements or pushing
elements on the top of the stack so at
line 11 you say stack.push basically
this stack is is holding the list of all
the countries or the entries of all the
countries so you say america at line 11.
then at line 12 i'm again doing stack
dot push and entering germany
at line 13 i'm again doing another
stack.push
and entering india
so basically i have added three
countries names inside this stack
now if you if you can think about the
mental representation or if you try to
build a mental representation of this
then
stack dot push america is basically the
first entry
then when you added germany this entry
went on top of america because that's
how the the stack of plates work right
and then
india entry will come on top of germany
so the america is the bottom most entry
then we have the germany which is
sitting in the middle and then at the
top we will have the entry for the india
string
and after that at line 15 i'm just
printing the stack
so
if if you want to just observe the
output till 15 let's comment this
particular section
for now and we will just focus till line
15 and once we have figured that out
then we will move to the rest of the
code here so let's run this particular
program and observe the output
so you can see this is the
system.out.println which is getting
printed so i'm printing a stack string
and then i'm printing the stack as is
and you can see it's printed in the
sequence in which the elements were
inserted so when you print the stack you
will not be able to figure out which is
the bottom and which is the top because
you don't need to know that while you
are just printing the whole stack when
you actually want to understand and
observe that behavior is when you will
start taking elements out of the stack
at that time it would be critical to
know which element is at the top and
which element is at the bottom but for
now we can see that we are able to
successfully add elements or push
elements to a stack and we are able to
successfully print the stack now let's
uncomment this particular code and
understand what is happening here
so at line 17 i'm using another method
of the stack which is called pop
so
the push method was used to push
elements or insert elements into the
stack
and the pop method is used to
take elements out of the stack and
remember the lifo property of the stack
which means that if i call the pop
method which is basically i'm telling
stack to remove an element it is going
to remove the topmost element from the
stack and it is also going to return the
element remember that part
if you want to remove the element and if
you want to see
which was the topmost element which got
removed then you can actually store the
output of this particular execution into
a variable
and you can see which element was popped
or removed
and
and that's the basic property of a lifo
right that when you have a lifo
collection
when you pop the element when you call
the pop method on the stack you would
expect the top most element to be coming
out
and that's why we store that into this
particular string and then we print that
popped element to verify and see which
element was actually
popped and after that because i have
removed one element here then i print
the modified stack to just see what all
is remained in the stack
so let's run this particular program and
now we'll let's comment the first part
maybe this particular cis out is not
needed because we have already observed
the output of this so let's observe the
these two output after pop which was the
element which was popped and how the
stack looks like after the removal or
popping of one element from the stack
so i right click run as java application
and now
if you remember when we
inserted the elements we inserted the
elements in this fashion america germany
and india and when i called pop the top
most element of the stack should get
removed so it it so the basically the
java looked at this particular stack and
it could see that the element india was
added at the very last which means this
element was sitting on the top of the
stack and when you called stack dot pop
this method or this string basically
got popped out this element got removed
from the stack
and we stored that element into this
particular variable we printed that
element and here you can see that output
that the popped element is actually
india because india string was at the
top of the stack in this particular case
at line 20 now i'm printing the modified
stack basically printing what is
remaining inside the stack after we
called this pop
and we can see that the string india is
gone from the stack and now germany is
the new top
if i call this again let's call this
again
to verify if germany is at the top
actually
so i'm calling the stock stack dot pop
again let's just call it popped element
one for simplicity
don't do that a production code always
give nice variable names but for the
sake of demo
we can do this
so let's see what happens if after we
have these two elements left in the
stack and if i call pop again
which element gets popped
so i right click run as java application
and we can see that
this was the representation here at line
20 then i called popped and the popped
element was germany because now this
germany was the new top and after
germany has been removed from this
particular stack then this stack has
only one element which was which is
america so this is how you can work with
the stack and these are the most too
popular uh methods which are push and
pop which you would basically require to
uh to be
to use in your program if you're working
with stack and let's say you have a
scenario where you just want to view
which element is at the top you don't
want to remove it because pop is also
going to remove the element right so if
you don't want to remove it but just
want to view
which element is sitting at that at the
very top of the stack then you can call
the peak method so this peak method is
basically going to return the top most
element but it is not going to remove
the element from the stack so let me
just verify that as well for you
ctrl c and after we do the peak i'm
going to print the element again let me
just call it as peaked or let's say just
call it as top element
and then we print the stack again
so let me just comment out this one as
well and now we'll run the full program
let me call this as original stack
so we'll first print the original stack
then we'll remove one element
and we'll print that element and we
print the modified stack then i call the
peak method
and and then again i print the stack to
see if peak also removed
the top element or it just returned the
top element so let's run as java
application and observe the output so
the original stack was this where india
was the topmost element and germany was
in the middle and america was at the
bottom of this particular stack and then
we popped the top element which was
india and then the stack got modified
and we had only two elements left into
it
then here we called peak at line two in
line 22 and we just at line 23 we
printed
the peaked element or the top element so
in this particular stack if we call peak
we got germany
but if we printed the stack again we can
see that german is still there because
peak just returned the top element but
it did not remove the top element
whereas pop will remove the top element
and also will return that element to you
if you want to store it
so that's all i wanted to cover in this
particular session where we talked in
depth about the stack features and like
i always say please also go to the
javadoc api and
read about all other methods and
functionalities which are provided by
the stack collection
in the next session we are going to
focus on queues and we look at a
hands-on demo of queues as well let's
get started with queues in java so again
taking it back to the time when we
discussed about the collections
framework we briefly discussed about the
queue interface and what is the property
of the of a particular queue
so queues were again inspired from real
life cues which you form when you
whenever you try to go to a particular
place where you want to get your things
done you generally stand in a queue
and this queue interface is directly
inspired from that particular scenario
itself that it works on a fifo
arrangement
so now if you think about the fifo
arrangement and let's connect it back to
the previous lecture where we discussed
about stacks and we said that stacks are
a lefo arrangement so in case of a lifo
arrangement you had the last in first
out philosophy but in case of queues you
have the first in first out philosophy
it means the first element which enters
the queue will be the first element
removed from the queue that is the basic
premise around which the queue
interface or the queue collection is
formed so remember that particular
concept whenever you have a situation in
your project where you need to implement
this kind of mechanism that the element
which got inside the collection should
be the first one coming out of the
collection then you should be always
thinking about cues whereas if you have
an arrangement where
the last element inserted should be the
first element out of the collection then
in that case you should think about
stacks so remember the value proposition
of each of these collection types which
will help you take a decision as to
which particular uh collection to be
used in which scenario so talking about
queue queue is again an interface again
like i said uh we are
very soon going to cover the concept of
classes and interfaces and abstract
classes so just hold tight on that
particular concept but connecting it
again back to the theory lecture where
we talked about the collections
framework you can think of an interface
as a just a blueprint just a skeleton
with nothing concrete implementation
details inside that interface so the
queue is again an interface and there
are few implementations of it one of the
most popular implementation of queue
interface is a priority queue class
so the priority queue class is again
technically it is a queue which
basically works on the concept of first
in first out but at the same time it
also works on a priority you can assign
a priority to the elements
which will decide when uh which element
is going to come first and which which
element is going to come second and that
concept is basically again governed by
the same natural ordering logic which we
have been seeing in other ordered
collections like preset and tree map so
that's the basic idea about priority
queue and let me take you to a hands-on
example so that you can relate it better
so here i have
a class which is called queue demo it
has a public static void main method and
then at line number nine i'm
initializing the queue
i'm saying that this particular queue
should hold only string objects and it
is a type of priority queue and like i
mentioned if you use priority queue you
can see the import of it here
if you see the priority queue then you
get that natural sorting or natural or
ordering logic phenomena out of the box
because we are using strings here so
java already knows how to sort strings
and it is going to sort strings in the
alphabetical sorting order if you are
providing a custom class of yours maybe
let's say q of students then in that
case you need to tell java how to sort
those elements and like i mentioned in
the previous sessions we are going to
cover in detail about how do we write
that sort if you provide that sorting
implementation or sorting logic to java
in case of custom classes but we'll
cover that when we'll cover about that
sorting logic
for now for the demo sake we are just
taking a string or a queue of strings
basically which is of type priority
queue and then again you're
following the same example as we saw in
the case of stacks just so that you can
now build some sort of similarity i'm
again inserting few strings here which
are country names
so at first i'm inserting india then i'm
inserting germany and then i'm inserting
america so i have basically added three
entries into this particular queue then
at line 15 i'm just printing the queue
and i just wanted to see if i inserted
elements in this order where india with
an i go first germany with a g goes
second and america with an a goes third
and if it is a priority queue does it
automatically sort the elements or not
so let's first observe that part and let
me comment the rest of the code we will
cover the rest of the code slowly so
that we build a sort of cognitive flow
so let me comment this code and let's
just print the queue for now so i'm
inserting the elements into the queue
and just printing the element q has a
concept of head and tail remember that
so the very first element in the queue
is is basically the head and the very
last element is the tail so whenever you
see the term head and tail you can
remember that head is the first element
and tail is the last element
so now let's try to run this code and
see what happens if you just print the
queue as is you're not iterating over it
you're not accessing any particular
element but you're just printing it
so if you do this
we see the output here which says
original queue this particular one says
america india and germany now this might
be looking confusing right because if i
apply natural sorting then america
should come first which is okay then
germany should come because after a the
g is the is the next natural alphabet
starting point and then india should
come but we see india in the middle here
the reason is because when you call is
call this inside the
system.out.println method let me just go
back if you print it inside this
particular
system.out.println method automatically
when you try to print a variable its to
string method is called so technically
under the hood this is what is getting
called though we don't need to write the
tostring but the moment you try to print
any variable inside the
system.out.println
automatically its truestring method is
getting called and in the interesting
part is if you call the tostring method
it will call the abstract collection
classes to string method which does not
understand sorting so remember that very
well if you are working with priority
queues then in that case if you just try
to print the queue you will not get the
natural order but once you try to add
elements or remove elements or peak the
elements in those cases you will get the
natural ordering sequence but if you
just print the queue as is you will not
be able to get the natural order and it
will be random order that's why you see
a random order but let's try to build
our understanding around the natural
order so once we have printed the queue
now let's understand the other method of
the queue which is the remove method and
if you remember i told you that this is
a fifo queue so if you try to remove an
element the head of the queue is going
to get removed the head in this case is
this string america which should be
removed from this particular collection
if i call remove method so i'm just
calling the remove method and then
printing the remove remaining queue
again this queue will be printed in
random fashion but if it is respecting
the priority queue's natural ordering
sequence then america should get removed
when psychology move so let's verify
your understanding
so i can see the queue after removing
the head element remains as germany and
india these are the elements which are
left now and america is removed from
this particular queue now so that
verifies our understanding that when you
call remove the head of the queue will
be removed and the head will be the
alphabetically sorted first element of
the queue there's another interesting
method in the queue similar to stacks we
have a peak method if you just want to
view which element is sitting at the
head of the queue if you just want to
view it you don't want to remove the
element but you just want to view the
element in that case you can call the
peak method so i'm just calling q dot
peak and storing the output of q dot
peak into a variable called head
and then just printing the head so let's
see what happens in this case okay so
i'm getting this message which says head
of the queue is germany because germany
is now the new head after america was
removed from this particular collection
so that is our head and like i said
whenever you call these methods
these will respect natural sorting order
cis out will not respect natural sorting
order remember that another interesting
method is pole
so pole method is basically used to
remove the element and also return the
element so you can see which is the uh
head and it will also remove the head
both at the same time but in case of
remove you were just removing the
element you were not able to see which
element was removed in this case you
will be able to see which element is
sitting at the head and also at the same
time the head will also be removed so
for that you need to call the pole
method so i'm calling q dot poll and
storing this again in the same variable
head so the head variables value will
get just overwritten if i reuse it again
and then i'm printing the removed head
let's see so i'm right i'm just running
this application again and i see this
message removed head germany which is
coming from here so when you call the q
dot poll the current head of the queue
got removed which was germany and it
also was returned from the poll method
so you can store the removed element and
use that removed element
for further processing in your program
and after that only one element in the
queue should be remaining which is india
so at the last line number 26 i'm just
printing the remaining parts portions of
the queue so yes now only india is
remaining so you can see all the outputs
here this was where we started from uh
then we removed the head element of the
queue so this element got removed and we
were left with germany and india you can
see here india germany was in this order
and here the order was changed because
it is random order when you use it under
sis out then we wanted to just get the
head of the cube but we did not want to
remove it so we use the peak method and
we got germany then we wanted to remove
the head so we removed the head with the
help of pole method and it also returned
the removed element which is germany and
after the removal the queue looks like
this which is having just one element
left in the queue and in this case the
head and the tail both is india in this
case so this string will be both the
head and the tail this is a special case
if the the queue has only one element
left so this is all i wanted to cover in
the case of uh queues and uh like i
mentioned in all the previous sessions
as well do go and check out the java
docs api of the queue interface and the
priority queue classes learn and just
get familiar with all the different
methods which are available in this
class so that when you start using these
queues types or these collection types
you re you know what all utilities and
methods are available and even if you
don't know like i always mentioned if
you just do dot here it will automatic
any any good ide will automatically show
you all the methods which are available
here
which you can read about in the
documentation here and understand what
each method does and you can use that
method as well so that is also possible
so that's it i wanted to that's all i
wanted to cover in today's lecture and
in the next session we are going to talk
about classes and objects let's get
started with classes and objects in java
so like i have been promising in the
previous sessions that i will cover this
in a dedicated session and this is a
session where we will go deeper into the
concept of classes and objects
you have been seeing this keyword all
along in the all the sessions wherever i
ran the different examples and let's
understand what this means
technically if you go by the definition
a class is basically a blueprint of an
object which brings the question as what
is object an object is basically an
instance of the class
i know this becomes more confusing so
let's break it down into simpler
definitions
a class is technically a logical entity
it's you can think of it as any entity
in the world if you have to let's say if
you have to build
a student management system or a college
management system then all the real life
objects which you see we always say that
java is heavily inspired from real life
examples and classes and objects are the
reason we say that because whatever you
see in the world is always basically
some entity human beings are an entity
cars are an entity students are an
entity lecturers are an entity so who
are all the actors all the actors which
you see in the world are basically
entities and you can map them as classes
in the java program
now why do you want to map them because
these entities have basically
two
kind of specifications
one is every entity will have some
attributes and it will have some
behavior and actually that is how you
identify an entity for example human
beings have attributes like we have
hands we have eyes we have
ears legs etc these are our attributes
then we have our behaviors behaviors are
actions you can think of them as a human
being can speak so can speak is an
action it's a behavior can listen is an
is an action it's a behavior can walk is
an action is a behavior
similarly can eat is also an action or a
behavior so that's how you basically
represent an entity that's how basically
you identify an entity that an entity
will have some attributes and some
behavior if you see those two
specifications in any entity you can map
that entity or you can write that entity
inside a java program as a class because
a class in java will exactly have these
two properties
it will have some attributes which we
call as properties
and it will have some behaviors which
technically are called as methods so it
will have attributes and it will have
properties and
methods similar to real world entity
where we have attributes and behavior
behavior our methods and attributes are
properties that's how it is
if you if you apply this simple
philosophy whenever you are taking
requirements from a customer for a
particular project always try to
identify these entities these actors in
your program once you have identified
those you will be able to write a
corresponding java class
in your java program which can represent
those entities and without
representation of those entities you
cannot write the program so java will
kind of force you to think in this
direction to find entities which will
have attributes and behaviors
so taking that philosophy further and
taking that example further here for you
i have prepared an example where i am
creating a student class so basically
let's say if you have to build a college
management system or a student
management system then student is
probably one of the main entities which
will be
talked about when you take the
requirements
so if you think about the attributes and
the behavior concept a student will have
a name
will have an age will have an address
and at the same time a student
can also have some behaviors
like can enroll in a particular course
can attend a lecture can take a leave
can take exam etc these are all
behaviors
let's understand this in a more detail
with the help of this example where i've
created a class which is named a student
and you see the public keyword here
again i will cover access modifier
public is basically an access modifier
and i will cover this in very detail in
the upcoming sessions for now let's
focus on this part so we have created a
class to represent our entity you put a
curly braces around it it ends here
and after that you provide the
attributes
so here i'm saying that a student will
have a name it will have an age and it
will have an address it has three
properties so the technical name of
attributes is properties
after that let's skip this part and i
will come back to this part once you
have declared these properties
you would want to provide a way for
the name to be filled or replaced or
received for example if you have created
the student class how do you insert the
name inside the student class or how do
you insert the age or how do you insert
the address or modify the age name or
address properties
for that we have these
setters and getters methods we call them
setters and getters because they start
with this keyword not keyword but they
start with a string called set it is not
a keyword you can actually write it as
anything you can call it as modify name
that will also be absolutely fine java
will not give you an error but the
standard naming convention given by java
is to start the methods as starting with
set
and get
this is the stan this is the standard
naming convention and like i said it's a
naming convention it's not a compulsion
but if you write this way
your co-developers and the people who
are going to maintain this project in
the long run will be very happy
otherwise they will be very angry if you
use strange methods because like i said
this is the standard naming convention
so now you are going to write a setter
method for each of the properties in
this particular class for name age and
address so we call set name again you
put public void because this is not
supposed to return anything this is just
supposed to set the value of name with
whatever value you specified then you
call set name and then you provide the
value which you are supposed to set
against the name so whatever value like
any random name john or jane whatever
you need to supply that name here value
while you call this method and that name
of whatever you name your supply will be
set against the name property of this
particular class
and
remember i use the word this here
intentionally because the way you are
going to represent this is with the help
of this keyword this keyword means
current object it means that you are
when you use this dot name it is
referring to the current object's name
property and this name is basically
corresponding to the name which is
coming in when somebody
is trying to set a name similarly for
set age age is a numeric number if you
if you observed it's basically an
integer then i'm saying int h and
whatever value of h will be coming will
be set in this particular object's age
then similarly for set address we have a
string address
argument being passed into into this
method and this gets set inside the
current object's address property so i
have provided a way for the external
world to set the values of name age and
address because for each student you
would need to set these values
now you also need to provide a way to
receive the values or to return the
values or to read the values for reading
operation you need to provide the getter
method so you see this get again this is
not a keyword it's a standard naming
convention so similar when you when you
wrote set name similarly you will write
a get name method this get name method
is supposed to be reading the current
object's names properties value and will
return that value since name is a string
that's why you see the return type as
string here
similarly get age is going to return the
age which is an integer and address is
going to return the address you can also
write it like this which is absolutely
fine it is not going to complain because
technically it is returning the current
objects name properties and age property
and the address property now let's talk
about this what is what is this section
so this section is basically called a
constructor and i have a whole session
dedicated on the constructors but let's
understand why we need this
remember when i told you the definition
of the class i said that class is a
blueprint of an object
so you have created a student class and
you have 5000 students in your college
now you need to create a new student
object for each of those student you
need to initialize this student class
5000 times how do you do that
to do that
we do that with the help of constructors
we call this constructor this is a
special type of method remember this is
a special type of method which is
provided by java to initialize any
classes objects
if you want to create multiple objects
of the student class you can repeatedly
call this student constructor we call
this constructor so you put public here
because we want this constructor to be
accessible to the outside world then you
put the exact class name so whatever
class name you have provided here you
need to put the exact class name here if
you don't do that java is going to raise
an error
if i do this here it is going to you see
a red line here because java failed to
compile this constructor it does not
understand what is student triple one
but it does understand what is student
so this is how it is going to be and
then you provide all the properties
which are going to create the student
object so you're going to create the
name the age and the address so the name
age and address and then you set those
values again similar to the setter
methods we have seen the reason we need
to use this here because
if you don't if you write it like this
then java doesn't understand the
difference between the current objects
name and the name coming from the
argument so to differentiate that you
need to use this here if you use n here
and if i just use n here then this is
fine because there's only single name
variable in this whole class then but if
i write it like this
then and if i write it like this
then java doesn't know if this name is
basically the student class's name or
this name is student classes name it
will get confused like you are getting
confused if you if you try to just find
this in mind mapping so that's why
we need to write this here so that it's
clearly differentiable that whenever i
use this dot name i'm referring to the
classes name property and when i'm just
using the name i'm referring to the
method argument
that's what we do in doing this in this
constructor so you basically initialize
all the properties of your class with
some values with the help of constructor
we have the constructor we have the
setter we have the getter we can cover
about this two string basically this two
string is to print print something but
we can cover that later now uh let's
initialize this particular class so i'm
similar to the initialization we have
seen so far you just write student you
write the object name this can be
anything and then you use the new
keyword which is used to initialize
anything in java new is a keyword in
java which you can use to initialize
literally anything in java so you use
new student and when you say new student
you can provide all the values
which should match its constructor so
here we have three values
string
integer and string
and here also we are supplying three
values string integer and string again
so remember to match this exactly with
one of the constructors which is
available in the class if it doesn't
match it is going to fail it will not
work so if i for example if i do
this then i'm supplying four arguments
to the student class but there is no
constructor matching four arguments so
it is going to complain you see this red
line and the code is not compiling
if i remove this then it is matching it
and that's how you basically create a
student object so an object is basically
an instance of the class remember that
very well an object is an instance of
the class once you have created an
instance of the class then you can call
any method like say let's say you want
to read the name so you can call get
name you can read the name similarly if
you want to
so if you if you want to read the age of
this
student then you can do that as well so
let me just copy this
and
do this
let's call get
age
i want to print the name i want to print
the age
and i also want to print the address so
get control space i get suggestion
address yep so i'm printing the name i'm
printing the age and i'm printing the
address after i have initialized the
object successfully by using this
constructor representation using the new
keyword so now let's run this method or
run this class basically
okay so when i run this class the whole
class got compiled the constructor the
getters and the setters and the
properties and their types everything
was set then the main got called and i
created a new object from this classes
blueprint the object name was john then
i called john.getname to print the
name which is stored inside this
particular instance of the student class
similarly the age of
age which is stored in this particular
instance so we stored the name as john
so when we call john dot get name we get
john we got when we call john dot get
age we get the age 25 and we call john
dot get address we call we get this
particular address whatever values you
specified here the constructor got
called here and the name john got set to
the student's name value the age value
which you supplied got set against the
students age and the address value which
you supplied got set against the
students address and that's how you are
going to create a class so remember
whenever you create a class identify the
properties and the behaviors like setups
and getters
write a constructor which can cover all
the values which you want to initialize
and after that
just initialize that class create an
object of that particular class
basically and once you have the object
then you can call getters
you can also call this in this way if i
don't supply any of this
then it currently it complains and why
it complains i will cover that in the
following session whenever when i will
cover the multiple constructors concept
but remember you see this behavior here
that if you have created a constructor
which accepts some arguments and if you
supply this
kind of initialization then
student class does not have a
constructor which is parameter less
student class has only one constructor
which is taking three parameters and
that's why java complains because it is
not able to find a representation of a
constructor which accepts no parameter
but like i said we will cover this we
will find a solution to this particular
problem in the in the coming uh in the
coming session but for this session this
is all we are going to cover we covered
about classes we covered about objects
and we also saw how we can write getters
and setters we can initialize those
methods initialize those objects and we
can access the properties of those
objects using the getters and we can
also call the setters to modify the
values as well similar to this
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's session and in the next session
we are going to dive deeper in the
concept of constructors and how we can
write different types of constructors
let's get started with constructors in
java now if you remember in the previous
session we covered about the concept of
classes and we walked us through with an
example student class where we had a
constructor if i just open this back
this is the class which we covered in
the last lecture and we had this
constructor where we supplied the
required the necessary number of
arguments which can match my students
properties and then i set those
properties calling this dot property
equal to the argument like this
but what if you have a use case where
some of the values are mandatory and
some of the values are optional in these
properties section for example what if
all the students have same address
although this is a very hypothetical
situation but let's assume if if you
have a scenario where you have a
particular entity you have identified
the entity but there are certain
properties in the entity which remain
constant for all the objects if you have
such case then it does not make sense to
supply an argument for that
particular property which is going to
remain the same for all the objects what
if you can just initialize it with with
some default values that would be
simpler right because let's say for
example
if this property is going to remain
constant for all the student objects
then you can just supply these two
properties these two arguments in your
constructor and you don't need to supply
the address let's go further what if you
have a class where you have more than
one property let's say if your class has
10 properties and eight of them are
remaining constant or are optional and
only two are changing and mandatory then
how would you write that and what if you
have a different use case for the same
class let's make it even more
complicated that you have a single class
the same class or entity is being used
by different consuming applications
one application would expect let's say
these two to be mandatory and this one
to be optional other consumer
application wants these two to be
mandatory and this one to be optional
the third consuming application wants
all three to be mandatory the fourth
consuming application wants none of
these to be mandatory then how are you
going to do that the answer is multiple
constructors you can write multiple
constructors for each of those consuming
applications and whichever application
wants whichever constructor they can use
that constructor to initialize the
object of the class
so taking that concept further i have
created a class called cuboid
and i have three different properties
written in this class as we know that a
cuboid has basically three properties
which are width height and depth
so i'm taking that example here creating
a class for a cuboid providing the width
height and depth for simplicity i'm
taking this as integers but generally
you will see this as doubles probably
because the values can be in decimal
points but for simplicity's sake i'm
just keeping everything as integer here
then
with the standard use case if you have
to create an object of this cuboid class
you would need a constructor
where you can supply all these three
values and here it is this is the
constructor which can be called to
provide these three values so i'm
supplying the width i'm supplying the
height i'm supplying the depth depth and
then i am setting all of these values
with the this keyword say this dot width
equal to the coming width this object's
height will be the height which is
coming from here and this object's depth
will be the depth which is coming from
here
now for another use case where let's say
there's another consumer application
where it would expect the depth to be
constant for all of its objects let's
say a value 10 and it only wants width
and height to be supplied then you can
create another constructor java does
allow the use of multiple constructors
in the same class remember that concept
so you can create another constructor
for that representation where you supply
only the width and height
and you keep the depth constant now if a
consumer application calls this
constructor 100 times
all of those 100 cuboid objects will
have the depth as 10 only that will be
the fixed value and only width and
height will be the changing values
similarly if there's another consumer
application which wants to have the same
height and width and depth
for the cuboid then it would just
require a single parameter whatever
value the consumer application is
providing you are setting the same value
to the width to the height and to the
depth and to the depth so technically
this is basically becoming a cube
because then the three dimensions the
height width and depth are same
and what if you have another consumer
application which does not intend to
supply any of the values because for it
all the objects are going to hold the
exact same values for all the properties
let's say there's a consumer application
which would always expect the width the
height and the depth to be 10. then you
can create a constructor with the new
arguments you can see there is no
argument here you can create a
constructor like this and you can supply
all the default values which are static
values so in this case i have created
four constructors i have created this
constructor here which accepts all the
values and whenever you call this
particular object you will have to
specify three values and each object
will have the width height and depth
different
second use case where a consumer
application wants the depth to be
constant with the value 10 and only
wants the width and height to be
variable for each of the objects then
this particular constructor can be
called similarly for another consumer
application which
would want to create just supply a
single value and it would want whatever
value it supplies it would want the
height the width and the depth to be
exactly the same as that value supplied
then it will supply only one value and
the same value is going to be set
against height depth and width
and the fourth use case is where the
consumer application does not intend to
supply anything at all but it would want
the class to set some static values for
all of its objects so then it can call
this constructor
and then i define a behavior remember
the concept of behaviors i define a
behavior here i have not defined the
getters and setters here but you can
definitely do that there is nothing
stopping us from doing that but for
simplicity i just skip that here
then i define a behavior to basically
this class will provide a behavior which
will be to create the calculate the
value of volume based on the values
which you supply so whatever
value you supply based on that the
cuboid is going to calculate the volume
and as we know the formula of volume is
width into height into depth that is how
we are going to calculate the volume of
a cuboid based on whatever values of
width height and depth are supplied so
let's see this in action i've created a
public static void main method i've
initialized a variable called volume
which is an integer variable we'll see
how we can use that variable and first
let's create a standard cuboid so i call
this particular constructor with three
arguments so when i do this this
particular constructor gets called
and the width height and depth values
which i supply here three values will
get set and i get a standard cuboid and
then i can call the standard cuboid dot
volume then this particular method will
be invoked and the volume will be
calculated with this formula
with these values
that's how we are going to calculate the
volume for a standard simple cuboid and
i am printing that volume value exactly
here so this is basically the uh
standard constructor being called with
three arguments calling the volume
method and then just printing the volume
second use case where i'm calling the
constructor with two arguments and the
third value should be set automatically
so i'm just supplying two values here
when i call the constructor with two
values a matching constructor should be
found here with two values here it is so
width and height will be set with the
values which i am supplying and depth
will automatically be set to
10.
this is what is happening here cuboid
with some defaults and then i again
calculate the volume and print the
volume
i am just using the same volume variable
here in the third use case i am calling
the constructor with a single parameter
so i'm just providing one value and the
same value should get be should be set
against all the width height and depth
values and technically it becomes a cube
so i'll just call it as cube here
then i'm calculating the volume of the
cube and printing the volume of the cube
and then at last
i'm using the constructor with the new
arguments i'm calling this as default
cuboid because i'm not supplying any
values and then i'm again calling the
volume method on this
and printing the volume
so these are the four constructor
invocations so this class is
demonstrating four different kinds of
constructor invocations let's run this
class and observe the output
okay so let's start from here i called
this particular constructor with three
arguments 10 20 and 15 and then the
volume was calculated which would be 10
into 20 into 15 which is 3000
so this sysout basically prints this
output then move on to the next one
where i am saying cuboid with defaults
which is having the value 10 and 20 and
the third value of depth is
automatically being set to 10 so
technically when i call the volume it
will become 10 into 10 into 20 which is
2 000 and that's how the volume of the
cuboid default depth is printed from the
line 47 going on to the next one at line
51 the volume of the cube is basically
the volume which is calculated after
calling this particular constructor and
calling the volume method so here the
height the width and the depth all three
are set to 10 so it will technically be
when we call the volume method it will
be 10 into 10 into 10 which is 1000 and
that's how you get this output which
says volume of the cube is thousand
and then i call the default cuboid
method which is
simply providing no values and we expect
everything to be set with some defaults
and the default constructor is setting
the value as 10 for height width and
depth so in this case if i'm calling the
volume method and if i'm printing the
volume it should be printed as 1000
because 10 into 10 into 10 is thousand
so this is basically to showcase you how
you can use different constructors
there's another thing which you should
know is if you do not provide any
constructor to this particular class
let me just comment out all the
constructors in this class
and let me
comment out most of the code here as
well
so now if you see i have not provided
any constructor in this particular class
right there is no constructor let me
just
maximize this so there is no constructor
being called here there is no
constructor being left here everything
is commented so there is no constructor
in this class but this line still passes
there is no compilation error there is
no red line on this particular line the
reason is
if you do not provide a constructor to a
class java by default will provide a
constructor which will be the no
parameter constructor so remember that
whenever you don't supply any
constructor you can still create objects
of that class with this
non-parameterized constructor
representation like student student
equal to new student without any
parameters that will work if you have
not provided any constructor
implementation inside your class and if
you do that let's see what value do we
get because i have commented the default
constructor everything here right so
let's print the value
if i go to run as i get the value as 0.
so what happened here
when i call this particular line the
default constructor provided by java
gets called and java will set the values
of all the properties to the default
values which are supported by the data
type and integer primitive data types
default value in java is zero if you do
not provide any if you do not assign a
value to an integer variable by default
it is going to be initialized with zero
that's the java's behavior and that's
what is happening here because we did
not provided a default constructor so
when we call this new cuboid here
without any parameters without any
arguments
the default constructor of java gets
called and it sets everything with the
default values which is 0 0 0 and then
if we call the volume method it's
basically 0 multiplied by 0 multiplied
by 0
which will eventually be the output as 0
and that's how you get this 0 output
let's try one more thing what if i
enable one constructor let's enable any
one constructor which is non which is
having at least one parameter
let's say this one
so i have enabled one constructor i have
commented in i've just removed the
comments from one constructor which
takes a single argument and let's go
down
now you see an error so this is
something again a java's behavior that
if you provide even a single constructor
in your class which is non which is
having at least one parameter
i just repeat that if you create any
constructor in your class
which is having at least one parameter
then the default constructor
implementation of java will not
automatically work
in this case you will have to explicitly
provide a default constructor as well
the default constructor will only and
only work if you have not provided any
constructor at all in your class the
moment you provide even a single
constructor which is having even a
single parameter in your class
then the default constructor out of the
box will not work and you will have to
explicitly provide a default constructor
so to make this work i have to just
enable the default constructor code and
then only it will pass so if no
constructor it will work without any
parameter but the moment you provide
even a single constructor with even
single argument then you have to either
use that parameterized constructor or
you have to provide your own default
constructor implementation because java
will not use its own default constructor
implementation in that class
so i hope you find this particular
concept useful and remember this concept
because this is again this can be
confusing when you are reading somebody
else's code you need to always
understand what all constructors are
there and in the next session we are
going to talk about another very
interesting and exciting concept in java
which is about streams let's get started
with streams in java before i go any
further i just wanted to clarify that
when i say stream i am not talking about
the input output stream but i'm talking
about stream as a concept in general
this is a slightly newer concept which
was introduced in java 8 and has been
there and it is extremely popular and
the reason java introduced this the
concept of streams to uh to the jdk was
to promote the functional programming
paradigm what we have been seeing so far
is basically an object or the same lines
of code which you would write in java in
an in a classic object-oriented way in
like let's say 10 lines the same line of
code that whole 10 lines of code can be
written in a single line using the
functional programming paradigm so let's
understand the concept of streams first
so the basic concept of streams is to
help you hydrating and manipulating
collections so remember all the classes
which we covered in the collections
framework the list the set the map etc
streams provide you with a better and
optimized way to basically allow you to
manipulate those collections iterate
over those collections change the
representation of the collection types
etc so to understand why we need streams
let's understand what is how the
streaming works so let's take a very
simple example if you if you watch a
youtube video it is basically streamed
to your device and when we say stream it
means the whole object the whole video
size is not downloaded at once on your
device and it is being downloaded bit by
bit to your device piece by piece to
your device this is better in lot of
ways your device does not need the full
memory to store the complete video
because it is only going to process one
byte at a time and just throw it away
once it has been watched so the
streaming will basically
help you work on a very large size item
you know we're using a very small memory
footprint that's the power of streams
contrary to that you can also let's say
if you are if you're watching a one
gigabytes video then you can either
download the whole one gigabyte video on
your mobile which is going to consume
complete one gigabyte space on your
memory or you can stream that one
gigabyte video onto your mobile device
where maybe only a few megabytes will be
required to watch the whole video
because at a time it will only consume
few megabytes and it does not need one
gigabyte of complete space to stream
that video so that's the basic idea and
that's why streams are very popular and
very optimal way to work with
collections and let's understand with
the help of an example actually i've
prepared multiple examples of multiple
capabilities of the streams api so
streams is basically an api which is
provided after java 8 and you can use
that to iterate over collections or
manipulate collections let's see that
and let's also compare that with how you
have been doing this before java 8 so
here i have created a list you can see
it's basically an integer list and i
have created an array list here i have
added few numbers to this particular
error list so numbers are 10 20 30 and
40. so precisely four elements are
inserted into the list
now you have a requirement in your
project that you need to basically
calculate the square of each of the
elements of the list
and prepare a new list
that is the requirement
so if you were not using streams you
would write code something like this you
will initialize the list a new list
basically which will which you can call
it as anything for example you can call
it as squares list and then you are
going to call an enhanced for loop here
iterating over the numbers list one by
one taking each element calculating the
square of it and then adding that
element to the new list and that's how
you are going to write this logic if you
were not using streams so you can see
it's basically technically one two three
four lines of code just to get the list
if you were using streams then you can
do this with a single line let me just
comment out the
old code
and let me just bring this
to the same line to show you that it's a
single line code so the same logic which
you wrote here can be written just like
this
you can see it's so optimal so simple
for the processor to compile this code
is also very fast because they can
process a single instruction very fast
and very quickly and streams do utilize
the multi-core capabilities as well so
now is the time and that and the era of
multi-core processors and that's why
streams are more beneficial to use
rather than writing the verbose
instructions so let's understand how
this works to convert a particular
collection into a stream you need to
call the collectiontype.stream
so here the numbers list was the
collection variable so once you call
this dot stream you will get a stream
representation now the elements of the
list are being streamed one by one they
are not being sent at all at once they
are streamed one by one now so you get a
stream the element you call stream
then now the stream api has multiple
methods or utility methods which you can
read about for example if i just write a
dot here you will see lots of utility
methods which the stream api provides
you which you can use in different
conditions
we are going to cover few of the very
important and very popular methods but
again please do read out the streams api
documentation to get the hang of all the
other methods so once we have the stream
then the first method which i'm going to
showcase to you out of the stream api is
the map method
map method can be used to change the
representation of the elements one by
one and that's what we need to do right
we need to change the representation of
these elements to the square of these
elements so remember that that line
which i said whenever you have to change
the representation of the elements
inside the collection think of map think
of the map method this is not the map
collection this is not the map
collection this is the map method of the
stream api so if you're using stream api
you have a use case to convert the
representation of the elements of the
collection think about maps always
so i call the map method here and then
you see the strange syntax here this is
basically a lambda function syntax so
lambda function is another concept which
java introduced in java 8. uh lambda is
as a concept has been there in in some
other programming languages like scala
for a very long time but it's been
introduced in java of late in java 8
only and lambda is basically now you can
say is the paradigm which will enable
you to write functional programming
constructs in java and the syntax of
lambda is very straightforward
you provide a representation of the
element here so each element here one by
one is going to be represented to x
then you write this arrow here basically
a hyphen and a
greater than sign and after that you
write what
is the
final value which you want to see for
that particular element so here my
requirement was that i want to convert
the representation of the element to the
square of its element so i just do x
into x because x is the current element
i want to change this to this so
whatever destination representation you
have in your mind write that on the
right hand side of this arrow on the
left hand side it will be the element on
the right hand side it would be the
representation which you want to work
with
so you have written your conversion
logic inside the map method with a
lambda function representation under the
hood if you want to know more technical
details about it it's basically working
on the concept of functional interfaces
do read about the functional interfaces
concept as well that will help you build
the cons the usage of lambda functions
and how this whole construct is written
so read about functional interfaces and
lambda functions to understand map in
detail and what but for to to work with
it like i said this the left-hand side
will be the element and the right-hand
side would be the uh final
representation which you want to have
for that particular element once you
have done that still this till this
particular point you have converted the
collection into the stream it is
streaming the elements one by one and
you have successfully also calculated
calculated the square of each element
but this is still a stream
now you need to convert this stream back
to
a list which can be used further in your
program so to do that you can use the
collect method which we also call as the
terminal methods this is another uh
concept which i'm just introducing to
you right now so there is an
intermediate method concept and there is
a terminal method concept
this is what streams understand
javascript understands when you say
intermediate method those methods are or
those operators are basically the ones
which are used before the final
collection is prepared like the map
method is basically a intermediate
operation and then you have some
terminal operations like collect once
you call the terminal operations after
that the stream has been concluded the
stream is dead so once you call this
collect method
and if you try to
do something here again let's say if you
want to do something it will not work
because the moment you use the collect
method stream will expect this to be the
last method which you want to use in
this particular instruction after that
the stream is dead and you will get
strange exceptions if you try to write
any further operation after collect so
do so also do read about what are the
all the different terminal operations
available and what are all the
intermediate operations available i'm
going to cover a bunch of these in this
in the different examples i've prepared
in this particular class but um because
i will not be able to cover all of the
methods so do read about those methods
what are the intermediate operations and
what are the terminal operations and the
concept i just explained you
intermediate operations can be used in
in a chaining fashion after this dot map
you can use another dot map another dot
map another dot map you can again fight
like do this this will
this will work fine you can keep
concatenating multiple map methods and
multiple filter methods and any of the
other intermediate operations which are
available but once you have called the
collect method after this you cannot
call another map if you try to do this
it is going to fail it will not work
because collect is a terminal operation
and what i want to do in the terminal
operation is i want to convert this new
stream which is having the square of the
elements convert that back into a new
list and to do that i can call the
collectors.to list method the moment you
write this method inside the collect
method it is going to take the stream of
the elements one by one
just collate that stream into a single
stream uh into a single collection and
then return that collection back into
the list which you want to store is it
in so remember the correct method
terminal operation and the moment you
you do collectors.2 list the whole
stream elements is going to be
converted into a list and that list is
going to be stored into whatever left
hand variable you have written and that
is how you can basically write this
whole code which we wrote in four lines
into just one line and then you can
print the squares list so let's do that
let me comment this particular code as
well so that we don't get any strange
errors or strange outputs
let me comment this part as well we will
cover this one by one
and let me cover all of this as well i'm
just going to comment everything here
and we'll focus on only the square list
which we have prepared using the streams
api so right click run as java
application
there you go you have the output here so
the first number was 10 the square of it
is 100 so yes you get 100 second number
is 20 the square of it is 400 third
number is 30 the square of it is 900
fourth number is 40 the square of it is
1600 so you get all the values squared
by using the stream api and like i said
you can write the same code in the old
way as well but this is the efficient
and the better way of writing the same
code in a single line this is all i
wanted to cover in today's session let's
get started with streams api in java in
the previous session also we covered
some basic functionality of the streams
api of how we can convert a list of
numbers into the squares of the numbers
of the same list today we are going to
look at an extension of the same kind of
functionality let's say you have a
requirement where you have a list and
you are asked to convert that list into
a set and while you convert the list
into set you also have to calculate the
square of each number so instead of just
converting the list of numbers into a
set you have to convert the square of
those numbers into a set collection that
is our objective so i'm going to use the
same list which i had created in the
previous example which you can see here
i have a numbers list and i've added
four elements to it 10 20 30 and 40
and then if i did not have to use stream
or if i did not have the option to use
stream this is how the code would look
like where you would explicitly create a
set of type hash set
and then you will iterate over the
numbers list and then you will pick each
item of the numbers list and multiply it
by itself hence calculating the square
and then you will be adding those that
that result into the destination set
this is what i'm doing here just to show
you that different comparison of how do
you write it in the classical way and
then in a while we will look at how we
can write the same kind of functionality
using the streams api
so let's first run this particular
approach where i'm adding all the square
of all the elements into a set which is
a hash set type so the order of the set
is not guaranteed because i'm using a
hash set and then i'm just printing the
hashtag
so let's try to run this program
so i go to run as java application and i
get the output and you can see if you
look at the list here the results are
not in the same sequence in which the
elements were added into the list it is
because of the nature of the hash set
but we do get the result as expected now
if i have to write the same kind of
functionality
using the streams api then this is how i
will write it i will just uncomment this
one and will comment out this one
so now if i look at this new code it's
doing the exact same thing but in a
functional programming approach and
using the streams api approach so i'm
again calling dot stream hence
converting the list into a stream
then calling map which is to use to
change the representation of the
elements of the collection so i'm
changing the representation from the
single number to the square of it and
then calling dot collect which is a
terminal operator where i am converting
this stream
into a set by calling collectors dot two
set so two set is the method here which
is going to convert this into a set
and then i'm printing the square set so
let's run this program and observe the
output
if i run the program i get the same
output so i can achieve the same kind of
functionality but much more efficiently
using the streams api
so this was an example where i could use
the collectors.two set method to create
a set out of a list now let us move
forward to another interesting and very
popular functionality which is filtering
so let me comment this code again so
that we don't get multiple outputs and
let me uncomment this code here
so what i'm doing here is i'm creating a
list of languages which is an arraylist
and then i'm adding three elements to
this particular error list which are
java python and scala and this is a
string of
the list of strings here so i'm adding
three strings here these strings can be
anything i've just taken the example of
programming languages here but this can
be anything so technically we have a
list of string objects and then my task
is to
get a new list out of this existing list
which will have the elements which start
with the letter p let's say that is your
requirement that you have to get only
the elements of this list where the name
of the element starts with the letter p
if that is your requirement
probably this is how you will be writing
the code if you are not using the
streams api where you will create a new
list an empty list basically and then
you will iterate over the old list which
is the languages
so you will iterate over the languages
list and then you will pick the each
element of this particular list and
check if that string starts with the
letter p
if yes then you will add that particular
string element into the new filter list
by calling the add method and then you
can print that particular list that is
how you will be doing it if you were not
using streams
so let's run this program and understand
the output so i'm again going to right
click run as java application
and the output i get is python because
that is the only string in the list
which starts with the letter p so we get
the expected output now let's try to
write the same code using the streams
api so let me comment this code and i
will save the file and let's look at how
we can do the same thing in a single
line using the streams api so to use to
write the same kind of logic using the
stream api we start with the same kind
of syntax where we take languages dot
stream to convert the list into a stream
and then we call a new method called
filter so filter is the method which you
will be using whenever you have to write
any conditional logic on all the
elements of the list remember whenever
you have to write a filtering or a
conditional logic on a particular list
then you will be using the filter method
of the streams api so you will convert
the collection into the stream and then
you will apply the filter method to
apply the condition this condition can
be anything in this case the condition
is that the elements should start with p
it can be anything for example it can be
based on the string length if you want
if it's a numbers collection it can be
if a number is greater than 100 or not
so any kind of if logic which you might
have to run on a particular collection
can be run using the filters method
so if we call the filter method and we
again follow the same lambda function
syntax where we here this particular s
denotes each element one by one and this
arrow represents the lambda notation and
then what we want to do that we want to
run this condition
on each of the element of the stream one
by one and the condition is that the
element should start with the letter p
if that is true then
whichever elements satisfy this
particular condition will be getting out
after this execution so the block which
i have selected once the filter method
has completed its execution after that
only the elements which have satisfied
this filtering condition will be left in
the stream rest of the elements have
been filtered out so once you have the
filtered result then you can again call
the collect method which is the terminal
operator and you call collectors dot to
list same as the example in covered in
the previous session so i'm running the
filtering logic and getting a new list
which will have only the elements which
satisfy this condition so i get the
collectors.2 list result back into our
new list which is called filter result
and then i'm printing the filter result
so let's see if we get the same kind of
output if we use this logic yes we do
get the same kind of output and this is
something which validates how we can use
the filter operation seamlessly by
applying exactly the same kind of logic
which we used to apply by writing this
much verbose code another benefit is
that the streams api are more efficient
in using the multi-core processors which
are common nowadays on any machine
so this is all i want to cover in
today's session i don't want to last
this session to be even more longer so
we will conclude today's session at this
particular point and in the next session
we are going to have a look at some more
functionalities of the stream api seeing
how we can sort the collections how we
can iterate over the collections because
even this code is a bit too much for the
uh for for the streams api to iterate
over a collection we will look at a
smarter way of the streams api by which
we can hydrate over the collection we
will also have a look at how we can sort
collections let's get started with how
we can use the streams api to sort
collections and also to iterate over
collections
and i'm going to use the same
collections which we have used in the
previous sessions just to build some
sort of continuity here so i'm going to
use the same array list which i created
in the previous session which is storing
a string of elements which is having
three strings which is java python and
scala these are just three strings which
i am storing into a list which is called
languages and now my task is to sort
this particular collection i have to
sort the elements of this particular
list so that when i access the list i
get the elements accessed in a natural
sorting order so i should get the result
java first then python as a second
result and scala as the third result
let's make it bit more interesting let
me put this at the beginning so now i
have and let our element starting with s
being added first then an element
starting with j being added second and
the third element being added which
starts with p
let me add one more string to it just to
make it bit more interesting and
practical so let me add a new language
here which can be let's call it basic so
now i have four elements here and now i
want to sort this particular collection
so for sorting streams api provide a
very straightforward way to sort any
kind of collection which is to use the
dot sorted method and we will follow the
same kind of semantics which we have
followed in the previous session which
is you pick the current collection call
the dot stream method on it which will
convert the collection into a stream and
once the stream has been created then
you call the dot sorted method on the
stream which is going to sort all the
elements of the stream in a natural
sorting order remember we are using
strings here so java already knows how
to sort strings if you were using a
custom class let's say list of students
or list of customers then you have to
specify your sorting implementation to
java because java doesn't know how to
sort customers or how to sort students
so you in that case you will have to
provide your own sorting implementation
and we will cover that in the upcoming
sessions but for now let's understand
this example by using one of the
pre-built data types which is string and
we call the dot sorted method which is
going to sort this particular stream and
then we use the terminal operator which
is dot collect to convert this stream
back to a list and we do that by calling
collectors dot to list we do that and we
get the list out we store that list into
a variable called sorted list and then
we print the sorted list so let's run
this program and understand the output
remember that we have these strings
added here
so right click run as java application
and this is the result i get i get basic
as the first element when i get the new
list which has all the sorted elements
then i get java with a j then i get
python with a p and then i get scala
with an s so you can see that these
strings are presented in a natural
sorted sequential order here and that is
what is happening because we call the
sorted method and this is how you can
use the streams api to sort any kind of
collection hope this is helpful to
understand the concept of sorting now
let's move on to another concept which
is about how do you iterate over
collections using the streams api we
already have a way of iterating over the
collections using the enhanced for loop
remember we covered this at length in
different sessions in the past so we can
definitely use this particular logic it
doesn't break it will not stop us from
using this we can still continue using
the enhanced for loop logic to iterate
over any kind of collection but streams
api provides even a smarter way to
iterate over the collections let's see
how we can do that so let me uncomment
this particular code here and now if i
look at this particular code and if i
try to understand it i will see a sort
of similarity with the way we have been
working with streams so we'll follow the
same drill we'll pick up the existing
collection called the dot stream method
on it this is going to convert the
collection into a stream and then we
call dot for each method this is the
method which you need to use whenever
you want to iterate over a collection
using the streams api so we call the dot
for each method again follow the same
lambda construct where this is each of
the element y represents each of the
element here and then i
write the code which is supposed to be
executed for each element so in this
case i want to just print every element
that is my requirement when i'm
hydrating over this particular
collection so i can just put this arrow
here let me put the spaces here to make
it more legible so each element
should be applied this particular logic
on and we are printing each of the
element one by one if i do that let's
observe the output and let me comment
this particular code which we just
covered for the sorting logic so we get
only one output let's run this code now
so here we see we get some output here
first of all this sysout gets printed
which says printing all elements one by
one yes that's there and then here we
are saying element is which is a static
string and then every element one by one
is supposed to be printed and that is
what we see here we get all the elements
one by one and here it's not a sorted
order because we are not doing any
sorting here it's just printing all the
elements so this is how you can use the
for each method to iterate over any
collection in a single line of code
instead of writing all of that code now
you might be wondering what if i don't
have to i have to do more than just
printing the element what is it is a
multiple lines of code which i have to
run for each element how do i do that
it's pretty straight forward we just put
curly braces here in the starting and in
the end of the code block inside the for
each method and let me just put an enter
here just to make it more readable so
here you can write the code whatever you
want to in terms of the kind of logic
you want to apply on each element so
once you have put this curly braces you
can write as many lines of logic as
required inside this code in the inside
this curly base braces block and this
code is going to be executed for each of
the element one by one if you have just
one line of code you do not need to and
you should not put the curly braces if
it's just one line of code just drop
this curly braces completely remove the
semicolon as well along with the curly
braces and this is how you will run a
single line of code but if you have a
multiple lines of code which suppose
which is required to be run for each of
the element then you put the curly
braces and then you follow the normal
java construct which is to end every
statement with a semicolon the usual
java programming code basically which
can go inside the curly braces so that's
how you can use for each for any simple
and complex iteration logic which you
want to apply on a particular program
and this is all i want to cover in
today's session so we talked about how
we can use the dot sorted method to sort
a particular collection and we also had
a look at how we can use the streams api
for each method to iterate over the
collections in the next session we are
going to talk about a very interesting
method of the streams api and a very
popular one which is called the reduce
functionality let's get started with
using the reduce functionality in the
streams api
before we go to the implementation of
the reduced functionality let us
understand why do we need it and how the
constructs of the reduced functionality
work so let's understand first about the
requirement why do we need it
so imagine a requirement where you have
a list of numbers and you are asked to
calculate the sum of all the elements
inside the list a very straightforward
requirement that you have a collection
and you are asked to calculate the sum
of all the elements of the collection
now if you do not use the streams api
you can go ahead and very well write a
complex for each logic or enhanced for
loop logic to basically run that code
and write the logic where you pick one
element all the elements one by one and
keep adding them to the new element
but we can do the same kind of thing by
using the reduce method and to put it in
a generic way if we have to understand
why we need reduce methods so whenever
you have to change the whole collection
representation into a single result
remember that line whenever you have to
change the representation of the
complete collection into a single result
in those cases you will use the reduce
method of the streams api and if you
apply this definition to the example i
gave you i have a collection of numbers
and i want to calculate the sum of all
the elements of this collection which is
a single result which is a single number
so yes my example does apply correctly
to the generic definition of the reduced
method so remember this generic
definition this will help you understand
when to use the reduce method in your
program
so how does the reduce method work you
can see i have shown you an example of
the syntax of the reduce method and it
looks a bit complex here so let's try to
understand what is happening here to
understand the functionality of the
reduce method we have to understand
three terms which are identity
accumulator
and a combiner
let's understand each of them one by one
identity is basically an element which
is the default or the initial value of
the reduction operation
this value will be used if the stream
itself is empty or it will be used as
the first value of the result which you
want to get out eventually so in this
case if i have to submit all the
elements of a collection the initial
value can be set as 0 and that is the
first thing which you have to pass
inside the reduce method so you can see
0 here the next thing is the accumulator
so accumulator is a function which will
take two parameters the first parameter
would be the ongoing partial result
let's say if you have to calculate the
sum of the all elements and let's say if
you have iterated two elements so far so
the sum of those two elements is your
temporary or partial result right so you
need to store that partial result
somewhere and that is the first argument
of the accumulator method in this case
it is this variable which is shorthanded
as ans or answer
so the first argument is the partial
result and the second argument of the
accumulator function is the next element
of the stream so whatever the next
element is which is supposed to be added
to the existing result is going to be
the next argument of the accumulator
function which is i in this case
so we talked about the identity we
talked about about the accumulator
function then we have a third one which
is called combiner
and this is sort of an optional not in
all cases but in in some cases it is
optional let's understand why do we need
combiner so combiner is an optional
function which you will be required to
use if you want to sum the two elements
which do not have the same data type
what i mean is here this ans or answer
and i both are integer if both of the
arguments of your accumulator function
are of the same data type you do not
need a combiner and that's why there's
no combiner here but if there is a
requirement where you are let's say
adding a a correct sum to a student
object then it doesn't work right
because a student object is a custom
object and the current sum is a number
object so a student object cannot be
just added to a number object
it can work if you can do dot get age
which is a number object so a current
answer plus the student dot get age
might work but current answer comma
student will not work in those cases
where you have mismatching data types in
those cases you will have to write a
combiner function but for this case you
don't need to write a combiner function
because both of the elements or the
arguments of the accumulator function
are of the same data type so you specify
that argument function
functions arguments basically and then
you provide the implementation of the
accumulator function which is this one
this is the implementation again using a
lambda construct here so you provide the
implementation of this particular
accumulator function and then there is
no comma here to provide further comb
combiner functions specifications so
there's no combiner here if there was a
combiner there would be a comma here and
then you will write the combiner
specification where you will cast the
current object into the type
which is the same as the partial result
so you don't need that here and you can
just say the partial result plus the
current element and that should work
fine so this is how you will write the
reduced logic and if you have written
this logic correctly then it should
automatically just submit all the
elements one by one and produce a single
result and remember i'm using the
numbers list here which is
written here in the very beginning where
i have four elements to it which are 10
20 30 and 40. so if the reduce operation
works fine with with my intended
objective then 40 plus 30 which is 70
plus 20 is 90 plus 10 is 100 so i should
get the 100 as that as the final result
of this reduce operation you will also
notice that after this particular method
you don't need to call any collector
method or any collect method at all the
reason is because this particular
function itself will return a single
result which we can store in the desired
variable so now let's try to run this
particular example and see the output
so right click run as java application
and i get the result as 100 which is
coming from this particular sysout where
i'm printing the sum so yes this is
working as per our expectation where it
basically
created the sum of all the elements of
this particular collection so remember
when you will use the reduce operation
remember the generic definition whenever
you have to convert the whole collection
into a single result that would be the
use case where you will use the reduce
operation that's one thing remember the
identity operators definition remember
the how the accumulator function works
and also remember when to use that
combiner function a reminder of when to
use the combiner function is whenever
you have these two arguments of
different data types that would be the
use case where you would need to write a
combiner function it is also used if you
have to write parallel streams but
parallel streams is an advanced concept
which we are not covering in this
particular tutor but if you want to
learn about the the whole parallel
stream concept do check out the api docs
for that and you can also have a look at
some examples from the java tutorial
official website itself
and that's all i want to cover in
today's session in the next session we
are going to talk about the access
modifiers in java let's get started with
access modifiers in java so when we talk
about access modifiers let's understand
what is the underlying philosophy of the
reasoning behind this
and the reasoning is very
straightforward it can be even wrapped
into a single word which is called
security the reason is that you will be
creating multiple kinds of objects and
variables while you write your java
program and you should always write your
java program or any program in a manner
that only the intended classes packages
modules or applications should be able
to see what they are supposed to see
so as a consumer application i should
only be able to consume the variables
which i am expected to consume i should
not get any variable or i should not
even have access to any variable which i
am not supposed to access so the idea is
providing the least privilege principle
give access to different functions
different variables different programs
only by providing them the kind of
access which they need to run
efficiently and do not give them
complete access so with that notion in
mind java created the concept of access
modifiers and it created these three
modifiers which are called public
protected and private if you do not
provide any modifier then it goes to no
modifier or some people also call it as
default modifier which is also a type of
access modifier so let's understand
theoretically first how it works and
then we will try to have a look at an
example let's understand the first one
first of all these modifiers are
keywords and you can use these keywords
in front of classes in front of
variables and also in front of methods
and you might have already noticed this
particular keyword called public in
front of all the classes i have created
or even when we talked about the public
static void main method we saw this
public as a keyword it is basically an
access modifier and whenever you put
public in front of a class or a variable
or a method that particular component
becomes available to the whole of the
program it will be available to the
whole world basically any subclass or
any package or any other class which
might have been written in your java
program will be able to access that
particular class or variable or method
if you put public in front of that the
second modifier level is protected one
of the other thing which you you will
understand as i explain this is that as
you move down into this particular table
the access level will start getting more
and more restricted by restriction i
mean that less and less components will
be able to get access to those modifiers
so if you write protected in front of a
class or in front of a method or in
front of a variable then everything
within that particular class will still
be able to access it
everything within the package will still
be able to access it i still haven't
covered the concept of package but i
briefly touched upon it showing you how
whenever we write a class we have a
package in front of it and package is
technically is just an aggregation of
the classes if you have to write write
multiple classes and wrap all of those
classes into a single logical bundle
that would be called a package just to
show you an example these all are
packages which you see here you see this
square box here and you see that these
names these all are packages and these
packages contain multiple classes and
technically that's all the packages mean
that you can wrap multiple related
classes into a single package so coming
back to the access modifier whenever you
write protected in front of a class or a
variable or a method then that
particular component will be accessible
to everybody within the same class
everybody within the same package it
will also be accessible to everybody
which is a subclass of the class this is
again a new concept which i have not
covered but this basically means a child
of this class now what is a child of the
class we will cover at
that concept in detail when we will talk
about inheritance but for now you can
understand that it is a basically an
extension of the class so
when the moment you declare something is
protected it can easily be accessible
within the same class in which this
protected component was declared it can
be accessed in the package it can also
be accessed in the subclasses of the
class but anything outside the package
will not be able to access it because
you see an n here then we have the
default access modifier or no modifier
if you do not write anything in front of
a class or a method or a variable it
gets the default access modifier
privileges and that privilege mean that
anybody within the same class will be
able to access that default variable or
a default component anybody within the
package will also be able to access it
the subclasses of the class where the
default component was declared those
subclasses will not be able to access it
and anybody outside the package will
obviously not be able to access it
then comes the last one which is the
most restricted privilege which is
called private so if you put private in
front of a class or in front of a method
or in front of a variable that component
will only be accessible within the class
where it was declared
it will not be accessible in the package
it will not be accessible in the
subclasses and definitely not be
accessible to anybody outside the
package so private is the least
privileged or least access permission
level you have in java once you write
private in front of any component that
only the the classes other variables the
same class in which you declare this
particular private variable only that
class itself will be able to access it
and nobody else will be able to access
it and as you move above the accesses
become more and more lenient you can see
there is just one y and three n here the
moment you move a bit above to the
default modifier you get two y's so
everybody in the class and everybody in
the package will be able to access that
particular component rest of for the
rest of the other world it is still
unknown when you write something as
protected then everything in the class
everything in the package and everything
in the subclasses will also be able to
access it rest of the world cannot
access it and if you write something as
public then anybody can access it it's
like y everywhere so that is how the
access levels work now let us understand
this with the help of example
so i will go here and i've just written
a very simple dummy class here which has
uh which is a class called test and i
have a method here which is a display
method so very simple class nothing
fancy here and if you if you notice i
have not put any kind of public private
or
or protected modifier in front of the
class so this will get the default
privilege
if something has default privilege then
the whole world will not be able to
access it so let's go to a different
package let's go to this package which
is here
and let's try to access this particular
test class so we will try to access this
test.java here in the main class
so let's try to do that let's say test t
equal to new test i'm just initializing
the same class
so what do i get i get a compile error
let me try to fix it if i can and i
cannot fix it if you see i'm just trying
to use this particular test class into a
different package but that package is
not able to see the class at all i'm
getting a compilation error and if i try
to click on the error generally eclipse
provide me suggestions to fix the to
import this particular class but eclipse
is not able to find and find any class
with the name of test which can be
imported in this package which is a
different package than the one of the
test class so we cannot access it
because it's in the default access
now let's go back to the test class and
let's make it public
so i've just made it public here and now
if i click on this again i get the
suggestion if you see the suggestion was
not there earlier now it says import
test and if i click on this double click
it gets imported and everything is happy
so you can see the whole access modifier
in effect here the default walls is
versus public you can also try the other
other kind of uh
access modifiers let's try private as
well i think private will also have the
same effect because it will still not be
accessible from the package or from the
subclass from or from the from the whole
world we already saw this particular in
effect but we will see the private in a
different way now
so going back to the test class i have
made the class as public but the method
here is default i have not exposed this
method to be used outside the class
let's see what happens if i try to call
this display method from the main class
so i have successfully initialized the
class and if i say t
dot
and if i look at the suggestions here
i do not get the suggestion of the
display method
why because it is default
if i go back
make it private
can i now access it let's try again nope
still we can't access it eclipse is not
even able to find it inside this package
because it is private
let's go back and make it public
so i've made it just public now going
back to the main class and again saying
t dot now i get the display suggestion
as the first suggested method here and
now i am able to use the display method
once i have made it public so you see
the moment you change the uh the access
modifiers the changes are propagated
immediately and you can see the public
versus default versus private in play
here we can even go into further detail
by using the protected but for protected
i have to explain the concept of
subclasses so i will cover this
protected versus subclasses concept when
i talk about inheritance and there we
will see the usage of protected
variables and the protected access
modifier but we saw the usage of public
the default modifier and the private
modifier do check out the documentation
for these access modifiers and i would
strongly suggest you to play around with
this get more comfortable with this
concept of different kind of modifiers
let's also run an example for for
understanding the default modifier in a
better sense because we can see that for
the package it says why right so let's
go back to eclipse and within the same
package where we created test class
let's create another class let's call it
test
demo
so i will just click finish
i get a new class let me also
write the public static void main method
here so i get the public static void
main method here and let's try to access
the test class here within the same
package so let me again go back to the
default privilege here so i put the test
class access as the default class or
default access and same goes for display
so can other classes in the same package
access the test class now let's see that
if i go to test demo and here if i try
to get the test class initialize does it
work or does it give me a compilation
error yes it works it works because the
test class and the test demo are in the
same package and test class has that
default access
privilege so let's try to run one more
variation of it to understand the usage
of the private method better going back
to the test class this display method
has the default privilege right now so
going by that logic if i say t dot i
should be able to get access to the
display method and yes that is possible
if i run this particular program i will
be able to get whatever is given out by
the display method which is hello world
now let's try to make this particular
method as private and let's try to
access this method from one of the other
class in the same package as of the test
class so the class is default the method
is private
and if you see this class has already
turned red there is a compilation error
because now the display method is not
accessible to the test demo class even
if it was in the same package it's not
accessible because the display methods
privilege or access modifier has gone to
private now exactly the same as
explained here because it has become
private so the package level members
cannot access it there's an n here so
this is this was another variation to
show you how you can use public
protected and private together to only
expose the members methods and classes
which are supposed to be exposed to the
consumer this is a very critical and
very important concept to be used in
java and it is used from a very simple
program to all the highly complex
application this is sort of the bare
bone or the
laying foundation for any kind of basic
security level premise which you need to
build your application so that's all i
want to cover in today's session where
we discussed about the different access
levels in the next session we are going
to talk about the concept of inheritance
let's get started with inheritance
so inheritance is basically one of the
most important properties of any
object-oriented programming language
it's basically a concept and the concept
says that what if you have a scenario
where you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example let's take the example of a
bank
when you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account it can be
a type of current account there can also
be a different offering for personal
account and commercial accounts such as
for businesses
then you may also have loan accounts
which are having different kind of
properties so all of these types of
accounts are still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example all
of them will have to maintain some sort
of an interest rate for example all of
them will be used to either deposit
money or withdraw money so there would
be some kind of similarity across all of
these types of account classes but at
the same time there will also be some
sort of differentiality amongst these
classes the way you will calculate the
interest rate for a current account will
be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate for a
savings account and the same applies for
commercial account personal account loan
account etc so you see that we have some
common behavior but at the same time we
also have some different behavior so
whenever you have such scenario always
think about applying the concept of
inheritance in your application there is
another simple way to spot whether
inheritance can be used at a particular
place or not inheritance is also called
is a relationship so whenever you read
the requirements from a customer just
try to find the words which use this
particular phrase is a
for example
car is a vehicle
savings account is a type of account
similarly you will find many other types
of similar examples so whenever you will
see that is a relationship between two
different kinds of objects or two
different kind of entities that means
that there might be an inheritance
relationship being applied between them
and that's how you will spot the usage
of inheritance
so so far we have understood this
concept that there would be some sort of
relationship between the two classes
what would be this relationship the
relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class some
people also call that as base class and
then there will be a child class
so the child class will be inheriting
the properties and the behaviors from
the base class or from the parent class
i will be using base class and parent
class terms interchangeably during this
session but the basic idea and basic
premise is like that only that there
will be a child class and there will be
a parent class and the child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh what you see here is
basically the official definition which
is given by javadocs here we can read
the definition as well and the basic
idea which i told you lies in the parent
and child relationship and this is how
you can conceptualize it that you will
have a base class or a parent class and
then you will you can have multiple
children of it and then those children
can again have their own children and so
on so forth so this hierarchy this whole
inheritance hierarchy can go as deep as
you want it to be and that's the basic
idea and basic conceptualization of how
you understand and how you visualize
inheritance
now let's move to eclipse ide and try to
understand this with the help of an
example so for this particular case i
have created a set of classes basically
which we will be using to demonstrate
the relationship of inheritance and i've
taken the simple example of a bicycle so
a bicycle is again a very generic
definition of any two wheeler and
bicycles can have multiple types there
can be an all-terrain bike there can be
a mountain bike
there can be a city bike there can be a
bike which is specific specifically made
for ladies and similarly there can be
multiple different types of bikes but
all of these bikes will have some
similar properties
for example all of them will have two
wheels all of them will have a seat all
of them will have brake all of them will
have some sort of some sort of a
speeding mechanism whether they can
accelerate or deaccelerate so there will
be some commonality but at the same time
a mountain bike's features might be very
different from a city bike feature a
mountain bike features might feature
mountain bike might have gears for
example whereas a city bike might not
have gears because you don't need that
much of a variation in in inclination
and declination when you drive down the
road so i'm trying to conceptualize the
same example here where i've created a
class called bicycle and this is my base
class i define two properties in the in
the bicycle class which is
gear and speed we will come back to
protected in a while but
let's let's leave that there so i have
two properties which is gear and speed i
have a constructor where i'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear and then
i have three methods here which says set
gear apply brake and speed up when i
apply brake the speed is going to get
reduced so that's why you see minus
equal to unary operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase that's why
i'm using the plus equal to unary
operator so when you use the method
speed up the speed is going to be
increased by the value you supply in the
method similarly when you apply the
brake the speed is going to get reduced
by the amount you supply in the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle gear speed and three methods now
let's have a look at the child class
so the way you will define the
inheritance relationship in java is by
using this extends keyword remember i
told you to remember the extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual and then you
will use extends keyword and then you
will use the parent class name or the
base class name so here i am saying
class mountain bike extends bicycle and
here i am providing an additional
property remember the whole commonality
versus differentiality equation so a
mountain bike might have an extra
property to adjust the seat height so
that's the extra property which mountain
bike is having
and then
since this mountain bike is extending
the bicycle class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility to initialize the bicycle
class as well and the way it will
fulfill that responsibility is by taking
all the arguments of bicycle class plus
the mountain bike class in its
constructor and that's why you see three
different properties here you see the
start height property which is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class but this class is inheriting those
properties from the base class remember
the keyword inheritance here and then
once you do that how do you initialize
the base class constructor is by calling
the super method this is again a keyword
in java and you will use this super
keyword to
refer to the base class constructor in
this way so what you will do technically
is that you will write super and you
will supply the arguments which is
required by the base class constructor
if i go back the base class constructor
requires two arguments start speed and
start gear
so i write super and then i write start
speed and start gear so whatever i got
from here in the constructor of mountain
bike i'm supplying those values as is to
super and java will automatically take
care of invoking this particular
constructor the moment it
it encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super keyword or super statement has
to be the first statement inside your
constructor remember that whenever you
are dealing with inheritance and
whenever you have to initialize the
super class constructor or the base
class constructor use the super
constructor invocation as the very first
statement inside your child class
constructor otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable i should
call this as this remember i we
discussed about this in this in the
classes session okay and then it just
has a method of set height so there's no
extra method which this mountain bike is
providing but this mountain bike will
have access to all the methods which
have been provided here and all the
properties which have been provided here
this mountain bike can access everything
from the bicycle class and that's the
whole idea of inheritance that the child
class can access the properties of the
base class by extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class so for that i have a
simple class name as inheritance demo
which has a public static point main
method and then i am initializing the
mountain bike class
i'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to
start speed
and
one here goes to gear or the start gear
and that's how i'm setting the values so
when i call this particular constructor
here the mountain bike constructor is
going to this mountain bike constructor
is going to get called and which in turn
is going to call the base class bicycle
class constructor as well and everything
will be set accordingly and then let's
try to access the gear property remember
gear is not directly available in the
mountain bike class but i'm still able
to do mountain bike dot gear because
child class can access the parents class
properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well and seat height is the local
property of this particular class
mountain bike so it will anyways be
accessible so i can access all the
properties of the base class and the
child class itself seamlessly without
any differentiation now let's try to
call a method so here i'm calling the
method apply break remember apply break
was defined in the base class not in the
child class it's defined here so i'm
calling the apply break method and i
want to reduce the speed the current
speed by one and then i'm printing the
current speed saying that bike speed
after applying brake is mountain bike
dot speed so let's run this particular
program and observe the outputs
okay so the the first statement which
gets printed is at line number seven
which says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height is mountain bike dot
seat height which is 20 which is the
first argument here and then the bike
speed is 10 which is coming as here and
getting printed here and then when i
apply the brake let's go back to the
apply brake method the logic is that
whatever is the current speed reduce it
by the value i supply in the method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if i
supply 5 here the current speed will be
10 minus 5 equal to 5 let's assert that
particular assumption as well yes we can
see that and similarly you can access
other methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break is accessible set
gear set height speed up all the methods
which are defined in the base class are
accessible in the child class as well
this is the power of inheritance one
more thing which i said i will come back
to is around the usage of protected
access modifier
remember when we discussed about the
access modifiers in the previous session
i said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance that
whenever you define something as
protected it will be available to be
accessible in the child classes of the
base class so if i define this
particular variable as as protected then
this particular property will be
accessible in the child class mountain
bike as well
let's play around this let's make this
as private and see what happens so if i
make this private now when i say private
the scope of this particular variable is
within the class only and nobody outside
the class will be able to see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo class because now
mountain bike object cannot access the
gear property because the gear property
is defined in the base class and now it
is private that's why the child class
now mountain bike class cannot access
the property gear
and the moment you make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected access modifiers it is always
always recommended to use them when you
when you write any kind of inheritance
logic and inheritance logic as well
intentionally if you want to hide a
particular
property from the child classes just
make it private and that's all i want to
cover in this particular session where
we uh dive deep into the concept of
inheritance we had a look at an example
using the bicycle and mountain bike kind
of construct and you can apply the same
kind of construct on any kind of other
other kind of business requirement
remember the is a relationship
so that's all i want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another very interesting concept of java
which is about encapsulation let's get
started with encapsulation so again
let's understand what is encapsulation
in general and then we will apply that
concept to java encapsulation if you try
to break that word if i just write it
here in the form of a comment
it's n
capsulation just trying to break this
word into to make it more visual so you
see you see a word called capsule here
so if you try to imagine a capsule why
do you create that and what's the
concept of a capsule capsule tries to
pack lot of things inside a small
tube-like shape and the concept of
encapsulation is sort of inspired from
that not exactly not literally but
that's the basic idea of of this root
word which is called encapsulation so
encapsulation basically means to
restrict
accessing the properties of a class to
the outside world if you want to protect
the properties of your class how do you
do that you do that with the help of the
concept called encapsulation so here you
this is a sort of a security feature you
can think of a think of it as a security
feature that you want to protect the
properties of your class
and you will use encapsulation to
protect the properties how you implement
encapsulation let's have a look at that
now so basic idea is to encapsulate the
objects create sort of a capsule around
the object which can provide that
protection layer and you will define how
the outside world is going to access the
properties of the class if needed so
i've created a simple class here
and
it's if you if you remember one of the
previous examples when we discussed
about classes i used the same class
which was the student class and i'm just
using the same class for continuity so
i've created a student class here and i
have created three different properties
of this particular class which is name
name of the student age of the student
and address of the student you see
intentionally i have used the keyword
private
in front of these three properties and
that is the first thing which you need
to do to implement encapsulation on your
object that you hide all the properties
from the outside world remember the
moment you make anything is private only
the class which is the student class
itself only the class itself can see
these variables or these properties
nothing outside the student class will
be able to
access the name or age or the address
directly from the student class it's not
possible that's the whole idea of making
it private because you don't want the
outside world to access these properties
so you make those properties as private
then you create a constructor the
constructor has to be public so that
anybody can initialize the student
object because you want your object to
be accessible remember so you want the
objects to be accessible but you want
the restriction on the access of the
properties of the object
and these are the properties of the
object
so you have restricted them by making it
private but that doesn't solve the
problem because there will be some
illegitimate consumers of the student
object which should not have access to
the student properties
but there will also be some legitimate
consumers of the student object which
should be having access to the
properties of the student for example
the payroll
application will need access to these
particular
properties the examination application
will require access to these particular
properties so how do you do that
you create getters we call them getters
because they start with the keyword
get so you create a getter method for
each of the property you create the
method called as get name and this is
the naming convention with java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property in camel case
so you write get name and this property
is supposed to return the name property
of this particular object and you here
you say return name so you're returning
the the name which is being stored by
the current student object whenever
somebody calls student object dot get
name and this is the way you have
restricted the access of this particular
object as well so remember you made it
private so that nobody can access it and
then you defined your own way of
providing access to the
name property of this particular class
now if anybody wants to access the name
value of your student object there's
only one and one way to do that which is
via calling get name so you have
provided restrictions and you have also
provided prescriptive guidance on how
you are going to expose the properties
of your class that's the second
thing which you need to do to implement
correct form of encapsulation on your
object that that is to provide the
getter methods with the right visibility
you want to make them public so that
anybody can call them but since you are
governing which is what is written
inside the method you have full control
on what kind of exposure you want to
give for this particular property
similarly you create a getter for age
calling getage which returns the age and
then you call get you write get address
and return the address here it is simply
returning it but if you want to do more
stuff here feel free to do that like i
said you govern the control of how do
you want to return the name maybe you
don't want to return the complete name
and you want to just return the initials
then you can split the string trim the
string and return only the initials so
that's the basic idea of getters now
after you have created the object there
might be use cases where somebody needs
to overwrite the values of the
properties like name age or address
whatever student's name was incorrectly
mentioned when they called the
constructor and now they want to
overwrite the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name with a new
name
so in that case you need to provide what
we call as setters and they start with
set that's why we call them setters and
we follow the same kind of logic that
you provide the setters for all the
properties of your class so you had
three properties which were name age and
address and you provided the setters for
all three of them and how do you provide
that you write you again make them as
public because you want the outside
world to access this setter method to
overwrite the values of the name this
method is not going to return anything
so it is going to be void then you write
the name of the method which starts with
set and then the property name in camel
case and then you provide the new value
which is the value which should be which
should be the new value and this is the
value which should replace the existing
value so whatever new value you want to
supply you supply that as the argument
of the setter methods for set name for
set age or for set address and then you
write this particular line
which says
set the current name property of this
particular object with the name which is
coming in from the argument so this dot
name remember this dot name represents
the current objects property because
this represents the current object so
whatever is the current object property
value of the name is just override that
value with the argument coming in do the
same thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the in the set address method so this is
how you are going to provide the setters
and the getters
so setters and getters can also be
generated in smart id is like eclipse so
you just right click you go to source
and here you will see the option of
generate getters and setters if you
click on this it will give you the list
of the fields which are available to be
had to be having getters and setters
currently it says no fields or all
fields have getters and setters already
yes because they have it let me just
comment this and show this how this work
so for example let me comment all the
getters and setters
so i'm commenting them and if i right
click source
generate getters and setters i get all
the fields available for which setters
and getters can be generated so you can
select them and leave everything as
default hit generate and it is
automatically going to generate the
getters and the setter you see all the
code of the getter and setter is
automatically generated you do not even
need to write it and this is the power
of the smart ideas let me just uh revert
what i did
so you created everything as all the
properties as private and then you
define how you want to replace the
values by providing the setters and you
define how you want the outside world to
access your properties so you have full
control of the class now you you control
the visibility you control how they are
going to get initialized you are you are
controlling how the properties are going
to be overwritten or set and you control
how the properties are going to be
returned so you have complete control of
the class so you have created a perfect
capsule here a perfect form of
encapsulation in this class and this is
how you can implement encapsulation and
that's all i'm going to cover for this
particular session in the next session
we are going to discuss about
abstraction let's get started with
abstraction let's first understand the
definition of abstraction before we
relate this to java abstraction
generally means hiding something when
you want to hide some details of of a
particular object from the outside world
you apply the concept of abstraction for
example when you drive a particular car
you just hit the accelerator and the car
speeds up now it's not only one action
when you hit the accelerator the whole
machinery of the car and all the
components different parts of the car
work together to speed up they would be
engine there would be propulsion there
would be fuel there would be there might
be some if it's an electric car there
would batteries uh there would be whole
different kinds of pistons and plugs
which will make the car speed up it's
not only a single component it's a lot
of different components under the hood
and that's the concept of abstraction
that we only show the relevant parts to
the user and we hide all the internal
details from the user that's the basic
idea of abstraction so a car
manufacturer
abstracts away all the inner technical
details from the driver and just gives
the driver a single pedal to speed up
the car for a user it's a very good
experience because he doesn't need to
know about all the internals of the car
but the car manufacturer can hide all
the details and provide a very simple
interface for the driver to interact
with which is just a gas pedal and
that's the basic idea of abstraction and
we try to apply the same kind of concept
to java in the form of abstraction and
java provides this kind of concept
implementation with the help of a
keyword which is called abstract now
abstract is a keyword which can be used
in front of a class or a method when you
use it in front of a class the whole
class becomes abstract abstract class is
a type of class so the class itself
becomes an abstract class one of the
things to remember is that abstract
class cannot be instantiated but can be
subclassed remember we talked about the
concept of subclass and the parent class
when we talked about inheritance so if
you make a class as abstract class you
cannot call the constructor of the class
because you cannot instantiate it but
you can extend the abstract class and
create a child class class out of it
that's the concept of abstract class
another concept is abstract method you
can also use the abstract keyword in
front of a method and when you use
abstract keyword in front of a method
then that method is only declared
without an implementation you are not
going to provide any implementation of
the method and you're just going to
declare the method something like this
we will see a similar example in the in
the hands-on as well but that's the
basic idea that you just declare the
method you are not providing an
implementation as to what does move to
method actually does because that's the
whole concept of abstraction and it is
the responsibility of the child classes
which inherit the particular class in
which the abstract method would be
sitting so that child class will be
having the responsibility to provide a
concrete implementation of the declared
method let's understand this better with
the help of an example so here i have
created a class called graphic object
and i have made the class as abstract
class this is the keyword which you need
to use in front before the class keyword
and the task becomes an abstract class
now when you create an abstract class it
automatically gets some properties the
first property is that this particular
class must have at least one abstract
method and this is how you define the
abstract methods where you just provide
the declaration but you do not provide
the implementation of the draw method or
the resize method and the way you will
create the abstract methods is by using
the abstract keyword before
the actual method declaration starts so
general method declaration would look
like this and if you use abstract in
front of it this becomes an abstract
method declaration abstract class can
also have concrete methods so that is
the liberty which abstract class gives
you that you can have abstract methods
which are just declared but you can also
have normal methods which are which
where you can also provide the
implementation so you can have normal
methods and abstract methods as well in
an abstract class
so this is the abstract class now if if
you want to provide an implementation of
the draw and resize method you have to
extend this abstract class so we extend
this abstract class by creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is circle.java
where you can see i create a normal
class and i use the extends keyword for
inheritance and i'm saying that circle
class is inheriting from the graphic
object class which was my abstract class
and once i use this extends keyword then
i have the responsibility of providing
the implementation of the abstract
methods actually java will force me to
provide the implementation of these two
methods if i do not provide all the
declared methods so there are two
declared methods here so if the circuit
class does not provide that the
implementation for both draw and resize
methods then java will throw an error
and it will ask you to take an action
which can be either define all the
methods meaning provide implementation
for all the methods or make the circle
class itself as abstract let's see if i
just comment this particular out i get
an error you see a red line here and if
you click on this particular balloon
here it will say either you can add the
unimplemented methods or you can make
the circle type as abstract these are
the two options which you will get to
fix this particular error so an abstract
class can be extended by another
abstract class if the child abstract
class is not implementing all the
methods of the parent if you want to
implement all the methods then just
implement them and keep at keep it as a
normal class and that's what i've done
here i've just created a normal class
here and provided the implementation and
once you provide the implementation of
both of the methods the error is gone
similarly i have also provided another
child class because it's uh there can be
there can be multiple children of a
particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object and it
also provides its own implementation of
drawing and resize because generally the
way you will draw a rectangle and you
resize a rectangle will be different
than drawing or resizing a circle here
i'm not doing anything in the methods
because this is just to show you the
demonstration i'm just printing a cis
out saying drawing a circle and resizing
or drawing a rectangle and resizing a
rectangle and in the circle class
drawing a circle and resizing a circle
so one abstract class is the parent
class which is the graphic object and
two children circle and rectangle both
providing the implementation of the
abstract methods which were declared in
the base class now let's go to the main
class where i've defined defined the
public static void main method and here
you see i have created two different
kind of blocks of code here one block is
where i'm saying graphic object creating
a reference of the graphic object named
as circle and initializing the circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class and here is
the concrete class so whatever you
define on the right hand side whatever
is the type of object will be the type
of methods being called so if you
created a circle object and then if you
call the draw method and resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class if you initialized it as
new rectangle then you are creating a
rectangle class object and then the draw
and the resize method will be called
from the rectangle class that's the
basic construct and that's how you will
initialize
a a particular class which is using an
abstract class so i i call a graphic
object circle new circle and i call
circle.draw and circle dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle and rectangle.draw
rectangle dot resize let's run this
program and observe the output so when i
call this particular block of code
circle object gets initialized and then
circle.draw method prints drawing a
circle and circle.resize method prints
drawing resizing a circle similarly when
i create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class rectangle.draw prints this
particular line drawing a rectangle and
rectangle.resize prints this particular
line which is resizing a rectangle and
this is how you will use the concept of
abstraction there's another very
interesting thing which which is which
is going on here remember i told if i do
this and i i create i just put a system
out here
base
abstract class so if i do this here if i
create if i still write a constructor
though java says that it cannot be
instantiated if i still write a
constructor of it and i do not do any
changes here and if i run this
particular program let's see what
happens you'll see the base abstract
class being called here let me just
reformat it by putting ln here so that
we get a better output so if i run this
particular program you see base abstract
class is getting printed somehow though
we said that abstract classes cannot be
instantiated but still the constructor
of this is still getting called somehow
when i create a circle class the base
class constructor gets called and when i
create a rectangle class again the base
class constructor gets called this is
this is the power of inheritance because
in inheritance remember how it works
when you call when you initialize a
particular child object referencing it
with the parent object see the
references of the parent class and the
object is of the child class so whenever
you do it like this
first the default constructor because
i'm calling the default constructor here
the default constructor of the circle
class will get called which will go here
remember i told you that java provides
the default constructor automatically if
you don't provide it so the default
constructor of circle gets called but
java sees that you are writing this code
here which says circle extends graphic
object so java is automatically going to
call the parent class and going to
initialize the parent class as well
because that's how it will be able to
see these methods and so so that's why
it will automatically call the base
class constructor even if you don't call
it explicitly in fact you cannot call it
explicitly java will not allow you to
initialize the graphic object class
explicitly it can only and only be
called by java itself indirectly via the
concept of inheritance if you try to do
this let's try to do this for fun and
also for better understanding so if i
write graphic object
go equal to
new graphic object you see i don't even
get an option but let's write it and
let's see what happens so you see that
this particular it gives basically an
error because it's not able to find the
constructor of the graphic object class
though even i have defined the default
constructor here but still java is not
able to find it because this class is
abstract so hence proved abstract
classes cannot be instantiated
explicitly they can only be instantiated
by the child classes through the
internal mechanisms of java itself and
that's all i want to talk about in this
particular session where we looked in
detail about the concept of abstraction
couple of more things which i did not
cover in the previous session i just
want to call them out for clarity java
does not support multiple inheritance
when i say multiple inheritance what it
means that you will not have a scenario
where a child will be extending from two
base classes java does not support it it
does support it with the with the help
of interfaces but i will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions but
here just understand this that you
cannot use multiple inheritance with
classes in java a child cannot have two
parent or two base classes in java java
will not allow that it is also called
the diamond problem because the child
class
does not know whether to follow the
route of base 1 plus or the base 2 class
if it is extending from 2 different base
1 and base 2 classes so a class can only
extend from one class in java we can
find a workaround of it by using the
concept of interfaces but that's
something which will be coming later
another thing to understand is that when
you create an abstract class here these
variables you can declare declare these
variables as well and these variables
will be accessible by all the child
classes as you access them so that's all
for this particular session and in the
next session we are going to talk about
interfaces let's get started with
interfaces in java now again let's
understand what do we mean by an
interface in general and then we will
see how do we apply the concept of
interfaces in java so imagine let's
let's take the same example of vehicle
industry because that's something which
we see every day around ourselves and we
can relate to it so imagine if all the
car manufacturers were creating a
different way of driving a car what if
in one car you have a steering but in
other car you do not have a steering but
you have something else which is which
may be called something else in one car
you have the gas pedal to speed up in
other car you have a button to speed up
similarly in in one car you may have
different kind of doors and in other
cars you may have different kind of
doors which are completely different
looking it's not even a single simple
handle to open it so you see the problem
here the problem here is that all the
car manufacturers are not working on a
single contract they are not respecting
a single interface which will create a
poor user experience because the users
whenever the users have to buy a new car
or they have to switch from one
manufacturer to other manufacturer they
are completely clueless as to how to
drive that particular class because the
interface they were using in the
previous car is completely different
from the interface they are being shown
in the other car and that's that's the
basic need for the concept of interface
think of it as an contract agreement you
see it is also mentioned here that
if you apply the same kind of concept to
programming world imagine if every
programmer was writing their own logic
in their own way without following a
single contract or a single guideline
soon it is going to create a problem and
that's the kind of problem
interfaces try to solve so interface is
again a keyword in java and the basic
idea or the basic construct is that the
interfaces are going to define the
specifications
of how a class would act let me repeat
this in a more generic way interfaces
are going to define the contract or the
specification which is going to govern
how an application or code or
programming logic will behave that's the
basic idea of interfaces
so interfaces are their own type and the
basic property of interface is that it
can only contain
constants method declarations similar to
abstract classes and some default
methods or static methods or nested
types what is nested type we will cover
that later default methods will touch
upon a bit here and the static methods
as well but the basic idea is that when
you create when you create an interface
in java you cannot write anything
concrete in terms of the behavior of the
interface when i say behavior always
think of that as method so you cannot
define a concrete method in an interface
you can only declare methods you can
also declare constants you can create a
particular type of concrete method by
using the default keyword but use it in
very special circumstances you can also
create static methods as well which are
only going to belong to the interface
and nobody else now let's look at an
example
and and also before we go to the example
let me also phrase this here that if an
interface cannot define a concrete
implementation of the methods then
naturally the interface is going to be
extended by a child class a concrete
class which is going to provide the
implementation of the methods declared
in the interface it does sound like
abstract classes but there is a
difference let's understand the
difference with the help of an example
this is how an interface will look like
i've used the same construct of bicycle
and mountain bike just to maintain some
continuity and less context switching
but this is how an interface would look
like you will not use the class keyword
but instead you instead of that you will
use the interface keyword you can only
declare methods you cannot define
methods remember when we looked at the
abstract classes example we were able to
define concrete methods as well but in
interface that's a strict no no you
cannot define concrete methods let me
show you the abstract class in the case
of abstraction which we used this was
the abstract class and it did have a
concrete method right but bicycle.java
here which is because it's an interface
it is not going to allow you to create a
concrete method another thing is that if
you try to declare a variable inside the
class they will have to be constant you
cannot just declare them without any
value for example i cannot do this
if i do this it is going to give an
error you see an error here and it says
initialize field x at declaration
something like this public static final
so interface is going to force you to
declare all the variables as public
static final with some value if you try
to use them inside interface
so that is also something which
interface will mandate so you see
interfaces are more strict they are more
strict in terms of what you can do you
can only declare public static final
variables and you can only declare
methods you cannot define methods so
abstract class is less restrictive
interface is more restrictive and that
is the differentiation which you have to
keep in mind whether to use abstract
classes or whether to use interfaces
that is also a very common confusing
question in the interviews as well and
remember that interfaces are only for
contracts or specifications where in
case of abstract class you can write a
concrete behavior as well in terms of a
concrete method in the base class
interfaces there's no concrete
implementation in the base class
abstract classes yes there can be a
concrete implementation in the base
class that's the basic difference moving
on i have created a child class here
which is again mountain bike and it has
three properties seat height gear and
speed similar to the previous example it
has a constructor and remember in again
interfaces cannot be uh initialized
directly so you don't even need to call
a super method here because there is
nothing to initialize you initialize a
class to create a state state is denoted
by the properties but interfaces will
force you to write a public static final
property and initialize its value
automatically so you do not need a
constructor for the interface because
there is nothing to initialize
everything has been initialized in terms
of the variables and the methods are
anywhere just declared that's why you
don't need to call super here after that
the moment you write this particular
keyword here implements and that is how
you will basically extend from the from
the interface you will use the
implements
bicycle keyword here implements is the
keyword and bicycle is the name of the
interface if you write this here then
java is going to force you to provide
the implementation of these two methods
if i
if i do this implements bicycle and if i
comment out these two methods which is
coming from the base class it is going
to give an error and if i read out this
error it says either you add the
unimplemented methods or you make the
mountain bike class as abstract there
are two ways to fix this particular
class similar to abstract classes it
will force you to write the
implementation of the base class
declared methods another thing which
java will will suggest you and will will
also force you via some ides as well is
that you use this particular annotation
we use this particular annotation to
tell java that we are overriding this
method from the base class since apply
break and speed up methods were defined
here in the base class and this child
class is supposed to provide the
implementation of the methods by
overriding them overriding is again a
concept which we will talk about in
detail in the coming sessions but for
now remember that you need to write this
annotation here on the methods which
have been taken from the base class to
provide an implementation and the
implementation is similar to what we
have seen before so whatever value you
supply in the apply break the speed is
going to get decremented by that
particular value and in case of speed up
whatever value you supply in the
argument that value is going to be added
to the current speed and the speed is
going to go up
let's look at the main class here which
is called interface demo it has a public
static void main method and here i'm
again initializing the child class
nothing's nothing strange here and then
i'm using the getter method here because
i have made everything as private here
and rest of the things are just here as
is i have the getters and setters here
for all the properties and i'm using
those here so i'm using the getters to
just get the value of gear seat height
and speed and then i'm applying the
brake and then i'm printing the current
speed after applying the brakes let me
just
expand this a bit more and then i'm
using the speed up method trying to
increase the current speed of the bike
by 10 and then printing the new speed
again so using the apply break and speed
up methods which are concretely defined
in the child class by using this
override annotation and these were the
methods which were declared in the
interface in the base interface and
that's all it which is happening in this
particular class let's run this
particular program
and these are the values i get i get the
gear as one which is coming from here i
get the seat height as 20 which is
coming from here i get the current bike
speed as 10 this was the value which it
was initialized with then i'm applying
the brake and after applying the brake
the speed of the bike gets reduced and
it becomes 10 minus 1 which becomes
9 and that's what gets printed here and
then i'm speeding up the bike by 10 so
the current value of the current value
of the speed of the bike is 9 and if i
incremented it by 10 it becomes 19 and
that's what gets printed here
and that's all i want to cover in this
particular session where we had a look
at an example of how we can use
interfaces in java and how we can use
interfaces with the concept of
inheritance and in the next session we
are going to have a look at the concept
of multiple inheritance using interfaces
let's get started with multiple
inheritance in java using interfaces if
you remember in the previous sessions i
said that multiple inheritance is not
possible in java and it is not possible
because of the diamond problem or simply
put of one child cannot have two parent
classes that's what java says and let's
understand why this is a problem so i
have created a very simplistic diagram
to to demonstrate the problem of
multiple inheritance and then we will
see how we can solve that so let's say
you have a class c a normal class then
you created two parents of class c so
basically class c is extending class a
and you also want the class c to extend
class b first of all it is not possible
in java and why it is not possible is
because of there can be a super class
which is
extending class a and class b as well so
you started with class c you wanted to
have you wanted class c to have two
parents which is a and b but a and b
also had a common parent which is super
class so now as you know that the child
classes can see the properties of the
base classes as well then if class c
wants to access something from super
class which route should it take should
it take this route or should it take
this route that is the problem which we
called as the diamond problem and that
is the reason why java prohibits using
multiple inheritance using classes so
that's the problem statement
that we don't have a clear route to
reach to the super class from class c
and we try to solve it using interfaces
so let's jump right into the eclipse ide
to understand how we can solve it so
here i have prepared an example for this
particular problem and the solution of
it so again i'm using the same bicycle
and mountain bike example for the sake
of continuity i have created an
interface of bicycle which has two
declarations which is for applying break
and speed up this is my simple interface
and then i have a mountain bike class
which is implementing the bicycle
interface and providing the
implementation of apply break and speed
up this is something which we have
already seen in the previous example so
nothing new here and then you have other
getters and setters and you have a main
class where you can initialize the
mountain bike and get the gear get the
seat height get the speed we have
covered all of this there's nothing new
here but now let's say you have a
requirement that you have another
interface
which is called vehicle and your
mountain bike should extend or implement
this interface as well is that possible
let's try that remember mountain bike
was already implementing bicycle
interface what if you want to have two
parents of this mountain bike using
interfaces like i said previously that
interfaces does solve the problem of
multiple inheritance so let's see if it
does solve that problem so i can just
say vehicle here and see if the code
compiles the code doesn't compile here
and the reason is pretty expected it's
because vehicle has a declared method
which is called can drive and mountain
bike now needs to provide the
implementation of that particular method
so if you click on this balloon and hit
on add unimplemented methods just double
click on that and you will get an empty
method definition of that can drive
method and let's put assist out for
simplicity and say
mountain bike
can
be
driven so this is how you can see this
this code is working fine and now this
particular child class has two parents
it has a bicycle parent and it also has
a vehicle parent so if bicycle and
vehicle would have been concrete classes
then this would have caused an error let
me quickly show you that if i can so let
me go to bicycle and i just change this
to class and i
put an empty definition for both of the
methods and then let's go to the vehicle
class and convert interface and convert
that into class as well and again
provide an empty implementation so i've
just converted the vehicle interface and
the bicycle interface into classes and
now if i go back to the mountain bike
and if i change this to extends
i get a whole lot of errors
if i go here
it says multiple markers and it doesn't
give you the right error but the right
error is happening because you cannot
extend from two concrete classes now
bicycle and vehicle are both classes and
mountain bike cannot do that because
java does not support multiple
inheritance from classes but if you go
back to the previous state if i just
quickly do control z here and control z
here in case of vehicle as well
converting both of them back to
interfaces and putting the implements
back here everything goes fine so using
interfaces you can implement multiple
uh inheritance but using classes you
cannot do that let's cover one more
interesting scenario what if you have a
need to extend from let's say one
interface and one more class is that
possible because we saw the comp we saw
the combination of two classes that was
not possible we are seeing the
combination of two interfaces
which is possible now is it possible to
extend from a base class and implement
an interface let's see what happens if
you try to do that and i have another
class this is not an interface but this
is a class called two wheeler so
technically speaking mountain bike is a
two wheeler and at the same time
mountain bike is also a vehicle and
mountain bike is also a bicycle so what
if you have a requirement that your
mountain bike should also extend from
two wheeler class can you do that let's
see if i can do that i will just write
extends
two wheeler and let's see if that works
it doesn't work here
but let's put it here if i put it here
does it work now yes it works there's no
compilation error here which means java
does accept this particular construct so
what happened here first thing when i
put this extends tooler after implements
java did not allow which means that the
extends keyword has to come right after
the child class it cannot come after the
implements clause it has to come right
after the child class that's first thing
second thing is a normal class a normal
child class
can extend from one concrete class
and can also implement any number of
interfaces you see i have two interfaces
so now technically this mountain bike
has three parents it has a concrete
class two wheeler as the parent it has
bicycle interface as the parent and it
also has vehicle interface as the parent
so three parents so this con this
basically uh justifies the philosophy or
justifies the concept that a class can
extend from only and only one base class
but can implement any number of
interfaces you can have more interfaces
here as many as you want so
number of interfaces is not a
restriction but number of concrete
classes is a restriction a child class
will have only one concrete based class
but can have any number of interfaces
being implemented from this particular
class that's the basic property and then
the main in the main method
you can access any of the vehicle or two
wheeler or bicycle interfaces methods
and the classes methods as well if you
want to so for example if i want to
just type this and if i just do dot here
i can see i can access can drive as well
now can drive
was implemented in the vehicle interface
or declared in the vehicle interface
similarly if i look for the two wheeler
method can i see the two wheeler method
as well let's see if i can yes and this
you can see this is the two wheeler
class method which says can rotate two
wheels so i can call this particular
method which is coming from the two
wheeler class i can call the vehicle
class declared method which was can
drive so this is also possible and this
is possible because mountain bike is
implementing the interface of vehicle so
let's run this particular program and
understand the output
so at first i initialize the mountain
bike class and i print the gear the seat
height and the bike speed values we have
already seen this
then i apply the brake and i speed up so
after applying the brake the speed
becomes 10 minus 1 9 and after speeding
up the new speed becomes 9 plus 10 as
19. then i call mountain bike dot can
rotate two wheelers two wheels which is
going to invoke the method which is
defined in the two wheeler class which
is printing a simple sis out so i get
the same sysout here this method is
being invoked from the mountain bike
object due to the concept of inheritance
similarly when i say mountain bike dot
can drive the scan drive was declared in
the interface vehicle and then when
mountain bike implemented this interface
java forced it to provide a a definition
of this particular method and this is
the definition which is again assist out
and you can see that's just out being
printed here so this is how you can
implement multiple inheritance in java
using the power of interfaces and you
can also combine the classes and the
interfaces the condition is that only
one class should be the parent class and
then you can have any number of
interfaces as the parent entity if you
want to and that's all i want to cover
in this particular session
in the next session we are going to
discuss about method overloading
concepts in java let's get started with
polymorphism so polymorphism is a very
generic concept which means that a
particular object can take multiple form
let's not even call it as object let's
make it more generic a particular entity
can take multiple forms if any entity in
java exhibits that kind of behavior then
we say that polymorphism is in action
that entity can be a class or an object
or even a method and in today's session
we are going to talk about that type of
polymorphism
which is exhibited by methods so we will
see how a particular method in java can
take many different forms containing
different logics but still having the
same name
and that concept is called method
overloading so whenever you hear the
word that you need to overload a
particular method or this is method
overloading happening technically or
conceptually it's basically polymorphism
in action and polymorphism is being
applied on a method here and that
phenomena we call as method overloading
so in today's session we are going to
have a look at how we can implement
method overloading in java so the basic
idea of method overloading is that the
name of the method should remain the
same so you see in this particular class
which i have created to demonstrate the
method overloading so this is the class
name and the method name which i am
going to overload is called multiply and
that is probably the first thing which
you need to remember to implement over
method overloading correctly that the
method name is going to remain the same
the type of the return of the method may
change here you see it's returning int
here in the first instance in the second
instance also it is returning int but in
the third instance it is returning
double so the return type of an
overloaded method can change another
another thing which which can be varied
between same method being defined again
and again is that the number of
arguments and the type of arguments the
first multiply method takes two
arguments of integer type the second
multiply method takes three arguments of
integer type and the third multiply
method takes two arguments of double
type so by using method overloading you
can vary the number of arguments and
also the type of arguments so the basic
idea is that you declare you define the
method using the same name but you do a
variation in the arguments or the return
types and that's how you technically
implement method overloading in this
case in this particular case the
multiply is the method being overloaded
and in the first case it is accepting
two integer arguments and returning the
result of multiplication of those
arguments in the second case the same
method name multiply here the same
visibility public and the same return
type but this time three different types
of integer values can be accepted and
this method multiply method is going to
return the multiplication of three
integer numbers in the third case at
line 15 i again use the same multiply
name the method name but this time the
return type becomes double and this
method accepts two double arguments and
returns the result of the multiplication
of these double values so the method
name is same but the arguments vary and
also the return type may also vary
that's the basic premise of how you
implement method overloading so whenever
you want to implement it keep the method
name same vary the
arguments and the return types and after
that i'm just created a public static
void main method here i have initialized
the class here this particular class
itself method overloading demo and then
i am calling the multiply method on the
object and based on the number of
arguments i supply the corresponding
method will get invoked that is
something with java will take care
automatically that whatever type and the
number of arguments you supply in the
call in the invocation based on the
number and the type of the arguments
java will try to find a matching method
in the overloaded methods if it is able
to find a method it's going to get
invoked if it is not able to find the
method you will get an error in fact you
will get a compile error itself while
you invoke a method which for which the
definition is not available for example
if i try to just copy this
and make an invalid invalid method
invocation let's provide four arguments
and if i do that here itself i will get
the error because java is not able to
find a multiply method in this
particular class which is accepting four
integer arguments so you will get the
compilation error itself before you can
even run the program but the basic idea
is that you use overloading with
multiple different types and the number
of variables so i'm calling multiply
three times let's run this particular
program and observe the output so let me
just bring this output down yep so first
i call demo.multiply and pass two
integer values 10 and 20. when this
happens this particular method gets
invoked and it is it returns a result of
10 into 20 which is 200. in the second
invocation i'm calling again the
multiply method but this time with three
arguments three integer arguments
specifically and this call is going to
match this particular method signature
and it is going to execute whatever is
written inside this particular method
which is the multiplication of the three
arguments being supplied so 10 into 20
into 30 which is 6 000 the third case
let's go back here at line 25 the third
case of invocation of the multiply
method is accepting two decimal based
arguments 10.5 and 20.5 so java is going
to look at the class and trying to find
a method which can accept decibel values
and there it is this is the method
signature which is going to match the
invocation java is going to do this
matching automatically for you and here
whatever logic you have written inside
this particular method we will get
executed so 10.5 into 20.5 returns
215.25
and that's the output you get so this is
how you can use method overloading in
java this is a rather fairly simple
example but you can make it as complex
as you want but a word of caution do not
use it too extensively in fact lot of
expert programmers do not recommend
using method overloading because it
becomes very confusing use it only when
you do not have any other way out use it
only where this is the only way to write
correct form of methods with the right
readability otherwise generally there
would be other ways to avoid method
overloading by writing concrete purpose
friendly method names themselves maybe
you don't need to use the multiply name
again again we can call it as multiply
two numbers multiply three numbers
multiply doubles so that the method name
itself is more explicit and
understandable rather than juggling
around different signatures of the same
method especially it becomes more
confusing if you are creating an
interface which is to be consumed by a
third party developers or third party
application so try to use it with
caution that's what i'm trying to stress
here and that's all i want to cover in
this particular session and in the next
session we are going to talk about
method overriding let's get started with
method overriding in java so in the
previous session we discussed about
method overloading concept now in this
session we'll focus on another
interesting concept by which you can
have the same signature of the method
again and again be used in your code but
in a different way and this concept is
called method overriding method
overriding basically
is used together with the concept of
inheritance you won't you will not be
able to use the concept of method
overriding without using the concept of
inheritance remember when we talked
about inheritance i spoke about the
subclass and the parent class concept
sometimes we also call the parent class
as super class so the basic idea is that
if a super class defines a method
remember i'm using the word define here
if the super class uses the
defines a particular method and then the
subclass again tries to define the
method with the exact same signature
this phenomena is called method
overriding now when you do method method
overriding there are some rules to
follow and i'm showing you a tabular
structure here a table basically which
will show you what is possible and what
is not possible when it comes to method
overriding so let's try to understand
this table so if you try to define a
method with the same signature as a
superclass method the rules follow as
per this table let's go with the first
one if you have an instance method
defined in the super class instance
method is the normal method which you
define in your in your classes so if you
have defined an instance method in your
super class
and if you define a method in the
subclass with the exact same signature
then that concept is called method
overriding and it will be a successful
override override also let me also
explain what override means here
override means that once you try to
initialize the subclass object you will
be able to invoke its own overridden
method definition if you call that
particular method the subclasses own
instance method is going to get invoked
rather than the super classes instance
method we'll look at that when we look
at the example as well but that's the
normal scenario when where your
superclass defines an instance method
and subclass also defines the an
instance method with the exact same
method signature that concept is called
method overriding what if your
superclass defines a static method
static method is is basically a method
which belongs to the class but not to
the object instance method is called
instance method a normal method is
called instance method because it
belongs to the object you can call the
method on the object but static methods
are called by class so you say class
name dot static method name but when you
when you call instance methods you just
call object name dot instance method
name so that is the basic difference the
static methods belong to the class once
you have defined our static method the
same static method will be available to
all the objects of the class but
instance method are unique to each
object so that was a short tour of what
static methods mean so if you define a
static method in the super class and
then if you try to define an instance
method with the same signature in the
sub class you will get a compilation
error it will not be allowed it's not
allowed in java to override a static
method from super class that's what it
says next one if your super class has a
normal instance method and then the sub
class tries to use the same signature
but creates a static method out of it
then again you will get a compilation
error so that the overriding of an
instance method to a static method is
not allowed and the last concept is
again a very interesting concept and a
very popular interview question about
method hiding so if the super class
defines our static method and the
subclass also defines the static method
with the exact same signature then the
super static method gets hidden it
basically hides the superclass method so
that's the basic idea behind over method
overriding so if you see technically
it's a form of polymorphism because the
same method is having multiple
definitions but when we looked at the
previous example the multiple
definitions were in the same class here
the multiple definitions are in
different classes and those classes are
having a parent parent-child
relationship that was about the theory
of it let's go to an example of it to
understand it better and i've used again
the same construct of bicycle and
mountain bike which we have been using
in this in this series just to maintain
continuity so i have a parent class
called bicycle here which has two uh
properties gear and speed it has a
constructor nothing unusual there and
then it has defined three methods set
gear apply break and speed up set gear
is just setting the new value as the
gear value apply brake is going to
decrement the speed by the value you
supply and speed up is going to
increment the speed by the value you
supply simple this is exactly what we
have seen before now mountain bike tries
to extend bicycle so mountain bike
becomes a child class it defines a
variable called seat height defines a
constructor called super here nothing
unusual so far also defines a setter for
height
center for the seat height not exactly
following the center construct but this
is just to set the height but here
things just get interesting let me just
bring this down a bit yeah so here it is
overriding all the three methods of the
base class and by overriding it is
providing its own implementation of the
same methods let's compare them here
when it overrides the gear and whatever
value you supply it adds 2 to the plus 2
to that value and then sets that value
as the gear value but in case of base
class it was just setting the new value
as the gear value so for instance for
instance if you supplied one here the
gear value becomes one but here if you
supplied one the gear value becomes
three similarly when you apply brake on
the mountain bike class whatever value
you supply will be subtracted from the
current speed and 10 would be subtracted
even more so if the speed is let's say
50 and your decrement you supply the
decrement value as 10 so it will be 50
minus 10 minus 10 equal to 30 but in
case of bicycle if the speed was 50 and
you supply 10 then it would be just 50
minus 10 40. so there is
and there is extra 10 being subtracted
from the speed when you apply brake in
case of a mountain bike similarly for
speed up its increment of 10 in addition
to what's what value you supply so again
if the speed was 10 and you supplied 10
here in the argument so 10 plus 10 plus
10 30 will become the new speed in case
of mountain bike but in case of bicycle
if you supply 10 and if the current
speed was also 10 then it becomes 10
plus 10 only 20. so that's the
difference so the basic idea i hope you
get the basic idea here is that you
override the methods and your own class
provide its own implementation of those
methods that's the basic premise of
method overwriting all good so far and
you do not have a an
obligation to overwrite all of the
methods because here we have the
concrete implementation of the methods
so here in case of mountain bike you can
skip overriding one of the methods if
you like to this is also fine there will
be no compilation error because speed up
has a concrete implementation in the
bicycle class as well so it's up to you
how much you want to override
so let's move to the main class now
so in the main class we have created the
public static void main method here and
let's look at what is happening inside
the class first we initialize the
bicycle class
so bicycle class reference and bicycle
class object nothing unusual here we
supply the gear value and the speed
value then we print the gear and the
speed value we apply brake on the
bicycle and then we observe the new
speed of the bicycle after applying the
brakes let me comment out the rest of
the code and let's observe the output
for only this part of the code which we
just walked through for this section so
if i run this as a java application
and if i show you what i'm getting what
i'm getting here so bicycle gear is one
which is what you supplied in the
constructor bicycle speed is 10 which is
again what you supplied in the
constructor then you applied brake and
when you apply break this logic gets
executed and you supplied one here so
current speed was 10 so 10 minus 1
becomes 9 and the new speed becomes 9
which is what you are printing here so
far so good let's move on to the next
section let me comment out the previous
section now and let me uncomment this
section so here i have a bicycle
reference but the object is of mountain
bike remember this concept this is this
is called dynamic object binding concept
or dynamic binding concept again this
might be asked in your interviews so
here i am initializing the mountain bike
with the reference of bicycle remember
whatever is written on the right hand
side will govern the variables and the
methods usage we'll we'll we'll see how
that works out what i just said so i'm
supplying three values here 50 50 and 3
in the mountain bike
if i go here in the mountain bike
constructor so the start height start
speed and gear are the three values
which is supplied as 50 50 and 3 then i
am accessing the gear and the speed now
remember gear and speed are declared in
the bicycle class but they are
accessible in the child class due to the
inheritance phenomena which we have
already covered so if i print only this
part i should get the expected values
mountain bike gear is 3 which which is
what i have supplied here and mountain
bike speed is 50 which is which is what
i have supplied here
then i apply the breaks now let's move
on to this section i apply the break
supply the value as one and then i want
to see what would be the new speed after
applying the breaks so let's see what
happens when we run this particular code
so if i run this code after applying the
breaks the speed becomes 39 before
applying the breaks the speed was 50. so
what happened here is 50 minus 1
basically this this logic is getting
executed here 50 minus
1 minus 10 which becomes 39 that's why
you get the value as 39 as the new speed
similarly if you want to call another
method as speed up speed up method was
also defined here where i'm saying speed
plus the argument supplied plus 10. so
the current speed is 39 right now then
i'm speeding it up by 10 so by this
logic 39 plus 10 plus 10 which will
become 59 and then i'm printing the new
speed after speeding up so let's see
what happens so if i go to run as java
application and if i observe all the
outputs the speed was 50 initially after
applying the brakes the speed became 39
and after speeding up the speed became
59 so this was a quick demo to show you
the power of method overriding and how
you can override the behavior which is
defined in the base class so this is all
i want to cover in this particular
session let's get started with the
static keyword in java now let's first
understand the need of the static
keyword and then we'll talk about how
java implements the static keyword
imagine a scenario let's take the
example of a class which we have been
using in our in our different uh
tutorials in this particular series
which is about the student class so if
you are building a college management
system you have a student class there
and if you have an entry a property in
the student class which is storing the
name of the college then the name of the
college is going to be the same for all
of the students of that particular
college it's not going to change another
example let's say you are building a
employee management system for our
organization and you want to maintain
the employee numbers for the first
object the employee number should be one
for the second object the employee
number should be two for the third
object the employee number should be
three so on so forth so when you
initialize all the employee objects the
last employee object has the final total
employee count and you can also treat
this employee count as let's say the
employee number as the employee id so
starting from the first employee to the
last employee the employee number is the
employee id which is a way to uniquely
identify an employee so we talked about
two different cases in the first case we
had a particular value which was same
for all of the objects which was the
student and the college relationship and
then in the second example which i
quoted where all the employees objects
have to share a particular property
amongst them because if the second
object did not know the previous value
of the employee number it will not be
able to get to the new number it needs
to know what was the previous value so
that it can do plus one so each of the
object needs to know the state of the
previous object two different cases two
different scenarios one single solution
which is static keyword so the static
keywords are used for those members
which belong to the class now apply this
definition to the examples which i gave
you if i make a member of the student
class let's say the college is the
property of the student class and if i
make that property as static now that
static on that member that static member
becomes the property of the class and
not the property of the object it means
it belongs to the class it also means
that all of the objects will get the
same copy of this static member variable
and that's that's one of the first usage
and you can you can make any property or
any member of the class as static by
just putting the static keyword in front
of it we also call the static member
variables as class variables like i just
described so use it for the cases where
the value across the different objects
doesn't change you can make those class
variables those variables as class
variables or static variables similarly
also try to identify the cases where a
particular value has to be shared in
terms of knowing the previous state in
those cases as well you can use a
particular member in that particular
class and make that static for example
in this case we have a bicycle class and
we have a static variable which says
number of bicycles so every time you
initialize the bicycle object this
number will be shared and you can see i
mean this is here it is incrementing the
number of bicycles so every time you
create the object the id becomes plus
one to the previous count of the number
of bicycles exactly same example as i
gave you for the employee number so
every time you create an object you do a
plus one to the previous value next
object will take the previous value plus
one and so on so forth so you can use
the static uh keyword in front of a
property of the class and make it a
class level variable which will be tied
to the class and not tied to the objects
you can also make the methods as static
as well and the same kind of rule will
apply on the methods as well that the
methods will become will belong to the
class instead of belonging to the
objects let's say you have again a
common functionality which you want to
share amongst objects just make that
common functionality as a static method
and that would be shared amongst the
objects for example you want to get the
total number of bicycles for the
previous example which i just shared in
this particular dock here so you can
just create that method static and any
object which will call this method will
get the latest count of the number of
bicycles you can also make these uh
these static variables as constants by
putting the final modifier in front of
it so if a variable in a particular
class is static and final both then
technically becomes a constant so these
are some of the interesting use cases
and
constraints of the static methods and
static variables there's also a thing
called static block which is just a code
block which you can write inside your
class and we will have a look at that
example as well so let's shift to the
ide and let's have a look at how we can
use this static keyword so i have used
again the same class which i have been
using using in other examples which is
student.java and you can see i have this
same class you have you would have seen
these properties earlier as well and the
code below is exactly the same just
centers and getters and constructors and
it has an additional property which is
college and the college name xyz is the
same for all the students so i have just
hard coded it but you see what is
happening here is that every time you
create a student object this variable
gets initialized even though the
variable for all the objects has the
same value still it gets initialized
again and again and again so technically
it's a waste of memory you're just
wasting memory of an offer new
allocation every time even though the
value is same what if we create this
object once and this member variable
once and just use it across objects you
can do that by just writing static in
front of it if you do that then you see
this becomes sort of italic here and
that's java's convention to show that
this particular variable is a static
variable you can also see the static
keyword in front of it and then whatever
value you have specified this will be
initialized only when the class is
loaded remember i'm not talking about
the object initialization i'm talking
about the loading of the class in the
jvm
so the first time the class is loaded
this particular variable will be
initialized and that's it after that no
matter how many student objects you
create the same college reference will
be used again and again and the college
variable will not be initialized again
it will be initialized once and the same
college reference will be used again and
again that's the power of static
variables for example if i want to
access this particular college variable
how do i do that so let's look at a main
class where i have initialized this
particular student class with an object
named as john and i've specified the
name the age and the address and i'm
printing those values how do i access
the static variable if i say john dot
do i get access to the college variable
yes i do have access to it but does it
work let's see you see a yellow line
here and we will come to that yellow
line in a while but let's first see if
this works
yes it works i can see that the college
name is printed here as xyz which i have
set now let's look at the error or the
warning it says the static field student
dot college college should be accessed
in a static way because the way you are
accessing it right now is the instance
way of accessing a particular member
this is not a static way of accessing a
member so if you want to access a static
member of a class you should access it
with the class name and not the object
name why going back to my original
definition that the static variables
belong to class they do not belong to
object and that's why java will warn you
if you are not accessing the static
variables via the class because they are
supposed to be accessible via class it
will not give you a compilation error
but if you are working in an enterprise
project this is going to raise a lot of
violations and lot of questions for you
as to why you are not accessing it via
the class name so this is the correct
way of accessing it and you will get the
same output now no matter how many
objects you create of the student class
you can always access the
student.college and you can always get
the same value of the college name
that's the first use case second thing
is about static methods
so you will use the static methods in a
case where i described about the
counting the employee numbers and let's
say if we have the same kind of scenario
where you have to count the number of
students because you can use that
particular count as let's say the role
number of the student so if you have
that kind of requirement then you need
to create a static method because you
need to share the state of the object
across objects remember that so what you
can do simply is create a static method
so let's say i create a normal method
and then i just put static in front of
it saying static void student count and
now i want to count the student so i can
let's create a simple count variable and
let's start it with 0 and then i can
increment the count variable again and
again in the static method right but you
see i get an error here the error is if
you go to the balloon it says cannot
make a static reference to a non-static
field count this is one of the
properties of the static methods the
moment you make a method as static then
that particular method can only access
the static member variables of the class
the static methods will not be able to
access the non-static variables count is
a non-static variable count is a normal
instance variable so a normal instance
variable for that matter name or age or
address nothing would be accessible here
if i try to access let's say try to
access name here so if i just say this
out and i say name it will also give me
give me the same kind of error if i go
here it gives me the exact same error
because static method cannot access the
non-static member variables of the class
so you have to make this count variable
as static as well and then only this
compilation error will be fixed i can
remove this one and now this method is
fine now i can
increment the count every time that
object is created
and that is one of the use case of using
the static method that you can share the
state across the different objects and
if you want to fetch this particular
variable then you can simply write a
getter for this
saying end count return
count
and then you can return the count you
can see that now an instance method can
access
the static member so
the reverse is is fine a non-static
method can access a static variable but
a static method cannot access a
non-static variable remember that a
static method can
not access a non-static variable but a
non-static method can very well access
anything including the static variable
that's second thing the third concept is
of static block
and static block also has a similar
usage that if you have a block of code
it's not just a variable it's not just a
method but you have a block of logic
which you want to execute only once when
the class is loaded into the runtime if
that is your requirement then you can
write a static block and the way you
will write it generally we write it at
the beginning of the class and the way
you will write it is it as you write
static and you put curly braces and you
start writing code here as to whatever
you can say initializer
and you can write whatever code you want
to write the only caveat is that in the
static block you will only be able to
access
only the static member variables of the
class so you will not be able to access
these variables you can only access
these two variables you can very well
move these two variables here if you
want to so if i go here i can paste this
and i can drop the static keyword
because everything in the static block
is automatically static so i don't need
to explicitly call out static variable
and now this code is fine you get some
warning because it's not used anywhere
in the class but that's fine because
this is just a simple demo but the whole
point is that you can write the static
block and you can write all these
initializer code which you want to write
here which you only want to execute once
during the whole execution of your
program just to show you the the reason
and
the way it works let's try to see if the
static block works
and let me comment all the static code
which i wrote here and let's go back to
the static demo and let me remove this
one as well so now i just will run this
student dot java i will i will create an
object of student.java and i will see if
the static block gets executed or not so
let's run this particular class which is
the main class and i have a main method
i have a student object initialized and
i'm printing the name agent address
if i run this you see the first line of
code which gets printed in the output
console is the static block code
which is what i wrote here and let me do
one more thing just for fun sake let me
create
more objects of it
let me just call them one
two
three and four
and let's see and let's see how many
times the initializer code gets printed
you see that the code still gets printed
only once even when i created five
different objects of the student class
and that's the property of the static
block that it will be executed only once
when the program is loaded into the
runtime and that's all
and that's pretty much all what i want
to cover in this particular session
let's get started with nested classes in
java so so far we have seen that we can
create classes in java and we can create
objects of those classes to interact
between those classes and objects and
other properties as well but what if you
have a use case or what if there is a
need that you need to define a class
within a class so that's the concept of
nested classes that java does allow you
to create classes within the classes now
you might be wondering as to why do you
want to do that and the simple answer is
encapsulation you would be facing some
scenarios while writing enterprise grade
applications where you have a class
which has its own scope but that whole
scope or the existence of that class is
justified by another class for example
if you try to design an object oriented
design for a house then a kitchen cannot
exist without a house because the
kitchen exists inside the house right
so
if you have that kind of relationship
then probably kitchen class has to be
inside the house class somehow and
that's where this nested class concept
will come into picture and that's why we
have this nested class concept here as
you can see with what i'm showing on the
diagram that java programming language
allows you to define a class within a
class and that is called nested class
now when we talk about nested classes
you will hear two different terms
basically nested classes are divided
into two categories which are static
classes or static nested classes and
non-static nested classes now static
nested classes are called simply static
nested classes and the non-static nested
classes are called inner classes because
they are non-static they are just normal
inner class exactly similar to the way
we say a normal method and a static
method similarly if you put a static
keyword in front of in front of a nested
class that becomes a static nested class
and if you do not put static keyword in
front of a nested class then it is
simply treated as a general inner class
that's the overall concept now there are
some more drivers of why you would like
to use it one example is i gave you
about the existence of an object within
an object or or technically speaking the
existence of a class within a class the
whole house and kitchen analogy which i
just shared with you but broadly you
will see three different reasons these
different reasons due to which you will
be using nested classes first of all
it's a way to logically group all the
related classes that are only used in
one place what it means is that if you
have a class
which is only serving the purpose for a
larger class then it's better to group
those two classes together inside a
single class or simply nest the smaller
class inside the bigger class we i might
be using the term inner class and outer
class to point out the static nested
inner class and the outer class that's
the first reason the second reason is
like i said it increases encapsulation
because now you have full control over
what you can expose and what you cannot
expose or what you should expose and
what you should not expose because inner
classes will also come with its own set
of visibility constructs like private
protected etc so you you get more
fine-grained control in terms of what
you want to expose to the outside world
collectively from the outer and the
inner class and it can lead to more
readable and maintainable code though i
would honestly say that this is
debatable because in lot of programming
languages static nested classes are not
promoted because they drop readability
imagine if you have 10 classes if you
have a single class and if you have a
nested hierarchy of 10 classes it
becomes super confusing and super
complex to track the visibility of the
variables and also to understand the
code better so this is debatable whether
it improves to readability and
maintainability or not maintainability
yes to a sense because you have a single
class which is containing the logic of
our inner helper class and the outer
class readability yes or no it depends
if if the classes are small size then
yes it does improve readability if they
if they grow larger then it's better to
move the class outside and just make
that class maybe a package private or
something so this is the basic premise
of why we use nested classes now let's
talk about an example which by which we
can demonstrate how to work with the
static nested classes
so here i have created a class it's a
simple class but i've just named it as
outer class so that we understand that
this is the outer class so i have a
class here which is named as outer class
and at line 5 i am defining a static
variable inside the class you can see
the static keyword here and i just
called it as outer static member then i
have a simple instance variable this is
something which you have seen normally
in in all the different examples i have
given you and then i have another static
variable but this is private so this one
is a normal static variable this one is
a normal instance variable and this one
is a private static outer variable all
these three variables are sitting in the
outer class but this is private this is
static this is private static and this
is a normal instance method and we will
see how we can access these variables
inside the static nested class to define
the static nested class the way you will
write it as you will be inside the class
opening and closing braces and you will
start writing like this static class and
the name of your class that is how
you're going to define a static nested
class and then you put the curly braces
and whatever goes inside it is just like
any other normal class you would write
so let's say inside this static nested
class i have defined a method called
display and now i am trying to access
this particular variable which was a
static variable defined in the outside
class or the outer class we will see if
we can access the static variables from
the outside class or not so that is what
this
system.out.println is doing i'm just
accessing this directly you can see you
can directly access the outer class
static member variable inside the static
nested inner class then in the next
statement i am accessing the outer
private member this one so the outer
private member which is also static so
these two static variables are being
accessed here in these two lines
basically and then i have commented out
one more thing to try out if i can
access the normal instance member also
remember the concept which i which i
taught you in the previous session that
a static method or a static block can
only access static variables a static
block will not be able to access
non-static variables so these two are
static variables and this is a
non-static variable so we will see if
the same construct still applies on this
particular class or not so inside the
display method i have these two sis outs
and this one is commented out i will
come back to that later so you have the
you have your outer class and your
static nested class ready with a sample
method and now let's see how we can
invoke these outer and inner classes how
do we create the objects of an inner
class so for that i have this static
nested demo class it's basically
containing a public static void main
method as you can see here and let's try
accessing a static nested class so if
you want to initialize or access the
inner static nested class then you have
to follow this kind of construct where
you say outer class
dot inner class name then you give a
reference to it and again you follow the
same construct you say new outer class
dot static nested class name and a
simple parenthesis
and this is how you are going to create
an object of the static nested class
which you have defined inside your outer
class remember this syntax this is how
you are going to do this that you type
outer class dot static nested class once
you have done that it will call the
default constructor of static nested
class and you will get an object now you
will also see the dependency which i
talked about there is no way that you
can initialize this static nested class
without referring it from the outer
class you always have to write this
outer class dot to access the static
nested class you will not be able to
access or use this static nested class
directly anywhere in your program so the
whole concept of the
inner class only existing with the outer
class holds true here because you can
the inner class only can exist if you
refer it from the outer class once you
have the object you call the dot display
method and let's see what happens so if
i run this particular program
and let's see what kind of output do i
get i get two lines of output when i
call the display method so let's go to
the display method where i am doing a ss
out for the static member of the outer
class which was this variable so that
value gets printed as 10 and then i am
printing the private static member of
the outer class and that also is
accessible so it means that you can
access the normal static variable of the
outer class and also the private static
variable of the outer class inside a
static nested class that's one part of
it now let's uncomment this and see if
this works you see that you directly get
a compilation error and you don't even
have to wait for the program to be run
you see that this particular variable
instance member this instance member
variable is not accessible so this this
also verifies our understanding which
which was built previously in the
previous session that static blocks can
only access static members and those
static blocks will not be able to access
any non-static variable or member and
this was a non-static member so that's
all i want to cover in this particular
session where we talked about the nested
classes concept the static nested
classes concepts basically and we also
had a look at what the static nested
class can access or cannot access and we
also saw how do we initialize an object
of a static nested class in the next
session we are going to talk about the
second category of the nested classes
which is the normal inner classes or the
non-static nested classes let's get
started with inner classes in java so in
the previous session we talked about the
static nested classes and in today's
session we are going to focus on the
non-static nested classes we also call
them simply as inner classes so whenever
you hear the word inner classes always
clarify whether they mean the static
nested inner classes or the non-static
nested inner classes because people may
use different terminologies but the
official or the standard terminology is
whenever somebody says inner classes it
means the normal nested class and when
somebody wants to convey static nested
classes they will use explicitly the
word as static nested classes so when we
talk about inner classes they look a bit
similar to the static nested classes
with the difference that you will not
see a static keyword when you define the
inner class
that's the one type of the simplest
inner class you can create it follows
pretty much the same kind of construct
where you define the outer class and you
define the inner class and you write the
logic inside the inner class
so let's understand this with the help
of an example and we will also talk
about the other type of inner classes
which we have so with that i want to
switch back to the eclipse ide and let
me comment this one out because i will
cover this in a while and let me fix an
error here as well so i will comment
this as well okay so let's talk about uh
the demo which we which i prepared it's
a very simplistic demo just to
understand the concept and please do
practice all of these concepts in detail
to get get more confident about this so
i start defining a normal class just
naming it as outer class and then you
can create a class within a class i am
calling it as inner class you can
obviously name it as anything you want
and you can write any logic which you
want to write inside your inner class
here i just have a display method where
i have a simple sys out which is
verifying if i can invoke this
particular method or not
so if you have this simple kind of
construct of outer class or inner class
how do you how do you initialize the
inner class remember when we talked
about the static nested classes and if
you wanted to initialize the static
nested class i had to follow this
particular syntax where i said outer
class dot inner class on both sides when
i try to initialize the object but if i
want to initialize a normal inner class
or a non-stat non-static nested class
the way to do that is like this so on
the left hand side you again follow the
same kind of construct where you say
outer class
dot inner class you write a reference
for it and then you say new outer class
here you are creating an object of it
dot new inner class so you basically
first initialize the outer class create
an object of the outer class and then
that object of the outer class
can be used to create an object of the
inner class so this is the difference if
i take you back to the static nested
classes initialization here on the right
hand side it was simply outer class dot
inner class and then the parenthesis
because this was a static member so you
access the static members by the class
name that's why class name dot static
member but you access the normal
instance members via the instance and
not the class name so you need to create
the instance first and then once you
have created that instance then you can
access any member variable of this class
and inner class technically is just a
member variable which has been
initialized here so this is how you are
going to initialize an inner class then
you get an object of it and once you
have got the object of the inner class
then you can call the display method and
whatever is written in the display
method shall be executed let's run this
program yes i can see that the display
method is getting called and it is
printing whatever was written inside the
display method in the display method i
just simply had a sis out which said
this is an inner class method and that's
what is getting printed here that's one
type of the inner class which is looking
very simple another a bit more complex
and special type of inner class is
called method local inner class when i
say method local inner class the name
itself explains what it means that you
are trying to create a class
inside a method of the outer class so
let me just uncomment this part so this
is a normal method normal instance
method of the outer class and inside the
method i create a class you see inside
the method also you can create an inner
class that is also something which is
supported by java and that's what i'm
trying to showcase here that when i
define the outer class method i write my
whatever logic i want to write in my
method and then i can create an inner
class a method local class basically
i've just named it as method local class
to uh to just look it more readable and
then you can define anything you want to
write inside your method local class
here i have just defined a simple method
called local inner method and i have
just printed a statement inside the
local inner method which says in the
method local class method once i've
defined the class then within the method
i can also initialize the class if i
want you can see i'm creating an object
of the method local class within the
enclosing method that is also possible
so i create an object called mlc and
then once i have the object i can invoke
this method by the object and that is
what i'm doing here so this whole logic
can be just embedded inside a particular
method and we call this type of class as
method local in our classes this is also
a type of inner class but this is just
to show you that you can also create
method local inner classes so this is
what i've done here and if i if i invoke
this outer class method what happens
let's see that so here i have written
the code to simply initialize the outer
class nothing new here this is a normal
initialization and once i've done that
once i've got an instance then i say
outer class dot outer class method i
simply call the instance method and once
i call the instance method everything is
written inside the instance method gets
executed so first i should get the
statement then the class will get loaded
and compiled then an instance of the
class will be created and then whatever
is written inside the local inner method
will be executed so technically i should
see this this out and ultimately this is
out if i run those two lines let me
comment the first part so that we can
observe the output correctly and i run
this as a java application and i get
these two lines so i get the in the
outer class method statement which is
coming from here and then i
this this whole code gets executed and
eventually when this method gets called
i get this statement as well which is in
the method local class method so this is
to show you how you can invoke the
method local classes basically there's
nothing new here it's just a normal
class you instantiate the normal class
and then you call the
object you get an object and you call
the method on the object of the method
local class
now there is another type of inner class
which is called anonymous inner class
which we haven't covered so far
anonymous inner classes are not very
common but sometimes you you might need
to do that
you might need to create anonymous inner
classes but always first understand and
discuss with your teammates as to if
there is a way to avoid anonymous inner
classes because they are not very
readable but let me cover that as well
as part of this curriculum so if you
have to implement anonymous in our
classes let's first understand why do we
need to implement anonymous inner
classes and i would like to do that with
the help of a demonstration so i have
again created a simple interface of
bicycle and i will create an
implementation class called mountain
bike so you see a bicycle interface and
i have two methods which says can speed
up and can apply brake just simple to
interface methods being declared here
then i create an implementation class
called mountain bike which implements
bicycle and if it implements bicycle it
has to provide the implementation of
those two declared methods in the
interface and that's what it does here
and for the sake of simplicity i'm just
printing assist out here all good so far
and then if you have to access or create
an object of this mountain bike class
the way you do that is simply by just
saying bicycle mountain equal to new
mountain bike remember i'm using the
bicycle reference here and but the
object is of mountain bike so when i
call anything on the mountain bike then
that implementation of the mountain bike
will be invoked so i'm just invoking the
can apply brake method and can speed up
methods nothing new here you have
already seen this when we were talking
about interfaces session but what if you
want to create an object of the bicycle
class itself you don't want to create a
mountain bike class at all is there a
way to avoid creating mountain bike
class and still being able to write this
logic yes there is a way and that is the
anonymous inner way so i can just say
bicycle bicycle equal to new bicycle if
i say new bicycle remember i'm not
seeing new mountain bike because
mountain bike does not exist or i don't
want to create mountain bike class then
you can write this instantiation right
for the interface class but the moment
you hit control space and you will get
this option where it will say okay i
will get you an object of bicycle
interface but it has to be of anonymous
inner type which is of which is lying in
this particular package so if you just
click on this this whole code will be
generated for you so you see the moment
you double click on this this whole code
was generated automatically for you
which is providing everything
technically everything which you wrote
in the mountain bike class so the whole
logic which you could write in a child
class gets embedded right into the
instantiation code itself and this is
your anonymous inner class you see it
automatically looks a bit ugly and
imagine if you're writing this for a
real production code where each of the
methods may have lot of logic and you
may have lot of methods then it can grow
very long and it can look very ugly
that's why i was saying always try to
create a child class instead
it can be a simple use case but try to
create a child class or try to avoid
writing anonymous inner classes if you
can if there is no way out then this is
the way you do it you can there's also a
bit nicer way to do this using using
lambda function for functional
interfaces but that is also something
which will not uh improve the
readability a lot though it will make
the code look smaller so here you can
write the exact logic which you want to
write in can speed up and can apply
break basically whatever you wrote in
the in those two methods in the mountain
bike class can very well be written here
and the code will still be executed so
let's let's just do that quickly so i
will just go here and copy this out from
speedup method i'll just put it here and
i will copy the can apply break method
and i will put it here and i will
comment the mountain bike code so i'm
creating i've created the object of
bicycle class here and now if i say
bicycle dot can apply break and i can
say bicycle
dot can speed up so now i can access
these two methods and the implementation
will be invoked from this anonymous
inner class implementation so if i run
this i will get pretty much the same
output yes you can see i get exactly the
same output it's currently printing both
of these outside the same because i did
not change the cis out here and yeah i
have written the exactly same text in
both of the cases so if i just change
text to say can apply break
and i do the same thing here i say can
apply
break and if i run this
so you get the same output and if you
uncomment if you comment this back and
if you use the above code you also get
the same output yep so that's the basic
construct of anonymous inner classes
that you can use the interface
instantiation if you do not want to
create a child class of it just
instantiate the interface and java will
automatically generate the concrete
override implementation for all the
methods which are declared in your
interface and then you can provide the
implementation of those methods inline
and that's all i want to cover for this
particular session so we covered a whole
lot we covered about the normal inner
classes we covered the method local
inner classes and we covered the
anonymous inner classes let's get
started with packages in java now i have
been using the concept of packages all
the while in all the sessions but we
never focused particularly on packages
and why we need them how do we create
them what are the thumb rules so we will
focus on all of those questions in this
particular session so first of all just
to get the definition out a package is
basically a grouping of related types
now these types can be classes they can
be interfaces they can be abstract
classes uh they can be uh nested classes
or what not but the basic idea is that
you try to keep everything which is
related to each other at one place it's
quite similar to how you arrange your
house or how you arrange your office or
how you arrange your work desk you try
to keep the similar kind of stuff
together for example you might have a
particular rack in your almira where you
keep all the books you might have a
different track where you keep clothes
generally you won't mix
books and clothes together in a single
rack right because they don't belong
together and that's the concept
basically which java packages try to put
you or give you to implement in your
programming language and your project as
well so it's a logical way of grouping
related classes and types together
that's what packages do and if i take
you back to the eclipse ide before i go
any further you will see all these
square looking objects right these all
are packages you see the square icons
these boxes these are packages and the
way you create packages is basically if
you just go to the src let me go back to
the src and you right click on this you
go to new you will get an option of
package so you can go click here and
write any name of your package let's say
test dot package couple of things to
note is that packages
follow this convention of dot and that
is how you nest a package into other or
that is how you create a hierarchy of
packages and sub packages
so you can create this as a package
which is fine and you can also create
dot something dot something else dot
something else dot something else and
you can go further as well other thing
to notice is that this will not accept
keywords you can see it says else is not
a valid java identifier because else is
a keyword a reserved keyword in java so
make sure that you are not using those
reserved keyword names in the in this
particular package name so it can be
test.test1.test2.test3
whatever so just make sure that you're
not using keywords here and you can
create the hierarchy now how do you name
them different organizations and
different project teams follow different
naming conventions this is your area
this is fully customizable so you can
write it write it the way you want it
generally what companies do is they put
their domain
name from the backwards so for example
uh google.com might have a package
called com.google similarly amazon.com
might have a package called com.amazon
internally this this is something which
might have been there but they can they
they might have chosen something else
but this is sort of the standard
convention that you just reverse the
domain name of your application and you
write the package name backwards that is
the general convention and after that
once you have written that let's say if
you have written
com.google this is the top domain name
now after that you specify what you want
to do let's say you you are implementing
a web package then you can be even more
specific okay web package is a huge huge
package what is specifically your this
package will be doing inside the web
package so let's say html html might not
be a right example but uh let's say
some front-end code front-end auth logic
let's say so now this can be a valid
package because if somebody reads the
package they can understand what would
be lying inside the package this hugely
improves readability and please do spend
a good amount of time in naming your
packages right because once you write
the code the code is going to be living
for many many years to come and many
other developers once you leave the
organization many other developers will
be looking at that code and you would
like to make their lives easy by
by understanding the code by just
looking at the package name so please
name the package names correctly and
once you have written this package name
as for example in this case front-end
authlogic or let me say front-end dot
authlogic once you have written this
package name as authlogic then make sure
that only the classes which belong to
this particular business requirement are
present inside this package no other
unrelated class should go inside the
package that is something also which
developer have to take care of so this
is again the responsibilities of the
developers that they make sure that
whatever goes inside these this
particular package is only relevant to
the package there's no irrelevant stuff
we should go inside the package again
this is to improve readability
searchability maintainability and tons
of other
out-of-the-box benefits you get so that
is how you create the packages now let
me go back to the documentation and talk
about why would you use that let's look
at some of the more benefits of it so if
you scroll down in this official
documentation you will find bunch of
reasons and benefits of it first of all
you and other programmers can easily
determine that these types are related
because if something if some classes and
some types are sitting inside a package
then there is an expectation that those
classes and types serve the purpose of
that package only you also it also
provides a benefit that you and other
programmers can can easily find the
types that can provide a particular type
of functionality again the same concept
of aggregating simple single functional
classes into these packages that if you
are writing let's say a banking
application and if you if you have a
package called uh interest rates then
everything inside the calculation of the
interest rate and the specification of
the interest rates should sit inside
that particular package only similarly
the names of your type won't not
conflict with the type names in the
other packages that is also a huge
benefit of packages that you once you
start writing a particular class inside
a package and if you make that
particular class as private package then
that particular class will be visible
only within the package and you can
again recreate the exact same class with
the exact same name in another package
let me give you an example so if i go to
uh let's say the inheritance example
here i have a class called bicycle this
is a bicycle class and if you see
strategically i have not put public here
i have removed the public identifier
here so this class is only visible
within this package called dot
inheritance this particular class will
only be visible in this package to these
other classes
now if i go let's say if i go to method
overriding i have another bicycle.java
here if i open this this is also a class
these two classes are exactly the same
but they don't conflict with each other
because both of them are package private
and they live in different packages and
only those packages can see them this
particular class is present in this
particular package which ends with dot
method overriding and this particular
class ends in a package with ends with
dot inheritance so if i go here let's
see if i go to the main class and if i
try to type bicycle
and i put control space you see i only
get the suggestion of this
package private bicycle class which is
sitting inside the method overriding
package itself what if i change this the
visibility of this inheritance package
bicycle class to public let's make it
public and now if i go back to the
method overriding demo which is sitting
in the method overriding package where i
already have a bicycle class and now if
i type bicycle and i do control space i
get two options one is from the local
package and because i have made the
other bicycle class as public i get that
as well as a suggestion and if i import
this one you see now the inheritance
package bicycle class has been imported
in the method overriding package it can
create a lot of confusion that's why it
is always a good practice to work with
the access modifiers really well and try
to restrict the visibility of the
classes to what they should be
accessible at and that's why it's a good
practice to keep the classes within the
package private visibility so that
they're only visible within the package
this will help you in a lot of ways
providing any kind of
any kind of problems around ambiguity so
ambiguity is a big problem when you have
huge projects with lot of similar class
names so that's all i want to cover in
the in the session of packages and you
can obviously nest packages within one
another you can go as long as the
package name you want to be just make
sure that there are no keywords in those
package names so that's all for this
particular session let's get started
with recursion in java so let's first
understand what do we mean by recursion
and then we will look at the details of
the class which you are seeing on your
screen so recursion is the phenomena of
an a method calling itself so
so we we have the scenarios where we
call a particular method on an object
right but what if you have a scenario
where a method wants to call itself now
you might be wondering why a method
would call itself because this will go
into an infinite loop right if you write
a method called sum and then the sum
inside the sum method you again invoke
the sub method then this will keep
running into loops till your program
goes out of memory i will show you the
example of that as well but the basic
idea is the use case where if you have a
need where the where the method wants to
call itself that is where you will use
the recursion concept another thing
whatever you can achieve with recursion
generally you can achieve the same
output using for loops as well but when
you use it for for loops it will require
you to write lot of code recursion will
reduce the number of lines you need to
write and manage in your code but on the
other side recursion can get a bit
complex because it requires an advanced
understanding of how methods actually
work in java so before i go any further
understand that methods whatever you
define inside the method that goes on to
a stack remember i covered about stacks
and it's a lifo arrangement so whatever
you define inside your method all those
variables and all those statements they
go on to a stack and then the stack gets
emptied one by one executing the
statement which is sitting on the top of
the stack that is the concept of the
method execution that under the hood it
is using a stack now when we talk about
the recursion it also follows the same
stack uh insertion and stack item
removal concept that how do you insert
elements into the stack and how do you
remove them so i'm we are going to walk
through an example of recursion with the
help of a use case called factorial now
if you if you have studied about
factorial in your in your school classes
you might remember that factorial is a
way where let's say if i have to
calculate the factorial of 10 then it
would be 10 into the factorial of 9 into
the factorial of 8 into the factorial of
7. so you see i'm repeating the concept
of calculating the factorial again and
again first i'm calculating the
factorial of 10 in a 10 into factorial
of 9 then i say 9 into factorial of 8
then i say 8 into factorial of 7 then i
say 7 into factorial of 6 and so on so
forth so this is the concept of how do
you calculate factorials another example
where you can use recursion is a
fibonacci series so when we talk about
the fibonacci series the basic idea is
that you
sum the previous two elements and that's
how you create the next element then
this then you sum the immediate previous
two and you create the next element so
again you perform the operation of
summing the past two elements again and
again to calculate the next element so
you see again you're repeating the same
operation again and again so try to
identify that particular thing where you
have to repeat the particular operation
again and again on the whole sequence
that would be the use case where you
might be needing to use a recursion
concept so here i have prepared an
example for calculating the factorial of
a number so what you see on your screen
is a class called complex function and
then it has a method called calculate
factorial and inside the method you
supply an argument which is basically a
number for which you want to calculate
the factorial so if you supply 5 a
factorial of 5 will be calculated if you
supply 10 a factorial of 10 will be
calculated now the first thing which you
need to do when you write a recursion
function is to know the exit condition
that is probably the most important
concept when you write recursion you
should know when to end the program if
you get it wrong then your program will
start will be stuck into an infinite
loop and it will only exit when there
would be a stack overflow basically
there will not be enough memory inside
the jvm to run your program it will
crash technically so remember always to
define a exit condition some people also
call it as a base condition but remember
the base case or base condition or the
exit condition either of the terms can
be used interchangeably but always
remember to first define the base
condition so here when do you end
calculating the factorial you know the
factorial of 1 is 1 and it cannot go any
further so that would be your base
condition that once if if you if you
encounter a scenario where somebody
inputs one as an argument then you
simply return one because the factorial
of one will be one so this is your base
case this is what is going to make sure
that your program exits smoothly if you
get it wrong your program will never end
it will go into an endless mode then in
the else condition you write the
factorial logic based on the recursion
so like i said what does a factorial
function does is if you calculate the
factorial of 5 then it would be 5 into
factorial of 4 4 into factorial of 3 3
into factorial of 2 2 into factorial of
1 and that's when it will end so here
i'm saying let's say 10 was 5 so you say
5 into you again call back the same
function 5 into calculate factorial of 5
minus 1 so now again the function will
be invoked with an n equal to 4 it will
go here this condition will not be met
because n is 4 it will go to the else
block again the same thing will happen
four into calculate factorial of three
so you are again invoking the same
function but this time supplying an as
three so it will go here n will be
supplied as three it will again check
the base condition n is still not 3 and
is still not 1 so it will go to the else
block so 3 into calculate factorial of 2
it will again go up and again it will
invoke the calculate factorial method
but this time with n equal to 2 this
condition is still false because n is
still 2 it will go to the else block and
it will say 2 into calculate factorial
of 1 it will again go up this time it
will invoke with n equal to 1 and it
will go here and it will satisfy the
condition and that's where your program
will have its first output you remember
previous execution of 5 into factorial 4
into factorial 3 into factorial 2 did
not result into an output these were the
executions of the method call which were
just going on the stack so you were just
at first you had the calculate factorial
of 5 on the stack on top of it you had
the calculate factorial 4 on the stack
then you had calculate factorial 3 on
the stack then you had two and then you
had one but when you had one your
program did this uh
received or reached any particular end
so that was your first output once you
have your first output ready then you go
back to the previous one so the first
statement has been popped now you go
back to the calculate factorial of two
and you calculate that once you have the
output of that then you go back to
calculate factorial of three and so you
basically unpack the stack now you
basically try to remove the elements
from the stack to visualize this this is
how it will look like that you first
call the factorial 5 let me just change
the name of it just to make it
look exactly how it will go on the stack
so this is how it is going to go on the
stack so you first you call the
calculate factorial of 5 which in turn
called the calculate factorial 4 which
in turn called calculate factorial 3
calculate factorial 2 calculate
factorial 1 and once you had the
calculate factorial one you got the
first output and once you had the first
output then you start unpacking it
because you had the value of the
calculate factorial one so you can set
two into calculate factorial one's
output calculate factorial once output
was 1 so 2 into 1 becomes 2 and this is
the output of calculate factorial 2
right then it goes to the next step
basically this one sorry this one and
calculate factorial 3 was demonstrated
as three into calculate factorial of two
so three into calculate factorial of two
which is this one two so this gets
replaced here two and you get the output
as six now you have this one also
resolved the next one on the stack was
calculate factorial of 4 which was
written as 4 into calculate factorial of
3 so 4 into calculate factorial of 3 is
output so this function calls output
this functions call output was 6. it
goes back and it says 4 into 6 24 and
you have this one also calculated now
you go to the last statement which was
calculate factorial of 5 which was
written as 5 into calculate factorial of
4 and calculate factorial of 4 has been
already computed as 24 so now you can
simply say 5 into 24 which is the output
of calculate factorial 4 and you get the
output as 120 and this is the final
return statement which will be returned
to you so if you try to understand this
till this particular point you were just
calling function after function after
function with a different value of n and
everything started getting into a result
due to the base condition this was the
base condition and that's why the base
condition is very important now imagine
there was no base condition then this
would never return and it will keep
calling calculate factorial calculate
factorial and it will keep going down
the stairs it will never be able to come
up because there is no base condition
and that's why base condition is very
important at the same time also
understanding how recursion works is
also very important also always remember
that the output of the first execution
gets supplied in the second execution
the output of the second execution gets
supplied in the third execution and
that's how the stack unpacks or empties
itself so here i'm just doing the normal
drill here where i'm saying complex
function complex function equal to new
complex function and then calling the
calculate factorial method passing 5 to
it and then printing the eventual result
and if i run this i get the output as
120 which i just walked you through so
remember how to use the recursion why to
use the recursion how to define the base
condition all of these things will will
be of of very much importance when you
try to implement recursions practice
this a lot recursion is a concept which
takes time to to get used to so practice
many different examples and many
questions of recursion and you will be
more confident about it read more about
this concept in the java docs look at
different examples on the internet that
will help you build more knowledge
around this and that's all i want to
cover in this particular session and in
the next session we are going to talk
about how do we call methods basically
how the method calling works we will
look at different examples and the pass
by value concept etc when we look at the
method calling let's get started with
method calling in java now when it comes
to defining the methods i have been
talking about methods throughout this
particular series and the syntax is
pretty familiar where you first specify
the access modifier then you specify the
return type then you specify the actual
name of the method and after that you
specify all the arguments which this
method is going to accept and inside the
curly braces you do your calculation and
based on the return type you return an
appropriate value we have seen many
examples of it and let me show you a
quick example to just understand the
method anatomy better and then we will
talk about how do we pass arguments to
methods so in this simple class student
i have some properties i have
constructor and then i have methods
these all are also simply methods you
can see we have an access modifier which
will decide whether this particular
method should be visible to the outside
world or not you can also either remove
this particular access modifier or make
the method private if you want or you
can also make the method protected if
you want so all of the possibilities are
there and that and what what kind of
access modifier will you keep depends
upon upon your use case so that is the
access modifier and then if your method
is not supposed to return anything then
you would just say void void is the
default keyword in java which is used
for use cases when you do not want to
return something void just means empty
or nothing so when you have nothing to
return you are going to put void you
cannot skip this if you remove if you
remove this the method signature is not
complete so you have to provide this
there is no way around it so you need to
provide the method return type after
that you provide the name of the method
this is a free text string and you can
name it whatever you want just follow
the camel casing convention where you
start with a small alphabet and for
every new word in the method name you
start with the first letter as capital
after that you put normal braces and you
supply the arguments which this
particular method is going to accept for
example if this method was about
calculating interest then probably you
might supply the interest rate as the
argument and the principle as the
argument if this method was about
calculating the price of the car then
you might supply all the different
mileage details and the manufacturing
details which would decide the price of
the car so it depends upon what you are
doing and that's how you will understand
what kind of arguments your method is
going to need when you define the
arguments you need to define the data
type of the argument and again a name
which you can give it give it as
anything this is again a free text
string and after that it depends upon
you what kind of logic you want to write
inside the method the basic need for
writing a method is to not do the same
thing again and again at every place if
you have a functionality let's say if i
take the same example if you have to
calculate interest and the interest
calculation logic is required at let's
say 15 different places in your
application then just create a single
method for calculating the interest rate
or the interest and then just reuse that
method again and again
at different points in your application
just call that method that's that's how
we use it so that is the basic idea of
creating a method to keep reusing the
functionality over and over again across
all the different methods in your
application let's take another example
of this particular method because it has
a return statement again i specify a
public access modifier i specify the
return type which is string in this case
then i specify a name of the method and
i can also choose not to supply any
argument if the method does not need any
argument to do its computation or to run
its logic if you put a return type any
any other return type then y and then
void here then you have to provide a
return statement the return statement
will be the last execution step of your
method remember that the return
statement will be the last execution
step of your method execution this has
to be provided if you provide a return
type other than void inside your method
in this particular case this method
expects a string return type which means
when i call get name i should get a
result back which should be of type
string then i need to write a return
statement and return a variable which
should be of string type for example if
i just change this method to say let's
say if i say int i equal to 1 and if i
say return i this is going to give you
an error you see there's a compilation
error and if you hover over the balloon
icon it says cannot convert from int to
string it is trying to convert this
particular return type and trying to
match this into this particular return
type and it's not able to match into
string so you get you get an error so it
has to exactly match the return type the
data type of the of the return uh value
which you have put here it has to match
exactly with the the return statement
variable type if it doesn't match you're
going to get a compilation error that's
the first thing now there might be
scenarios where you have multiple
branches of execution in your method for
example if you have if let's say if i
just
use this condition of i equal to 1 and i
write if i equal to equal to 1 then
return let's say a test string else
return the name i'll just cut this and
put it here and we'll change this to
name this is also possible and this is
possible because of the same statement
which i told you earlier that return
statement has to be the last execution
step of your method execution in this
particular method there are two branches
of execution this is one branch and this
is the other branch at a particular time
either the if block or the else block is
going to get executed there would never
be a case that both of the blocks get
executed in the same execution cycle it
will always be either this block or this
block and that's why if you use these
kind of statements then you have to
provide return type in each of the
branches you can also do something like
this let's say if i say string return
var equal to null and then i say control
c
control v
i assign test string to the return var
and then here also i assign name string
to the return var and at the end i say a
single return and i say return var this
is also fine because here i am just
assigning different values in the if
block in the else block and then just
returning the placeholder variable which
is also absolutely fine so you can use
either of the way the better way is to
return from within the branch itself so
this was a quick tour for you to see how
methods work and what kind of anatomy
method represent now let me just quickly
revolt everything which i did here and
bring it back to return name that's good
and now let's talk about the method
calling patterns and how do we call the
methods so for that i have prepared a
class called method calling demo it has
a public static void main method and
here i have just declared a simple
variable i and initialize the value of i
as one then i am calling a method which
is named as change value and if you go
to this particular method it has a very
simple implementation it is accepting
the argument which i created here i'm
passing this particular variable as an
argument to this method and then
whatever argument i supply i'm
incrementing that argument by one and
just return
and not returning anything from here
just incrementing the value of i and
that's it and after that i'm printing i
so what would be your guess here what
would be the value here i'm gonna pause
here for a moment and to let you think
about what is going to happen okay i
hope you have you would have done some
calculations in your head to see what is
going to happen and what is the value of
i eventually at line eight let's run
this program to understand that okay so
i had initialized i as one then i passed
the value of i in this particular
argument and i said i equal to i plus 1
so it should be 1 plus 1 equal to 2 and
i the new value of i should be 2 but at
line 8 i still get i as 1. why is that
happening it's happening because of the
concept of pass by value remember that
concept that in java every argument
which you pass to a method is passed by
value and not by reference in simple
language what does it mean is that when
you pass this particular argument a copy
of this particular argument is a copy of
this particular variable is passed to
the method argument it's not the exact
same variable we are not passing the
same reference of i here we are passing
a copy of it a unique local copy of it
that's why whatever you do with i inside
this particular method is not going to
change the state of i which is defined
here because it is passed by value or
since simple language the object is
copied over locally to the method it's
not the same reference which is being
passed upon that's why you see this
value if you want to get the return
value then the one way is to just change
the return type and say return i and
then just store this return i value here
saying end result
equal to whatever is returned from here
and we are returning the new i here and
then you can print the result and you
will get 2. if i run this now i get is
2. so this is to just to validate that
this everything in java is passed by
value there is no concept of password
reference when we talk about method
calling in java let's take a more
complicated example this was a simple
variable let's go back to the
student.java so i have the student class
here let's create some objects of it and
try to follow the same pattern so here i
have created an object of the student
class named john age 25 address 23 east
california i'm doing some sis outs which
are not really important here but let me
just uncomment this particular method so
here what i'm doing is i'm calling a
method i'm basically defining a method
which says change name in the same
object and i'm supplying the student
object so the student object gets here
and then i'm overwriting the name in the
student object that's what i'm doing
here so now let's just call this
particular method and see what happens
so i'm going to call this particular
method here and pass the object john
inside it and then let's try to print
the name of the object referenced by
john if i say get name so i'm calling
this particular method passing the uh
john object here where i'm overwriting
the name john with jane and then i'm
printing the new name of the john object
let's see what happens now so if i run
this particular program yes i can see
that the name has been overwritten from
john to jane now this happened because
you passed the reference pointed to the
object inside the method and then you
overwrote the name ins
on the object which was pointed by this
particular reference so here you might
think that this is passed by reference
but this is still passed by value
because this reference is not the same
reference as this one this is a
different reference but both references
are pointing to the same object that is
the only commonality here so you can
mutate a particular object inside a
method and be very careful of that do
not ever try to do that because it is
going to create lot of unpredictable
results for you because it might be
possible that you are calling a
particular method from some other
application which is doing a lot of
changes in the same argument object
which you supplied and then you don't
know what is the state of it so it's a
very dangerous pattern and very
dangerous way to mutate the objects do
not do this let's find another way to
deal with this problem if i don't want
to mutate the same object how do i solve
that problem so we can solve that
problem simply by creating a new object
and changing whatever we want to change
so i have one more method here which
says change name in a different object
it is also accepting the student object
and then here it is creating a new
student object and here it is
overwriting the name but getting the age
and the address as the same values from
the argument so we keep the age and the
address same but we create a new name
but we don't overwrite the same object
we create a new object and then we can
return this particular new object if we
want to i can do clear this and i can
say return
new student and then i can store the
value of this particular method calling
i can call this method here supply the
same argument as
john let me comment this one and then i
can store the value of the result
student result obj
and i get the value here and then i can
say result obj.get name and if i run
this program now remember i'm calling a
different method now which is going to
create a new object and then
change the value i do get the same
effect but now my previous object john
is not touched at all it is safe and
sound i can reuse this john object
anywhere in my method in my application
and i can be assured that nothing is
changing in terms of the state of the
object so always follow this particular
pattern whenever you are calling methods
and passing arguments to the method and
if those arguments happen to be your
custom classes and even java classes in
fact then always try to create a new
copy of the object inside the method if
you intend to mutate or change the state
of the object let's get started with
today's topic which is about exceptions
in java let's first understand what are
exceptions and why do we actually need
this concept the simple reason for
having exceptions existence is that
developers make mistake we do create
bugs and errors while we write code it's
natural it always happens that whenever
you write code you might miss out some
condition or the other which creates a
bug in the application which creates a
defect in the application and then the
testing team finds that defect and then
we fix that defect and that's how a
normal software development life cycle
works so to handle those kind of
exceptions and errors every programming
language provides their own exception
and error framework to support the
developer in spotting those errors and
fixing those errors and handling those
errors instead and java also provides
its own exception framework so what you
see on the screen right now is basically
the a snapshot of the exception
framework of java and you see it has a
long hierarchy of different classes here
this is also an inheritance hierarchy
just to give you context and the whole
exception framework hierarchy starts
with a class called throwable so
throwable is is the class which is the
root or the parent class of handling all
types of exceptions and errors and
that's where the next differentiation
comes exceptions and errors java treats
these two things differently and i will
go in detail as to what is an exception
and what is an error but let's first
understand the hierarchy further under
the exception hierarchy you see some
exceptions like io exceptions which is
an exception which comes when something
goes wrong in the file writing or file
reading or the file handling operations
then you have sql exception which comes
whenever you are talking to the database
writing sql queries and something goes
wrong you also have class not found
exception which comes when a class is
not found in the in the runtime or in
the or at the time when the class is
being loaded in the jvm and then you
have also run time exceptions which are
the arithmetic number format and there
are a lot and lots more of this type of
exceptions as well on the right hand
side you have the error type and then
you have some errors like jvm error
memory error and framework error so now
coming to the differentiation between
exception and error exception is a type
of problem which
can be recovered in a program from which
the program can be recovered which the
developers should handle so exception is
a type where the developer focus is the
developer is responsible to make sure
that none of these exceptions occur in
the program and if these exceptions
occur in the program then the developer
has the responsibility to handle these
exceptions properly we will look at the
examples of how the developer can handle
these exceptions on the right hand side
is the error type where the developer
does not have any control you cannot do
anything if the jvm has an error or if
the underlying memory of the computer or
the jvm memory gets an error or the the
whole framework or the java itself
library itself has an error you can't do
anything about that and those are the
kind of problems which go into the
category of error that's why java has
created these two different categories
one is exceptions which is the
responsibility of the developer and
other is error which are not the
responsibility of the developer and in
fact developer cannot do anything if
this happens
so this was a quick tour to you to what
kind of the exception framework is
present in java do read about this
framework in detail in the java docs as
well but just to extend this
understanding further we'll have a look
at some examples of the exceptions and
how these exceptions occur so with that
i'm going to switch to the eclipse ide
and i have created bunch of classes to
show different types of exceptions so
let's go through the first class which
is named
simple exception demo it has a main
method it has a variable of int type the
variable name is data and what i'm doing
here is i'm dividing 100 by zero so if
you see this carefully you know that
this is going to result in an infinite
value you cannot divide any number by
zero and java also prohibits doing the
same because it doesn't make sense to
divide anything by zero so if you run
this particular line if you execute this
particular line this is going to throw a
runtime exception these are the runtime
exceptions remember so let's try to
comment rest of the code and let's
quickly try to run this so i run this
program and there you go i get an
exception which says exception in the
thread main main is the main thread with
the exception type is
java.lang.arithmeticexception
and this is the exception type divide by
zero and it will also give you the line
number at which the exception happens if
you click on this it will directly take
you to the exact line at which the
exception happened and this is you know
if you see now this helps the developer
a lot this
information which is printed here is
called exception stack trace and you can
look at the stack trace go to the last
line and this would be the line from
where the exception actually originated
if you click on that particular line it
will take you exactly at the place where
the exception might have occurred and
then you can look at the line fix the
code and rerun the program to see if the
exception is gone that's why i said that
developer has to handle this exception
now as far as handling these exceptions
is concerned i am going to cover that in
the next session but in the in this
particular session we are just going to
focus on the types of exceptions and how
they occur this was an example of
arithmetic exception where we are trying
to divide something by zero let's take
another example let me uncomment this
particular line of code and comment back
this one so here i am creating a string
a but the string is null and null means
nothing it's it's a it's a void
reference it has nothing in it and now
if i try to do some operation on this
particular string so remember a is null
and whenever you are trying to operate
something on a null object java is going
to throw an exception because you can't
operate on null because null means
nothing empty it is it is a dummy thing
so you cannot do anything on this
particular null reference and if i run
this program i get an exception which
says null pointer exception
java.lang.nullpointerexception
and it will give you the exact reason
cannot invoke string dot care at int
string dot this is a string type string
dot care at int because a is null so it
will give you the exact reason as to why
this program failed and then again if
you click on this particular line it
will take you the exact line where the
problem is and then you can fix the
problem maybe you need to initialize the
string properly to make sure that this
error doesn't occur so these are all the
runtime exceptions which the developer
has to take care of which the developer
has to fix
to make sure that the program runs
smoothly if they don't handle it the
program is going to fail and the program
will actually force them to fix because
the program will not run unless they fix
those exceptions now these are the
examples of runtime exceptions you can
also create these kind of exceptions
which are called checked exceptions
runtime exceptions are also called
unchecked exceptions you might hear this
term as well some some people use the
term runtime exception instead of
unchecked exception and use both of them
interchangeably so runtime exceptions
are also called unchecked exceptions and
these exceptions are called checked
exceptions why do we call them checked
and unchecked is because
these exceptions are something which you
do not have to explicitly specify in
your program in this program i did not
have to explicitly specify this
particular because i don't know if this
line of code is going to result into a
null pointer exception or not but these
exceptions are something which java will
force you to handle let's look at an
example of this so i have created one
more class which is named as checked
exception demo and i'm doing some file
operations basically reading a file
writing to a file etc i'm using some
classes of java named as file reader and
some methods like read line and close
and if you see the moment i'm trying to
read a file this line has a
has a red marker there's a compilation
error if you scroll over it it says
unhandled exception type file not found
exception so java is forcing you to
handle this error this particular
exception because file not found is a
checked exception so if your expression
urine of code is throwing a checked
exception then java will force you to do
something about it it will not compile
the code until you either handle this
exception or you re-throw this exception
again how do we handle this something
which we will cover in the next session
but you can you can always re-throw this
exception but you have to do something
about it you cannot just skip it so i
can do if i don't want to handle this is
i will pass on the responsibility of
handling this exception to the callee
program so whoever is going to call this
method has the responsibility now to
handle the file not found exception
because i have just thrown it i've just
passed it on i've just passed my
responsibility to the colleague and you
can do similar thing here as well if i
go here you see it says unhandled type
exception i o exception and if you
remember i exception is here it is a
checked exception so i can do one more
throws here comma v and
now if i just resolve the import whoever
is calling the main method has the
responsibility of handling the file not
found or i exception you can also handle
it like i said or you can just add
throws clause to the method signature
and then the caller has the
responsibility to fix or handle the
exception so this is how the checked
exceptions work remember in the
unchecked exception in the runtime
exception
we we can see that these two lines do
throw exceptions but there is no
forced way by java to tell us that i
have to fix it because java doesn't care
about unchecked exceptions at the
compile time it will only encounter
those runtime exceptions at the run time
that's why they are called runtime
exceptions but checked exceptions are
compile time exceptions and you have to
fix them handle them or throw them right
at the time of compiling the code so
that was about checked exception now
there's also a possibility that you can
create your own exception if you want to
so for that i've just created a very
simple class here called my exception
and the way you create your own custom
exception is by just extending your
class with exception class you just
write this extends exception and you can
write a default constructor or a
parameterized constructor whichever
makes sense for you and this is your
exception class ready to use
and you can just invoke this exception
explicitly remember whenever you are
creating your custom exception it is by
default a check exception so your
program has to handle it for example if
i go back to this particular class and
if i do this let me just comment all of
this code now and remove the throws
clause as well so if i go here
and i'm saying
throw new my exception my exception was
my class so i'm explicitly throwing an
exception which was my custom exception
and i again get the error if i hover
over it it says unhandled exception type
my exception so i have to handle this
exception or i can just throw this
exception and
let the caller handle it so this also
works so this basically builds our
understanding that broadly there are
three different types of exceptions
which we work with there is a runtime
exception which is also called unchecked
exception which happens because of
developers mistakes in the program like
this one then there is a checked
exception
which developer might not be responsible
for creating the exception but developer
has to handle it and there are some
classes in java which throw those
checked exceptions like file not found
exception and ioexception whenever you
are working with file handling
operations java will force you to handle
those checked exceptions or rethrow
those checked exceptions using the
throws clause similarly the third type
is when you create your custom exception
type and custom exception types are also
checked exceptions by default and
whenever you are explicitly throwing
your own custom exceptions you again
have to either handle the exception
within your enclosing code or you can
just re-throw the exception and let the
caller handle it so this is a quick tour
of different types of exception and
including this exception hierarchy let's
get started with exception handling in
java using try and catch blocks so in
the previous session we had a look at
the scenarios where an exception can
occur how do we see that there's a
runtime exception or there's a checked
exception or there's an unchecked
exception or there is a custom exception
now
we did not talk about how to handle
those exceptions
and now we are going to focus on the
handling part
so whenever you have to handle those
exceptions
the way java provides for that is using
the try catch block
so try catch block is basically a bunch
of syntax which you have to follow to
handle different types of exceptions in
your programming code
and the syntax of the try catch block is
pretty straightforward
you
write try and you put curly braces
and then you write whatever code
which might
throw an exception you don't know that
but it's always safer to enclose your
code in a try catch block so that you
know that if an exception occurs in the
try block
then you can handle it in the catch
block
so it's a it's always considered a
better practice to enclose your
application code in a try catch block so
that you can handle the exceptions
so you put this try block
and write write all the suspicious or
non-suspicious code which may or may not
throw an exception inside the try block
once you have done the dry block part
then comes the catch block part
so let me go to the catch block
so this is how the syntax look like once
you have written the try block then you
write catch and you put braces
and you write the exception type
which this block of code might throw or
the exception type which you are
interested in catching
you might not be interested in catching
all the different exceptions but only a
few ones based on your business
requirements so whatever exception type
you want to catch
you are going to catch it like this
and if an exception occurs in the tri
code let's say you have specified an
arithmetic exception here and if
any line of code in the try block throws
an arithmetic exception
then this catch block is going to catch
that exception and then inside these
curly braces you can decide what to do
with that exception
whether you want to lock that exception
or whether you want to re-throw that
exception whether you want to
embed some error code or get an error
code out of it or convert that exception
into a business or custom exception of
your own choice so it's up to you what
you want to do with that but catch block
will be able to catch that arithmetic
exception
similarly you can specify as many
exception types to be caught as you want
and keep adding more and more catch
blocks
remember that these catch blocks work in
a in a sequential fashion
so if an exception occurs here it will
first go to this particular block to
match the exception type
if it didn't match then only it will
move to the second type
if it did match the first type it is not
going to execute the second type so that
is how the try catch block work
you can see an example here that if the
code here is throwing an index out of
bond exception then it is going to be
caught here
and we are just printing the index out
of one exceptions message
if it is throwing an i o exception then
i can do this so you can keep adding
different checked and unchecked
exceptions in the catch block
you can also catch more than one type of
exception with one exception handler so
rather than writing these multiple catch
blocks individually you can combine
these exceptions together if your
logic of processing
both of these exceptions is the same
remember if the logic of processing
these two exceptions is the same
logic means whatever you write inside
these curly braces
so if that code is going to be the same
for both of these exceptions then why
bother writing two catch blocks
just write one catch block like this
use the pipe operator to separate
different types of exceptions and write
the common code which is going to be
applied
if your try block is going to through an
io exception or an sql exception
so that depends upon you
that's the second piece
the third piece of the try block is the
final block so we talked about the try
block we talked about the catch block
now there's a finally block as well
remember this is finally and not final
the finally block is used
together with the try catch block
when you want to perform some cleanup
operations
imagine you are opening up a file
handler
in the try block you're doing something
with it and then you want to just
close the file handler irrespective of
the fact if there was an exception in
the try block or not because even if
there was an exception the file handler
resource is going to remain open and is
going to consume memory in your
application you might you don't want to
do that similarly if you opened a
database connection inside your try
block
irrespective of the fact of what happens
in the try block you always would like
to close the database connection and you
can write that closing code in the
finally block that's the purpose of the
finally block that you can write the
code
inside the finally block which is
supposed to be always executed
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurs or doesn't occur
so now we have built a good
understanding of what is the try catch
what is what is the try block catch
block and the final block now if you
just put it all together
this is how it is going to look like
that you write the try block you do
something inside the try block
then you write the catch blocks
after that you write the final block you
can write the finely block without the
catch block as well remember that if you
do not have any exception to catch but
you have some resources to close or free
up after executing the try block you can
skip the catch block and just right try
finally that is also possible
with that understanding let's switch to
the ide and let's look at some example
so i have a writer helper class
which is having a method called write
list i have a try block here
and
this try block is basically initializing
an error list
adding an item to the error list
and then i'm accessing list dot get one
remember when i added this particular
value let me make it tend to make it
more understandable when i added 10 to
this particular list this goes to the
index zero position
and here i'm trying to access index one
position
which does not have anything
so in such case it might throw an error
because there is nothing at least not
get one so this is my method where i put
the try block code and then because
i don't want to end up in a position
where i get an index out of bond
exception index out of bonds exception
comes if you are trying to access an
index
which is illegal which is does not
having any value so i'm putting a catch
block and catching the index out of
bound exception and just printing the
message of the exception
and then i'm for just for simplicity i'm
showing a final block as well though i
do not have any resource to close here
but this just to show you how this looks
like in the code
this is just to show you that i'm
putting i'm printing assist out here
this is what my method is and if i go to
the main class
the try catch demo class
i'm creating an object of the
writerhelper class and calling the
writelist method which we just walked
through
let's run this program and see what
happens
okay so first get the statement saying
entering try statement so you go here
i call this method the execution goes
inside the try block and i get the cis
out which says entering try statement
then i try to access the second
element in the list because the position
is one this is going to index 0 and i'm
trying to access index 1 there is
nothing at index 1 so i get an error
saying index out of bounds exception
index 1 out of bounds for length 1
because the total length of the list
currently is 1 because there's just one
element and that one element is sitting
at zero and not one
so i get the exception
which is the index outer bound exception
but the index outer bond exception is
caught by my catch block
and the system dot error dot quintellen
is something which gets executed
and get this particular
line this particular line
from
this
line number 17
and then irrespective of the fact
whether an exception occurred or not my
final block always gets executed
let's fix this and see if the final
block gets executed even if there is no
exception so now i'm accessing get zero
and let's see what happens
yep i access the element 10 no exception
but the final block still gets executed
so this is to assert our understanding
that the final block will always be
executed irrespective of the fact
whether there was an exception or there
wasn't
now you can also nest different try
blocks if you want to
let's look at an example where i have
multiple try blocks so you can initial
you can write a try within a try within
a try if you want and you can go as deep
as you want but remember the more
indentations the more hierarchy you
create the program is going to get more
and more complex so always remember
to have that kind of trade-off
so i write multiple try blocks i
initialize an array i print
added 10 obviously edit 10 does not
exist because this array has just four
elements so this is bound to through an
index out of bound exception and i'm
catching that exception immediately in
the catch block this is the exception
printing assist out and just re-throwing
the exception you can also read through
the exception by just using the throw
keyword
remember this throw is different from
the throws keyword which comes in the
method signature this is just to throw
any exception from your code
so this is array index outer bond
exception for this try block
then i have another array index outer
bond exception for this try block
which starts from here block 2 and then
i have another catch block for the block
one try block
so you can see it is already getting a
bit complicated where i have multiple
hierarchies but you can do that
so this is what is happening in this
particular program now let's try to run
this and see what happens and try to
decipher the output
okay so at first i get this particular
line which says
array index out of bounds exception in
block 3.
what happens here is that this line gets
executed
it throws an array index out of bounds
exception
at line 13 that array index out of
bounds exception is caught which was
generated from this line
and then we go inside the catch block
we execute this is out this is what you
see here the same sysout and then we
re-throw the exception
if we re-throw the exception
the exception goes to the
enclosing try block the enclosing try
block is this one
there was an exception rethrown from
this try block and now it has gone to
this try block
and now
this try block block 2 will try to see
if it can catch this array index out of
bound exception
yes we can catch it
so it can so so the block 2 again has a
catch block which catches the array
index out of bound and it prints assist
out here which says exception in block 2
which we see here
and it again rethrows the exception
and if it rethrows the exception so now
the block 2
now the block 2 is re-throwing the
exception so this whole code
is now re-throwing the exception
if this block two is re-throwing the
exception it goes to block one
just going one hierarchy up
and then it sees if it can handle the
exception in the catch block
of this block one so yes the block one
try block also had a catch exception
which said array index out of bound e4
and here it just had a sis out
so if i just bring back the output
yes we do get this a particular
exception printed here which says array
index out of bounds exception in block
one this is what you see here
and this is where the exception just
stops going propagated because i'm not
re-throwing the exception from this
particular catch block so that's where
the exception ends the reason you see a
hyperlink here is because the text
the text which i have printed here
exactly matches with the name of the
exception
so java is pretty smart in that case if
you use the exact same name exception it
will link it to the matching class name
in java which is pretty cool
i also have a redundant cache block here
which does not have a try block this is
just to show you that you can write a
catch block without a try block but it
doesn't make sense it is of no use so i
can just remove this particular catch
block and the program still will compile
fine
so this was a quick demo to show you how
you can use try catch and finally blocks
and when would you use the finally block
and if you want you can use a nested
hierarchy of try blocks and you can
rethrow
the exception from within the catch
block only to be caught in the outside
or the outer or the enclosing block so
this is all i want to cover in this
particular session let's get started
with equals and hash code in java
this is probably one of the most
important and interesting concept in
java and extremely extremely popular
when it comes to java interview
questions
so let's cover this in detail
to understand why we need equals and
hash code and what equals and hash code
is all about let's first understand the
object class of java remember i am
calling it an object class and not just
an object
object is a class as well in java and it
is the super super class of any class
you create in java so anything you do in
java any class you create it will
automatically be inherited by the object
class
object class is the super class of any
class created in java
and if you look at this documentation
and if you come here you will see that
object class
defines this equals method which
indicates whether some
other object is equal to this one or not
and it also
defines a hash code method which returns
a hash code value for the object
so let's understand both of them one by
one
first of all let's establish that this
these methods have their concrete
implementations
available inside the object class
but how do you do that and how do we how
does it come into effect
remember when we talked about hash set
and i said that hash set will maintain
uniqueness automatically
how does it maintain uniqueness
automatically
it is because of the equals method
implementation which it inherits from
the
object class
that's how it maintains uniqueness
and if you remember i also told that
you can do
you you can maintain uniqueness in a
hash set if it's a built-in data type
like integer or string or float or
double etc
but what if you are trying to create a
hash set of student objects
then java does not know how to perform
equality on two student objects because
student is a custom object java doesn't
know how to run equality and that's
where equals and hash code comes into
picture
so the contract is that whenever you are
creating your own custom objects
and you have a need
to perform equality on those objects
you must override the equals method in
your own class
you have to overwrite that if you do not
override that
then two student objects will be
compared based on the reference and not
based on the actual object values
we will see all of that with the help of
an example
another thing which says that whenever
you are overriding equals
you should also override hash code
method reason is because hashcode is
also used in certain collections and we
will cover that in a while but let's
just focus on equals first
and let me switch back to the eclipse
ide
where i have a student class
again it's a very familiar class which
we have covered in other lectures as
well
and i have three different properties
here role number name and address
i have a constructor and i have setters
and getters
now if i go here and i create three
different
objects of the student class
you see i have created three different
objects
this student object has a role number
one named john and the address is the
same one
second object has a roll number two
and the name john
and the address is the same as this one
and third one again has a different role
number but the name and address is the
same it's a hypothetical situation
so let's do one thing let's make this
roll number as one as well so now these
two student objects are exactly
identical
so what happens if i compare john with
john 2.
by looking at naked eyes these two
objects look exactly the same so john
equals john 2 should return true
let's run this program
but we get false
the reason we get false is because the
default implementation of equals is
being run
on the on comparing the student objects
because java still does not know how to
equate these two objects why you are
getting false because these two are
different references java created a new
memory location somewhere and put this
object created a reference drawn to it
then java created one more new object in
this line and created a new reference
john 2. so these two
different references are pointing to two
different memory locations of the
objects though their internal values are
same but their memory locations are
different
that's why you get this particular value
as false because these are pointing to
different memory locations and that
brings me to the hashcode contract
you need to
override the hashcode contract as well
along with the equals to make sure that
your equality runs perfectly
let's go back to the student class and
let's fix this problem because we can
see that these are identical objects you
don't want to store the same student
twice in your database right
so you need to fix this
so i go back to the student.java
and i have commented this equals method
and let me uncomment this now
so what i do that i override
the equals method
and the equals method contract looks
like this where you supply an object
which is an which is a foreign object
and now you need to compare this foreign
object with your current object of the
student class which is this
so at first you need to run this
particular condition which says are
these two objects
these two references that this reference
and the obj reference pointing to the
same object
if they're pointing to the same object
then
this will return true and then we will
say that the object is that that
equality holds true because both are
pointing to the same object so obj
equals this
if that doesn't hold true if this
doesn't hold true then it moves on to
line 50 and it runs a condition saying
that
is obj null or obj dot get class is not
equal to this dot get class
get class is a method which will tell
you the class type
here we are checking is the obj class
object is of the type student or not
if it's of different type let's say
vehicle or something then then
definitely they will not be equal and we
can directly return false so that's why
i'm checking that it should not be null
or the class types should be matching
if these two conditions are if either of
these conditions are holding true then i
return false and i say that objects are
not equal so i've covered this condition
where both of the references are
pointing to the same object
i covered this condition where the class
types were not matching or the obj
itself was null
then then we returned false
if we passed all of these sanity checks
then we do the actual comparison
before doing the actual comparison i
need to do this explicit casting so i
cast the obj object into the student
type if you remember that's it this is
how we did this this the casting for
other data types as well
once you have converted this obj into
the student object
then you need to define your own
business logic based on which you are
going to define uniqueness
so how are you going to uniquely
identify a student in your application
will govern this logic
in this particular example i'm saying
that i am going to identify a unique
student based on its role number
so even if two students have exact same
matching details but if their role
numbers are different
then these are two different objects for
me but if two objects have are having
the same roll number and even if they
have a different name and address i am
going to say that those two objects are
duplicate so roll number is the is the
condition on which i'm defining
uniqueness equality and duplicity
so i define this and say if the roll
numbers are equal then the object is
equal objects are same basically or
duplicate and if the roll numbers are
different then these two are different
objects
good so far coming back to the main
class
so now i have the same roll number here
let me change the name just for fun and
address as well
so i have a different name and a
different address but the roll number is
exactly the same
remember we have defined the equality
condition based on the roll number
and here we are comparing if john is
equal to john 2 or not
so let's run this program
now i get true the reason i get true is
because this equals method is is used
to run this equals comparison
so this establishes how we can use the
equals contract to maintain uniqueness
now i also said that whenever you have
you are defining the equals method you
also have to override the hashcode
method
and to understand why do we need
hashcode as well let's go back to how
hashmap works
remember in the hashmap or let's say
even hashset in the asset you have to
maintain uniqueness now java maintains
uniqueness using both equals and hash
code
hashcode is nothing but a memory bucket
in the in java's memory where your
object is stored it's basically a memory
location so every object has a hash code
and that hash code is the actual memory
footprint where the object is stored
and whenever you are dealing with hash
set or hash maps you will be required to
override both of these methods
let's understand how this works
so if you have a hash set and you are
trying to insert an element then first
java will use your equals method
definition to check if an object similar
to the object being inserted is already
present in the hash set or not
if it finds an object it will basically
flag that this is a duplicate object and
it will not insert it
let's understand how an object is
fetched from hash set
let me open a hashtag example
just to
give you some sort of a visual
representation of what i'm talking about
so if i go to my hash set example in
in the collections package somewhere
and let's open a hash set demo plus yeah
so when we were doing these insertions
though this is this was a string object
so it was the java already knew how to
use the equals and hash code of it but
if it was a student object and you were
doing multiple
ad and then when you were actually
fetching the element
or you were doing that contains
then how does it work is basically first
it is going to calculate the hash code
of the object let's say you was you are
saying hashtag dot get b or hashtag dot
get john 1 then it is going to calculate
the hash code
of your john 1 object
hashcode is a memory footprint and
hashcode and the way it is going to
calculate the hashcode is going to be
based on the definition which you have
provided
so the definition which you have
provided this hash code will be run to
calculate the memory footprint
and then that particular memory for java
will go to that particular memory
footprint and see
if there is an object present there or
not
now java has a memory location right and
there can be multiple objects stored at
that particular memory location this is
possible in java so if there are
multiple objects present in that
particular memory location which was
calculated based on your hashcode
implementation
then java is going to run the equals
method to find the exact matching object
so just to try to visualize this if i
try to visualize this let's say you have
this memory locations
and let's say your hash code came up to
memory location two
and then at two memory location
you had multiple objects obj one
obj2
3 etc this is possible
multiple objects can point to the same
memory location so if this happens then
java is going to use the equals contract
to compare your john 1 object with obj 1
with obj 2 and with obj3
this is where the equals will come into
use so you see the both hash code and
equals are being used here to
point to the right memory location and
that's why i said that hash set and hash
maps are where equals and hash code will
come in full force where you will be
required to implement this and it's a
good practice to always override the
equals and hash code in your application
whenever you are creating classes the
reason is that you don't know when and
where these classes will be stored into
a hash set collection or a hash map
collection so it's always a good idea to
have equals and hash code being
implemented and when you implement hash
code the rule the thumb rule is that you
should use the same parameters which
have been used in the equals contract
in the hash code contract as well
the reason for that is what if you used
here let's say you use name here and you
used roll number here then two different
properties are being used to
find memory location and uni and the
uniqueness
and remember
this logic which i just gave you here
both hash code and equals are working
together to find the right object so if
you are going if you make any mistakes
in defining the equals and hash code or
if you made any mistake in defining the
symmetry
between equals and hash code then you
may get unpredictable results
how you define your hash code
up to you but make sure to use the same
properties which you have used to define
the equality always keep this consistent
to avoid any unexpected results
you can also do this just say return one
and every and what happens what will
happen that when you use this particular
student class in a hash set all the
objects are going to be stored at a
single memory location
and then this particular situation will
occur where you will have a single
memory location and all of your objects
will be present at that memory location
and when you are trying to fetch
anything
the hash code will always point to the
same memory location and then equals
will make sure to find out the right
object you are trying to fetch from the
hash set
so this is all about equals and hash
code which i wanted to cover in this
particular lecture do read about this in
detail there are tons of articles
available on this particular concept
because this is a very important and
popular concept both from implementation
perspective and from interview
perspective and that's all we are going
to cover in this particular session
let's get started with comparable in
java and before we go there let's
understand why do we need comparable the
need for comparable comes from the
requirement whenever you have to sort
your collections
so to understand that let's move over to
the java docs to understand how this
works
so the basic idea is that you want to
sort your collection
and to do that java provides you with a
method called collections.sort
you just provide you just supply your
list or your collection inside the sort
method and all the elements or objects
inside your collection will be sorted
based on the natural sorted ordering
this holds true for built-in data types
but what if your list is of type student
objects then again the same constraint
applies that java does not know how to
sort student objects it knows how to
sort strings and ins and floats and
doubles because those are built-in data
types but student is a custom type and
java doesn't know how to sort it
and to solve that problem java provides
an interface
called comparable
so comparable is the interface which you
need to
implement
from your class
whenever you have a need
to sort your objects or of your class
type
so this is the interface which your
class needs to implement
this interface provides a single method
which says compare to
and it provides the foreign object and
then you need to compare this foreign
object with your current object
so let's go back to the java class and
understand how do we work with this
comparable interface
so again i have used the student class
for the sake of continuity and i have
the same properties as role number name
and age but this time i say implements
comparable of type student this is a
generics type we are we will be covering
generics in a bit more detail in this
whole in this whole series but the basic
idea is that you define that this
comparable interface will only work for
student types
to define the type in this particular
construct which we also call a generic
type
so you do this and the moment you do
this java will force you to provide the
implementation of the comparative method
which i have provided here
so the way this
implementation works is
you have a foreign object here but this
time this foreign object since i have
defined this as of type student so if
you the moment you do this
java will ask you to override this
method and using eclipse ide
if you overwrite this
then you will get this signature
automatically
let me show you this how this works
so if you do this you will get an error
here and if you click on this balloon it
will say add unimplemented methods if
you double click on this
you will see a comparative
implementation here
and this is exactly the skeleton which
you see here by default it says return 0
but i'll just come back to that in a
while
so this is how this method came up here
and once you have the signature
available then you need to provide your
implementation on how do you want to
sort the objects
remember you need to define your your
logic here so again i would like to sort
my students based on the role number
which is the natural sorting order for
me for the student objects so this is
your custom
sorting logic which you which you can
call as natural custom logic sorting
order for your student objects so i want
to sort them based on roll number but
you see i've done a strange thing here
i've done a minus here so what i'm doing
is that the current objects roll number
minus the foreign object's
roll number
so if this value
comes as a positive number then this
this object is going to take priority
this is going to be sitting before the
student
if this result returns in a negative
value then this object will come first
and
this will come second so the student
object will come first and this object
the current object will come second
and if this returns zero then it means
both of the objects deserve the same
priority or the same order priority and
any one of them can come after the other
so the basic idea is that if this return
if this results in greater than zero
then the current object
is going to take precedence
if this is going to be a negative value
then the foreign object which you are
supplying here is going to take
precedence and if this returns in zero
then any one of them can take precedence
so you need to define your compare to
logic in the compared to override
implementation
once you have done that let's understand
this with the help of an example i've
created a comparable demo class which
has a public static void main method and
i create an error list and i create
three different student objects
first student object is named as john
second is jane and third is tom
the first has a roll number of three
so john has a three roll number of three
jane has a roll number of one
and tom has a roll number two
so if my compared to logic runs
perfectly then jane should be coming
first after after i sort this collection
after i add these three elements into
list and once i sort this collection
then jane should come first
tom should come second and john from
third
based on my natural ordering custom
logic which i have implemented in the
compareto method
and that's what i'm doing here
after i've sorted the list i'm just
printing the list
by using the for each construct streams
api
i'm just printing the name to see which
one comes first and which one comes
second
so let's run this program
and this is how it looks like so jane
comes first because she had a roll
number one
don tom came second because he had a
roll number two and john came third
because
his roll number was
three so no matter how many times you
run this program you are going to get
the collection in the same sorted
sequence and this is happening because
of the compared to implementation which
you provided here
now
if you
comment this implementation
let's see what happens and i remove this
implements comparable as well from here
i just create a simple student class and
now i try to run the sort
now you see that you get an error here
and if you hover over this balloon it
says that the method sort in the type
collection is not applicable to the
argument array list of student
java does not know how to sort this so
it will force you to provide a sorted
implementation
and the moment you provide comparable
implementation here
and if you go back to the main class the
error is gone
so this also will force you to provide
your comparable implementation
now you can use this sorting for any
kind of collection sorting as well and
whenever you are doing this always make
sure to provide the compare to
implementation and remember that
contract which i gave you about greater
than 0 less than 0 and equal and that's
all i'm going to cover in this
particular session let's get started
with comparators in java in the previous
session we talked about comparable
where we said that whenever we want to
implement a naturally occurring sorting
order where you just say collection.sort
and you sit back and relax
if you have provided they compare to
implementation you would expect things
to work
but what if you have a custom sorting
requirement
let's take a hypothetical scenario where
you created an application
and your application has a student
object and you created a collection of
student objects
and now you have different consumer
applications let's say you have a
payroll application you have a
attendance system you have an
examination system you have another
extracurricular activity system
and all of them want to get the student
collection but all of them have
different sorting requirements
payroll wants to have the sorting based
on the roll number
attendants want to have the sorting on
some other mechanism extracurricular
application want to have the sorting on
some other mechanism
so how do you implement custom sorting
or multiple sorting logics
for your collection
and that's where comparators comes into
picture
comparator is again an interface as you
can see here in the signature
and this interface provides you the
flexibility to define your own
custom sorting logic multiple times so
you can create multiple comparator
implementations and each comparator
implementation will focus on a
particular sorting order
so that's that's the basic need of
sorting so remember whenever you want to
sort the object in an order other than
natural ordering or ordering or you want
to sort some object that don't implement
comparable so whenever you have these
kind of conditions always think of
comparator
apart from that always think of
comparator when you have to provide
multiple sorting implementations on the
same collection
so let's see how can we do that with the
help of an example
so here again i have the same student
class
and i have the same properties
currently by default i have provided a
comparable student implementation which
is exactly the same as we covered last
in the last session and
if we use this particular implementation
you we create an arraylist we created
multiple student objects
we added them to the list and we called
sort
so what happens if i just comment the
new code and if i just run this
particular code
remember the sorting is happening on the
roll number
so here roll number one jane will come
first roll number two tom will come
second and roll number 3 john will come
third
but then you had one more application
which wanted to have the sorting based
on the age of the student so these are
the age values of the students and some
application wants you to provide the
sorting implementation for the age now
age is a custom sorting logic which you
need to provide and whenever you have
that kind of situation
create a comparator
how do you create a comparator
like this simply create a class
name your comparator anything
try to end it with a suffix comparator
so that you know that this is a
comparator implementation and then you
say implements comparator of
the class type
this is what you need to do and the
moment you need to you do this it will
force you to
override this compare method
remember
the comparable interface
provided compare two method
where you supplied the just the foreign
object
it its name was compared to
with single object
in comparator the name is just compare
and you have two objects here student
one and student two let me just call
them student one and student two for
simplicity
one and o two look a bit weird
so i've just refactored this one and i
will refactor this one as well
so i have student 1 and student 2
and this is an age comparator so i want
to apply the sorting logic based on age
simply put whoever has whoever is
younger should come first and whoever is
older should come later in the
collection once i sort it
so let's see how this sorting logic is
implemented
this is a single line code so let me
just put braces around it so that it's
more easily readable you can write it
without braces as well if you have a
single statement inside the if block or
else block
but you can always write it like this
and let me just
format this as well
okay so this is the compare
implementation the first logic which i
have run is saying which says that if
the first student's age is less than the
second student's age
then return minus 1.
similarly
if the first student's age
is greater than the second student age
then return plus 1
and if both of the students age are same
then return 0.
so this is your custom logic and this is
where you need to define your logic and
remember this will also govern whether
the sorting is going to be ascending or
descending
so for example if you have provided that
student
once age is less than student two's age
then return minus one then this is going
to maintain the natural sorting or the
ascending order sorting
now if you want to have a descending
order sorting
just change these values saying that if
this is less then return
1 and if it is greater then return minus
1 and this is going to run the sorting
in a descending order fashion now so it
depends upon what kind of sorting order
you want and based on that you can
define the values but the default is
always like this that whenever the first
object's value is less than the second
object value
return minus one
and if the first object's value is
greater than the second object's value
then return plus one otherwise return
zero
minus one means this one this one will
get precedence over this one
so this is how you have provided your
age comparator
going back to the main class and
uncommenting the other part of the code
here i have called the sort method where
i want to sort the list
but since i want to supply a custom
sorting operator or a custom sorting
comparator here
i need to
provide that comparator object here
so remember the age comparator which you
created here you just need to provide
the comparator you need to tell java
how to sort this particular list
if you do not tell java how to sort this
java is going to look for the comparable
implementation in the student class
and it will sort the student objects
based on the compare to implementation
provided inside the student class
but if you want to have more custom
control over sorting
then you need to tell java how to
do that sorting and if you see this is
an overloaded representation this is a
method overloading example as well where
the method signature is same but just
the number of arguments are different so
this is how you provide your custom
sorting you supply your comparator now
you can create multiple comparators you
can com create another comparator based
on let's say name you can add one have
one more property here create one more
comparator so you can have as many
comparators as you want just keep
creating them and keep supplying them
individually one by one in the sort
method you can just duplicate this
and add one more comparator
so this is how you are going to have
more control and if you have multiple
consumer application
call multiple sort methods supply their
corresponding comparator and you will
get the sorted collection
so here i am just printing the list
based on the age comparator sorting
and these are the objects so let's see
how this works
and understand the output from the
beginning so the natural sorting order
is something which we have already
covered
which was done based on the roll numbers
so jane comes first
tom comes second and john comes third
and this is how you get this this
particular output
now coming to the age comparator you pre
you print this particular statement
which is coming here
and then you print these values
so let's see how the edge comparator is
working
the youngest here is john so john comes
first then we have tom who is 20 years
old so tom comes here and then we have
jane
who is 21 years old and jane comes in
the last
so we can see that our age comparator
has fired here and it has sorted this in
an ascending order
now let's flip the values
i'm going to change the values here
and now it should work in a descending
sorting order for the age comparator
so let's run this application again and
now you see jane comes first
who is 21
then tom comes who is 20 and then john
comes who is 18. so now the age
comparator is working in a descending
order
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to have a look at a
project which will cover all the
concepts which we have talked about so
far let's get started with walking
through a particular project
using all the concepts which we have
learned so far
so in this session we are going to focus
on a particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application so you might
have interacted with different atm
stores in your cities where you go in
you insert your card you enter your pin
and then you can view the balance you
can withdraw some amount you can also
deposit some amount from the atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and and we will see what
kind of different
uh java and oops concepts we can use to
build such atm application
this is not a super versatile
application but this is just to give you
the idea of how to use
those oops concepts to build a simple or
a complex java application so let's
start from the options menu class
because that will give us the
understanding of what kind of
functionality i am using
and here you will use that
i am using different concepts which i
have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the iu
exception we are using the hashmap class
we are also using a scanner class which
is used to take input from the command
line
so this option menu class is extending
the account class and i will come to the
account class in a while but let's see
what this option menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of
format of money you have
then we have a hash map which is storing
the couple of uh records of account
number to pin mapping
so we create an map and inside the get
login method
we add couple of entries to the map
here the first entry the first integer
is pointing to the customer number
and the second integer is pointing to
the pin of the account of this
particular customer number
so
if we call the get login method this
method will insert the data
after that it will ask the customer to
enter the customer number which has to
be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever a customer number the
customer inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that
and once we have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping so whatever customer number you
select from here
you will be providing the corresponding
pin number and again if you provide an
invalid pin number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and
if you enter any invalid characters in
the pin number or the atm
customer number then you will get an
exception which i am writing inside the
catch block
this is all what we have seen so far
after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number i
fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing and again i'm
doing some basic validation checks but
things get interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here so we covered the get login method
the second method which is defined in
this particular class is the account
type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number we will ask
the customer to provide the account type
type this application supports two
different types which are checking
account or a savings account
so whatever so the customer has to
choose one of them again we will be
taking the input from the command line
using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case
if the customer entered 1 then i will
execute some code for the checking
account which is defined here in the
case 1
and if the customer entered 2 then the
case two will be executed
and if the if it enters three then i
will exit the application by just
printing assist out
so here i'm using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there's also a default specified here
which says invalid choice so this is
what is happening in the get account
type method
the next method is if the customer has
used the option one
then we call the get checking method
so let's go to the get checking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class so if
the customer has selected a checking
account then we provide the following
functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account or they can just exit
the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types 1 2 3 or 4
the corresponding case block will be
executed for example if the customer
wants to view the balance then this
block will get executed and i call the
get account type method
if the customer selects the
to as the withdraw fund then get
checkings with withdraw input method
gets called
and then get account type gets called
similarly if the customer enters three
then we deposit the fund and for that
also i have defined a method i will go
to the definition of these methods as we
go along but right now we are just
building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called whenever the customer
selects the option three
and for option four we just exit the
application
so this what is happening in the get
checking method
now if from the account selection if the
customer selected second option which
was savings account then we were calling
get saving method so this is where the
get saving method is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method
where we present the following options
like viewing balance withdrawing the
funds and depositing the funds in the
savings account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving withdraw input
get saving deposit input
so we define the switch case here based
on the customer's choices here
and that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
login method
then based on
that we provide
the customer the options to choose the
account type whether they can choose the
savings account or the checking account
and based on that
whatever account type they use we call
the get checking or get saving method
and inside this method we provide the
customer the other options to either
withdraw the money deposit the money or
view the balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class
you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now
so this is the account class where i
have defined some private member
variables like customer number so now
you will be familiar with the customer
number pin number which i just described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes where you have a
savings account class and a checking
account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class i'm initializing a scanner input
which will be used at multiple places
and then i have the setup getters for
these four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number if you
remember this set customer number was
called in the option menu class if i go
back to the get login
once we ask the customer to enter the
customer number
we call the set customer number which
gets called here
similarly
we call the setpin number
which gets called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values using the
getcustomer number and the getpin number
and that has that is also defined here
in terms of the getters
get pin number and get customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance
member
variables we do not have the setters for
them because they are not technically
setters but we have to calculate the
balance it's not a simple setter where
you can just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods
which are specifically when the customer
is trying to withdraw the money from
their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods so we will
come to that let's just understand that
we have two methods for calculating the
drivable amount or executing the
withdraw transaction for the checking
account account and the savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account
and then we get the the bigger methods
which are using these calculation
methods so i define four calculation
methods so far
calc checking withdraw calc saving
withdraw
calc checking deposit and calc saving
deposit basically withdrawing and
deposit for both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called get checking withdraw
input
and get saving withdraw input
get checking deposit input and get
saving deposit input
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember
if you go back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option two which was withdraw
funds or option three which was deposit
funds
then the corresponding methods which
were being called were get checking
withdraw input
and get checking deposit input
and this is the exact same method get
checking withdraw input
and
get checking deposit input
so if you see what is happening inside
this particular method is couple of
sysouts
then we
take the scanner input amount and we
convert that amount to the double
after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not and i'm running this
condition to check that
if the amount is smaller than the
checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here
remember i told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here i'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance and
then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500 you subtract 500 from
thousand and then you send back the
remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was
depositing funds to the checking account
then get checking deposit input gets
called
and it is defined right here
get checking deposit input and here
instead of subtraction
we are doing the addition
so here i'm again doing a condition
check that the current balance plus the
new amount which has been supplied by
the customer from the command line
the total sum of it should be greater
than zero
what if the customer entered an amount
minus 5000 i should not allow that
so that's
the reason i'm putting this condition in
place and if the current balance plus
the new amount which is supposed to be
deposited to the account the sum of it
is greater than zero then call the calc
checking deposit method
and this is where the calc checking
deposit method is present and where i'm
just doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the new balance
that's all which is being done here
and you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well if you look at
the get saving withdraw input which is
used to withdraw money from the savings
account so i take the input from the
command line and i run a condition check
that the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw
should be less than the current saving
accounts balance
if yes then call calc saving withdraw
method
which is defined here where i subtract
the
amount from the current balance and i
return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the get saving
deposit where we add the money instead
of subtracting the money
and this is all what is defined in the
account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account class and
now we have the atm class which is the
entry point which basically initializes
the option menu class and calls the get
login method
remember get login was the first method
which asked you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then call the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or exit
so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application so let's run this
application
so i just ran this application and let
me bring the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu class
and i will
pick up one of the customer number which
i have hard coded here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter
then it asks me for the pin number
so remember you have to provide the
correct pin number corresponding to the
customer number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then
this whole code got executed
and then it called the get account type
and the get account type method provided
you with these options which you see
here on the screen so based on what you
select the case block will get executed
and let's say i want to go for a
checking account so i press 1
and i hit enter
once you select the checking account the
case one gets selected and it calls the
get checking method
and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu view
withdraw or deposit or exit
so let's say i want to deposit fonts so
i press 3
and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0
and enter the amount you want to deposit
let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit enter
you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account
now let's try to withdraw something from
the ticking account so you again get
back the same option because inside the
get checking method
we call the once we have successfully
done the business operation we again
call the
account type method to display the menu
again to the user
so let's see again select the checking
account class
and this time i want to withdraw the
funds remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2 as the choice
current balance is 500 and it's asking
me the amount you want to withdraw from
the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit enter
when i do that the new checking account
balance becomes 400 so the 100 got
subtracted from the 500 and the new
balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well
and let's also run a
negative condition so i again select the
checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds i
choose the option to
current balance is 400 and i i would
like to withdraw a thousand
what happens
if you do that we get a message saying
balance cannot be negative and this is
coming from the calc checking method
which which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here
this condition was checked so the
checking balance was
and the amount i wanted to withdraw was
1000 so 400 minus thousand is not
greater than equal to zero so it jumped
into the else block and it said balance
cannot be negative
so this is how you can also build some
error conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have a
lot of bugs
we can also exit the application so if
you just type three
and hit enter
you will exit from the application and
will again call the login method where
it will again ask you to enter the
customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show how you
can use the different object-oriented
concepts like classes objects methods
setters getters switch case etc to build
the application with the correct
business logic and this is all i want to
cover in this particular session and in
the next session we are going to have a
look at another interesting core java
project just to build our understanding
more better about the core java concept
let's get started with walking through a
core java project using all the
different oops concept we have learned
so far
so in this example
we are going to have a look at a
calculator application and this
calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition
subtraction
multiplication and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs and whatever the
user inputs in terms of the expression
let's say the user entered 4 plus 5 or
whatever that whole expression gets sent
back into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers or
operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays and here i'm
providing the split expression that's
split at every time you encounter one of
these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4
5 3 and 2
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created this string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this link list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now
and then i'm using the poll method
if you remember the poll method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the
whole method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop
on the numbers q and i'm going to run
this
particular loop till this particular
queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do this exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it so
in this case plus will be picked up and
will be stored in this variable called
opr
and then i'm going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors for
multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operate interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a weararg array this is
called a arc expression this means that
this numbers will be an array of
arbitrary length it can be a one element
array it can be a two element array it
can be a four element area or whatever
you supply
but it is still going to be a fixed
length array but the length is going to
be dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operator interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other operate
classes so if i go to the subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this interface
reference so i'm using the concept of
dynamic binding which we talked about
when we talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object
to an interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue
remember we already did one poll here
so
as for this example 4 was here in this
res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum 4 and 5. this
rest is holding 4 right now
based on what i described here numbers
dot poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically
basically 5 here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number queue is now empty
no it is still not empty because we
still have three n2
left there
so
again it does the operations.poll and it
picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers dot poll is
going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9
4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate dot get result the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls the queue of the
operations where the expression divide
is present there which is the only
element left in this particular
operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers dot poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this time since the operate object refer
object operate reference type was of
divide class type so when we call
operate.getresult
the divide operation or the get result
method of the divide class
basically this method will get invoked
and
it will divide the current value of
result which was
4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers dot pole it is going to execute
27 by 2 and whatever value it gets it is
going to store a value back into the
rest variable and then it is again going
to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
star 3
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step we
pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we
fetch the next value in the numbers q
and then we call the get result based on
the expression and whatever result we
get from the get result we store it back
into the rest variable so we keep
updating the rest variable at every step
so that's the reason the result of 4
plus 5 gets stored in the rest and next
time you are calling the get result for
a multiply operation here the rest value
is 9 now and it says 9 into 3 again in
the next time the rest value will be
updated to 27 because we are storing the
result back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc
also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts
so that's all i want to cover in this
particular session if you like this
video a thumbs up will be massively
appreciated thank you and we'll meet
again in the next session thanks a lot
pikes for being with us and helping us
to learn the fundamentals of core java
hope this session was interesting and
informative
if you have any queries regarding the
topics covered in this session or if you
wish to get the codes executed in this
particular tutorial or if you feel we
missed out something important then
please let us know in the comment
section below our team of experts will
be happy to respond until next time
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you